Okay, was macht denn Daddy aus?
Ja, also mir ist dieser Begriff jetzt immer wieder untergekommen bei Instagram.
Und zwar ist das jetzt so, wie soll man es jetzt richtig einordnen?
Also Daddy ist so ein neues Kompliment, aber es bezieht sich auf so einen gewissen
Typ Mann eigentlich oder bezog sich, früher schien mir auf einen gewissen Typ Mann.
Und inzwischen hat sich das aber sehr erweitert.
Also, äh, Daddy ist, glaube ich, eher so aus der Pornografie heraus, so irgendwie so.
Also, ganz von Anfang, Daddy heißt erst mal Vater.
Heißt erst mal Vater. Und nun ist es ja so, dass man recht früh Vater biologisch sein kann.
Aber diese Kategorie Daddy meinte eigentlich Männer, ich würde mal so tippen,
40, 45 plus, die so einen typischen Mann verkörpern, ja?
Und dann gibt es aber so einen Daddy-Kult jetzt, der vielleicht aus der Pornografie
heraus entstanden ist. Ich habe es nicht nachvollzogen.
Also es gab ja so einen Hype in den letzten Monaten um Pedro Pascal,
der so als der Daddy-Typ gesehen wird.
Also irgendwie ein Mann mit schon ein paar Jahren auf dem Buckel und auch ein paar Spuren im Gesicht,
aber ungeheuer attraktiv für ganz, ganz viele Frauen und Männer und jetzt inzwischen
ist mir aber aufgefallen,
dass wann immer man irgendwelche Fotos anklickt bei Instagram,
das kann auch irgendwie von einem 25-Jährigen oder 22-Jährigen sein,
dann ist immer so als Kompliment darunter Daddy.
Also diese Ausstrahlung, so was weiß Bescheid, weiß wie die Welt läuft,
kann auch zur Not auf mich aufpassen, das scheint jetzt so ein Ding zu sein,
dass man immer Daddy drunter schreibt.
Also.
Du bist auf jeden Fall Vater, das ist so. Ob du Daddy bist, das müsstest du
jetzt mal posten bei Instagram und gucken ob das Kompliment bei dir auch kommt.
Also von einem meiner Kinder werde ich auch Daddy genannt. Allerdings scherzhaft.
Ist so mein Eindruck. Schon durchgehend, regelmäßig, pausenlos,
bei jeder Gelegenheit, aber scherzhaft.
Das hat ja eine erotische Komponente.
Ja, darauf wollte ich gerade zurückkommen. Warte, ich trinke erst einen Schluck.
Wir steigen ja gleich schon in ganz tiefe Themen hier ein.
Genau, denn ich glaube, diese Kategorie des anschmachtenden Daddy-Rufs kann
jeder nachvollziehen oder hat es schon mal gesehen.
Meine Vermutung, jetzt so spontan, es geht ja sehr viel durcheinander,
was die Generation angeht. Also wir haben nicht nur Jugendkultur oder nicht
mehr, sondern jetzt auch diese Juvenilisierung, also man ist 40,
lebt aber wieder wie 20 und so weiter. Also es kommt alles durcheinander.
Und mein Eindruck ist, in diesen Filmen wird das immer bewusst eingesetzt,
um vorzuspielen, dass es eigentlich um das Gefühl der Frau geht,
die damit diesen, ja, Daddy ...
Und damit spricht sie sozusagen aus, diesen ...
Ihre eine Generation höher zu meinen. Aber sie adressiert ja jemanden in ihrem Alter.
Mhm. so ein Daddy, aber in cool, Daddy, aber in sexy, also jemand,
der sich um mich kümmert, aber eigentlich kein Daddy ist.
Also so eine Verdrehung, der ja eigentlich ist schon so ein Rollenspiel.
Das ist ja das, was Petro Pascal verkörpert. Also er ist dann doch nicht wie
der Vater, den man so üblich hat, aber so ein Daddy, den man vielleicht gerne haben möchte.
Genau. Und wir haben ja gerade sehr viel, wie soll man sagen, Neo-Freud.
Das Kind in muss Heimat finden, weil wenn du auf dein eigenes vergangenes Kind
zu sprechen kommst, spielen ja nur die Eltern als Bezugsperson eine Rolle.
Also ganz schnell ist man wieder bei den Eltern und so weiter und so fort.
Und da hat das natürlich gewisse Konjunktur. Kann man richtig vorstellen,
wie, das sag ich jetzt so ein bisschen, es ist aber auch 10 Uhr morgens,
Also bitte Nachsicht, aber es kommt ja jetzt. Naja, Frauen, die...
Ihren Vater in der Hinsicht aussortiert haben, dass sie nicht mehr mit den Füßen
unter seinem Tisch leben. Ja.
Splitten das auf in ihren Liebes- und Lebensbeziehungen und den Therapeuten.
Das ist eine sehr interessante These. Zugleich haben wir das Pendant dazu,
dass die ältere Frau für jüngere Männer immer interessanter wird.
Und da kann man ja diese Aufspaltung dann auch machen, dass man dann wohl sagt,
da wird also die Mutter dann aufgeteilt in weiß ich nicht was.
Aber da ist glaube ich nochmal ein bisschen anders gelagert.
Ich finde auch dieses Phänomen Macron hochinteressant, weil sie nämlich auch
seine Lehrerin war. Also da ist so eine ganz spezielle Mischung.
Bei den Frauen habe ich so den Eindruck, in diesem Daddy-Ausspruch,
also wir spinnen jetzt wirklich frei rum um 10 Uhr morgens, ne.
Der Therapeut versteht einen ja besonders gut. Und der Freund behandelt einen ja besonders gut.
Und der Begriff Daddy macht, klammert beides wieder zusammen.
Aber ich glaube, Daddy, das bezieht sich ja auf Fotos. Also es sind ja gewisse
Fotos, die einen Daddy Kommentar bekommen und gewisse, die keinen Kommentar bekommen.
Ja gut, du bist jetzt noch bei dem Instagram Kommentar.
Ich bin in der Porno-Semantik. Ja genau, aber bei der Pornosemantik geht es
ja um Ästhetik. Also geht es ja um Ästhetiken und das gibt es ja,
also da wird ja ein gewisser Look, den man mit Daddy verkörpert.
Also Pedro Pascal ist Daddy und dann gibt es entsprechende andere Männer, die dazu kommen.
Inzwischen wird es aber, das ist das interessante Phänomen eigentlich daran
nun, so ausgeweitet, dass weiß ich nicht, irgendjemand 24 Jahre ein Foto postet
in Badehose und da steht Daddy drunter.
Ich glaube, da verkörpert sich dieser Wunsch.
Ja, und das ist aber dann wahrscheinlich auch bei den Männern,
dass das auch so ein Look ist, dem man wieder entsprechen will.
Und dann gibt es natürlich noch in der schwulen Szene auch nochmal den Daddy-Look.
Also ich glaube, das zeigt aber die Konfusion der Generationen.
Das ist, glaube ich, jetzt sehr stark spürbar, dass man nicht diese klaren Abgrenzungen
mehr hat und dass damit auch das Daddy-Sein nicht mehr auf eine gewisse Generation bezogen ist,
sondern man kann mit 24 Jahren Daddy sein, also im Sinne dieses Begriffs,
wie er da verwendet wird.
Und kann aber zugleich auch 45 sein und kein Daddy-Typus verkörpern.
Ja, ein Gedanke haben wir noch.
Auch mehr Instagram als Porno. Aber es gibt auch sehr viele Zelebrierungen von
... Es sind Kindermann-Masch.
Und das ist ja vor allem die Gender-Reveal-Party. Ja, so.
Und es gibt auch einen kleineren Trend, der kam mir zuletzt weniger unter,
aber dann früher doch ein bisschen, also so vor ein paar Jahren,
vielleicht auch, weil es mich dabei betroffen hat oder wie auch immer,
aber man filmt den jeweiligen Partner dabei, wie er reagiert,
wenn man ihn das erste Mal Mami oder Daddy nennt, weil ein Kind im Anmarsch ist.
Also wenn die Beziehung semantisch umschlägt auf Mami, also man geht so durch
Ikea, ja, und dann wie wäre das Bett?
Das finde ich eigentlich gut, Mami. Also irgendwie so, dass man das dann schon
mal so semantisch vorbereitet und sich dann das Grinsen oder überschwängliche Freude abholt.
Wird da noch ironisch gemacht, aber ich beobachte das natürlich in den Cafés,
in denen ich so sitze, wo man noch Torten sowas bekommt.
Da spricht man sich ja als Ehepaar einfach mit Mutti und Vati an,
was ich sehr eigenartig finde, aber ich gucke es mir mit Amüsement an.
Apropos Generationenfragen, wir lesen kurz aus einem, wie soll man sagen,
handgeschriebenen Audiokommentar ist es, wir würden sagen ein Leserbrief von
Danny, den hat er uns extra nochmal geschickt.
Lieber Stefan, lieber Wolfgang, Thema Husten in der Oper.
Danny hat nämlich Erfahrung und ich habe mich jetzt gerade selbst schon geräuspert,
weil es überträgt sich schon.
Ja, ja, ja, das ist ja meine These, dass das reine Kopfsorge ist,
aber jetzt kommt hier einer an.
Genau, einer fängt an zu husten und dann fangen alle an.
Also, Bluthochdruck-Tabletten können zu Reizhusten führen, müssen es aber nicht,
wenn man vom Arzt richtig eingestellt wurde.
Aha.
Richtig eingestellt werden ist ja ganz häufig ein Problem. Wir hätten ja zum
Beispiel mit Diabetes gar nicht so ein großes Problem,
wenn, naja, insbesondere so mittelalte Boomer-Männer nicht immer noch,
Ach ne, ich schaff das allein, ich piks mir weiterhin den Finger,
wie alle anderen in der Familie, die betroffen sind, einfach so ein Ding an den Arm machen können.
Obwohl die sich längst...
Aber nein, man klebt an der alten Technik. Jedenfalls seine Zahl,
mehr als 30 Prozent aller alten Menschen nimmt Bluthochdrucktabletten und er
fügt noch mal an, fast 100 Prozent aller Operngänger sind alte Menschen.
Das Alte also hier als ganz wichtige Kategorie der Entschuldigung und ja,
man kann sich da richtig einstellen und das ist seine Lösungsidee,
der nochmal unterstreicht.
Einfach nochmal zum Arzt gehen und sagen, Medikamente sind schon ganz cool,
aber nochmal nachjustieren, denn man kann diesen Reizhusten vermeiden.
Mir sind diese Zahlen unbekannt gewesen, Bluthochdruck ist aber ein Phänomen
und wir haben ja jetzt auch gerade diese Debatte, wer geht eigentlich zum Arzt,
Also wer blockiert eigentlich die Wartezimmer?
Und ich würde sagen, er merkt es. Also Populismus immer gern gesehen.
Ich finde es auch ganz amüsant. Aber üblicherweise ist der Arzt und seine Angestellten
sind die Ausländer, die hier arbeiten und das Wartezimmer ist voller deutscher Omas und Opas.
Ja, was ja in der Natur der Sache auch liegt. Absolut, klar.
Das ist ja logisch. Vielleicht wäre das eine Maßnahme noch für die Opernhäuser,
jetzt immer statt Einführungsvorträgen oder zusätzlich zu Einführungsvorträgen
noch solche medizinischen Einführungen zu geben.
Jetzt, wo du sagst, genau das steht hier auch, seine Empfehlung.
Es könnte vor jeder Operaufführung doch zunächst ein Facharzt über die Nebenwirkungen
der Medikamente, die die richtigen sind, aber falsch eingestellt und dann führen
sie zu Nebenwirkungen. Und das könnte helfen.
Also ich wäre sehr dabei für so eine Operntour mit einem Facharzt zusammen überall.
Wir haben jetzt auch die Diskussion, Karl Lauterbach findet ja,
wir brauchen nicht so viele Kliniken, weil, Zitat, sie füllen sich nicht mehr.
Und er meinte dann Patienten und Personal. Und ich mir denke,
komm, es kommt jetzt gerade mal der 58er Jahrgang in die Altersgruppe.
Warte doch mal den 64er Jahrgang nochmal ab, bevor du eine Entscheidung triffst,
strukturell, die uns wieder den Kopf kosten.
Aber die Apotheken haben ja dasselbe Problem, Nachwuchssorgen.
Apotheken sollen so seinen Plan jetzt Filialen aufmachen dürfen,
sodass klar ist, okay, das ist ja nur so eine Ecke im Rewe, aber da kann man
Medikamente ausgeben und grundlegende Sachen machen.
Es muss kein Apotheker anwesend sein, es kann auch die Assistenz,
aber unter der Bedingung, wie Lauterbach formulierte explizit,
es muss aber eine digitale Direktverbindung zur Hauptfiliale geben.
Wo ich mir wieder dachte, was ist das für eine Denke? Klar gibt es eine digitale
Direktverbindung. Die haben alle Smartphones in der Tasche und so weiter.
Wenn jemand eine Frage hat, ruft er an.
Also was ist das jetzt für eine Hürde? Jetzt macht er wieder extra ein Glasfasernetz.
Jetzt schreiben die wieder sieben Seiten Bürokratie dazu, das ist eine digitale
Direktverbindung zur Hauptfiliale.
Und ich denke schon wieder, nee, das ist schon wieder dieses Geld.
Irgendwer hat denen schon wieder eingeredet, sie brauchen da Beratung und Planung,
um Telefonate zu organisieren. Und deswegen dauert das wieder zehn Jahre länger jetzt.
Ja, super.
Es ist absurd.
Opa ist aber ein gutes Stichwort. Ich würde gerne auf eine Veranstaltung hinweisen.
Am 16. November bin ich im Staatstheater Wiesbaden.
Und spreche dort mit dem Chefdramaturk Konstantin Mende über folgendes Thema,
wie politisch ist die Oper? Wir werden uns vor allem um drei Opern konzentrieren,
unter anderem Lohengrin.
Und man muss aber nicht jetzt Opernkenner sein, um dem beizuwohnen,
sondern es soll schon so sein, dass man vielleicht auch Lust dadurch bekommt auf die Oper.
Wir werden auch ein paar Passagen einspielen aus Opern und werden darüber sprechen.
Tickets gibt es beim Staatstheater Wiesbaden auf der Homepage.
Und mehr muss man gar nicht mehr sagen, denn man hat ja Google und kann das
alles finden. Man braucht also jetzt keine digitale Infrastruktur aufbauen.
So eine Foyer-Veranstaltung oder seid ihr da auf der Großstätte?
Wir sind im kleinen Haus, also die Plätze sind begrenzt, aber ja,
der Verkauf hat gerade erst begonnen und hier ist quasi die erste Veröffentlichung
dieses Gingens. Sehr gut.
Mir fiel mal wieder auf, dass ich...
Du hast auch noch eine Veranstaltung.
Ja, ich bin fast nie in Süddeutschland und mit Süddeutschland bin ich alles
südlicher als Frankfurt jetzt.
Ich werde immer überallhin eingeladen, aber ich habe eine angenommen,
die vor allem des Termines wegen interessant ist.
6. Oktober, also nächsten Freitag, zwei Tage vor der Landtagswahl in Hessen und in Bayern.
Also habe ich gesagt, wenn ich in München eingeladen werde, komme ich natürlich
und erzähle denen nochmal, sie wissen alle, wer der Aiwanger ist,
wer der Söder ist, wer hier so zur Wahl steht. Aber wer wählt eigentlich?
Wer sind Sie eigentlich?
Und wie viele? Ja, so lustig.
Und das findet in der VHS Taufkirchen statt.
Taufkirchen ist irgendwie südlicher Stadtteil von München oder so,
keine Ahnung. Also Volkshochschulen, Veranstaltungen.
Es ist ein Raum angeplant, der 60 Leute fasst. Da hab ich gesagt,
gibt's auch einen größeren? Da meinten sie so, ja.
Also wurde auf der Webseite immer geschrieben, wie viele Plätze es noch sind.
Und jetzt freue ich mich schon, dass da steht Warteliste.
Jetzt gerade sind wieder 37 Plätze frei. Also wahrscheinlich wurde er schon
umgelegt und die, es gibt Plätze. Also man kann jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch
37 Plätze buchen. Es ist mal eine Veranstaltung, die Geldkoste 6 Euro, aber gut.
Und da gibt's dann noch mal, keine Ahnung, nachdem es in Hamburg jetzt so harmonisch
zu ging, wollte ich eigentlich zwei Tage vor der Landtagswahl noch mal ein bisschen
alten republikanischen Dampf erzeugen.
Könnte lustig werden. Gut, wir verlinken beide Veranstaltungen mit unter diesem
Podcast. Könnt ihr mal überlegen, ob ihr da kommen wollt.
Tickets ist auch eine gute Überleitung. Wir wurden jetzt mehrmals gefragt,
wie kommt man an Tickets für den Salon.
Der Salon findet jetzt noch einmal im Dezember statt, ist aber schon ausverkauft.
Aber im November die neuen Termine bekannt geben und dann auch wie man an Tickets kommt.
Wir hatten einen schönen Salon in Frankfurt vor wenigen Tagen und haben dort
unter anderem über Familienunternehmenserben gesprochen, die ihre Challenges meistern müssen.
Wir haben Fernsehen gesehen, wir haben Neo Ragazzi uns angesehen,
die neue Sendung mit Sophie Passmann und Tommy Schmitt. Und es ist die reine Hölle.
Und es ist das große Nichts, aber in 45 Minuten jeweils. Und andere Themen haben wir noch aufgegriffen.
Ja, wer also sich dafür interessiert, kann das alles nachhören im Salon.
Und zum Salon haben wir auch heute so ein paar Worte mehr zu sagen.
Also erst mal, wir wissen, wie man den Salon bekommen.
Patreon gibt es, es gibt Apple.
Aber heute geht es vor allem um Steady, wie man da zum Salon kommt.
Das ist ja unterhin unsere präferierte Wahl.
Und ist es eine ganz gute Idee gewesen jetzt, dass man mal überlegt,
wie können sich eigentlich Steady Creator untereinander so ein bisschen auch unterstützen?
Und das machen wir. Also es gibt eine Mini-Kooperation mit den den Crowdreportern.
Wer das nicht kennt, das ist eine crowdfinanzierte Plattform,
auf der jeden Tag ein journalistischer, langer Text erscheint.
Genau, die Crowdreporter waren ja so ein bisschen eigentlich die Vorreitersache auch für Steady,
denn die haben ja damals das so gegründet als, okay, das ist eine Plattform
für Autoren, können sie damals für so einen Standardpreis 500 Euro oder so pro
Text konnten sie publizieren.
Jetzt mittlerweile hat sich wohl so eine Redaktion gefunden,
die so ein bisschen fester angestellt ist, was ich ja auch sehr begrüße und damals auch im Pfahl.
Und Steddy hat, es ist sozusagen dieses ausgelagerte Finanzierungskonzept damals gewesen.
Und jetzt kamen die auf uns zu und fragten so, kann man das nicht irgendwie so kombinieren?
Und ich dachte mir, ja, das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee,
denn Podcast-Landschaftspflege war ja immer so zweitrangig, hat eine große Rolle
mitgespielt, auch auf einem Podcast und überhaupt so.
Der Salon ist ja ein Angebot für Leute, die Texte mögen. Wir lesen ja nur Texte.
Wir spielen ja nie einen Clip oder so. Wir lesen einfach und besprechen Texte.
Und Krautreporter schreibt eben Texte.
Ja.
Die kann man sich zwar von denen auch direkt vorlesen lassen,
also eins zu eins, ohne weitere Vorlesung.
Wir lesen sie ja nicht vor die Texte, sondern wir reden ja vor allem darüber.
Wir machen ja so eine Textbesprechung. Ich dachte, das ergänzt sich wirklich gut.
Jetzt gibt's das einfach als Kombi, also die Krautreporter man es gemeinsam
bucht, die jeweils ein bisschen billiger bekommen.
Aber man muss dann eben beide buchen für den Fall. Ansonsten ändert sich nichts.
Die drei Pakete, die wir seit Anfang an haben, sind sie genau so.
Und hier kann man glaube ich 50 Cent oder wie viel genau, kann man nachschauen. Kann man sparen.
Das mag sich für Leute lohnen, die beides kennenlernen wollen.
Das ist einfach 20 Prozent billiger, als wenn man es einzeln bucht.
Ah ja, okay. Das ist 20 Prozent billiger, beides zusammen. Man kann es buchen,
indem man auf unsere Steady-Seite geht.
Die kann man sich direkt aufrufen oder man kann das über unsere Homepage neue20er.de,
machen. Und da gibt es ein viertes Paket.
Und dieses vierte Paket ist das mit Crowdreporting zusammen.
Also wer Interesse hat, beides zu abonnieren, beides zu unterstützen,
kann das auch auf diesem Wege dann tun.
So ist es. Und hier wirklich noch mal eine ausführliche,
eindrückliche, impressionistische Einladung in den Salon,
denn mir ist es jetzt in Frankfurt wieder aufgefallen, ich habe ja dir diesmal
so ein bisschen die Freude überlassen,
mit den Hörern im Foyer und so weiter rumzuhängen und habe das so aus der Peripherie
mir einfach angeschaut und habe wieder festgestellt, das ist eigentlich cool.
Es ist eine Veranstaltung, bei der, wenn man den Saal betritt,
weiß, alle hier hören den gleichen Podcast wie ich. Und er ist auch allen genauso
wichtig, denn wir verkaufen ja die Karten zuallererst mal an Sanon-Mitglieder.
Die kriegen die Information zuerst. Was bedeutet, alle sitzen da und hören den
gleichen Podcast und er ist ihnen sogar geldwert. Und darüber hinaus lernen
sich aber dann so Leute kennen, die dann so wissen, okay, die Wellenlänge stimmt.
Und das ist irgendwie ganz gut.
Ja, wir wechseln ja so, dass wir mehr Wochenendtermine haben,
das heißt, da kann man das den Abend dann auch noch länger ausklingen lassen.
Man kann ja auch in Frankfurt noch weggehen.
Wir denken auch darüber nach, ob wir es sogar mal kombinieren können,
dass wir einen Tag davor oder Tag danach in die Oper gehen und dann sagen,
wer möchte, also nicht, dass wir jetzt hier ein Ticketing mit der Oper anbieten,
das wird ein bisschen komplex.
Wir gehen in die Oper, wer sich vielleicht anschließen will,
Wir sind dann vorher und im Foyer zu treffen und in der Pause und so weiter.
Wir gucken mal, ob wir das machen.
Also wir sagen einfach, in welche Opern wir gehen. Es ist so,
dass wir drei der vier Termine sind Samstag oder Freitag und wir planen einen
fünften Termin. Dazu noch Infos. Der ist auch an einem Wochenende.
Ach, sehr gut.
Wenn wir einen Operntermin damit verknüpfen, bedeutet das für alle,
die interessiert sind, man muss nicht zwingend mit in die Oper kommen,
sondern man kann auch abends sich noch einen Döner holen oder so,
dann aber vor der Oper stehen,
weil die wird ja akustisch nach draußen übertragen, auf dem Willy-Brandt-Platz,
man bekommt dann also mit, ah ja, gerade die letzten Lieder,
wie auch immer, der Applaus, jetzt kommen sie gleich raus, also irgendwie so, das lässt sich sehr gut.
Man kann sich da begegnen mit anderen Worten. Und wo wir jetzt so viel schon
über uns reden, dann gestatte mir noch, dass ich noch eine Minute über ein neues Buch lese.
Dieses Buch, das ich zweimal habe. Ich hab's mir bestellt und du hast es mir
schicken lassen. Jetzt habe ich fünf Kilo Buch zu Hause.
Also, ich habe ein Buch herausgegeben mit Seidelman & Company.
Das Buch heißt Die Filmanalyse Kino anders gedacht.
Und es enthält 120 Filmanalysen, die in den vergangenen elf Jahren,
zwölf Jahren erschienen sind, also ein Best-of Filmanalyse in Kapitel unterteilt,
deutscher Film, neues Hollywood, altes Hollywood, etc.
120 von? Wie viel gäbe es?
Von 650.
Also ungefähr so ein Fünftel.
Ja.
Weil das ist wirklich sehr dick, das Buch. 720 Seiten, das ist schwierig.
Genau, ich hab mir dann auch gedacht, ey, wenn das jetzt alle,
das ist ja auch materialmäßig,
das mal so verdeutlicht zu sehen, man textet halt so vor sich hin,
aber mal den Mediensprung zu machen und plötzlich… Ja, ich hatte auch,
als ich da angefragt wurde von dem Verleger, ob ich sowas machen will,
er findet das eigentlich eine gute Idee, dachte ich, naja, wie viel Seiten werden
das sein, es soll ja nicht zu kurz sein.
Und dann waren wir natürlich dann bei so einem Riesenwerk und wir wollten es
aber dann auch nicht verkleinern. Und man dachte, dann ist es halt so.
Es gibt noch ein ausführliches Interview mit mir.
Ein paar sehr schöne Fotos sind gemacht worden von mir.
Ja, es ist wie so ein Instagram-Fotostream irgendwie. Text, Text,
Text, Bild, Bild, Text, Text, Text, Text, Bild.
Wir waren in, naja so viel sind es ja nicht, zwölf oder so, wir waren in Düsseldorf
im Filmmuseum und im Kino und haben das dort gemacht. Und worauf ich besonders
stolz bin, dass Dominik Graf, der wunderbare Filmregisseur, tatsächlich ein
Vorwort geschrieben hat.
Verweise auf Anzüge.
Jetzt muss ich sagen, dieses Buch, aber, und das wird jetzt manche verschrecken
und hat auch schon manche verschreckt, kann man fast nur über Amazon kaufen.
Also man kann das versuchen über den Buchhandel zu machen, dann kontaktieren
den Verlag und so. ist dann etwas umständlich und dauert lang und so.
Aber wer das machen möchte, kann das so machen. Aber dann wurden mir z.T.
Sinistere Absichten zugeschrieben, dass ich bei Amazon bin. Nun,
dieses Buch wird von Amazon gedruckt, denn man kann sich ja denken,
das ist jetzt nicht ein Buch, das sich 10.000 Mal verkauft und überall in den
Buchhandlungen herumliegt.
Sondern das ist ein Buch, das sich an Leute richtet, die mich wahrscheinlich
schon kennen. Oder die sagen, ich kenne den und ich würde das aber eigentlich
mal gerne jemandem verschenken, der nicht bei YouTube ist und vielleicht lieber
die Sachen lesen will oder was auch immer.
Und dieses Buch, wenn das jetzt ein Verlag selbst drucken müsste.
Dann könnten die das überhaupt nicht stemmen. Also so ein kleiner Verlag.
Das ist ein Verlag von zwei Leuten, also ein Paar, Mann und Frau, in Düsseldorf.
Die machen ganz viele englischsprachige Bücher. Die können natürlich von Düsseldorf
aus nicht den amerikanischen Markt eigentlich bedienen.
Amazon aber macht das über dieses Print-Modell, die haben ja Print-Presse,
die haben ja Drucker-Pressen überall, stehen in aller Welt, möglich.
Dass die in Düsseldorf ein Buch rausgeben und dann kannst du in Japan und Amerika
das Buch bestellen und innerhalb von 48 Stunden ist es da.
Also es wird on demand gedruckt und das ist natürlich für solche Nischen Verlage
besonders gut und für so ein Buch wie hier dieses meine auch.
Und da gibt es bei manchen immer so diese Vorstellungen, naja die Verlage reißen,
würden sich doch um dich reißen, die würden sowas machen, dann würde ich sagen,
nee, das ist gar nicht so wie man sich das vorstellt.
Und ich kann auch sagen, dass man sogar jetzt über dieses Modell als Autor tatsächlich
etwas mehr davon hat, als über den klassischen Verlag.
Und ich ja auch noch mal sagen würde.
Ich bin ja jemand, der noch fast alle Bücher im lokalen Buchhandel kauft und
das sind ein paar hundert Euro im Monat.
Ich sag mal, wenn alle so viele Bücher wie ich im Hochhandel kaufen würden,
dann hätten wir nur noch Buchhandlungen in Deutschland. Also du bist ja ohnehin
schon jemand, der mich immer dann anguckt, ein bisschen die Augen verdreht.
Es gibt natürlich ganz tolle Buchhandlungen mit einem unglaublichen Sortiment
noch, aber das sind, sagen wir, zehn Prozent der Buchhandlungen.
Der Rest der Buchhandlungen, da findest du weder unser Influencer-Buch,
noch dein Altenrepublik-Buch und mein Buch würde da in 100 Jahren nicht reinkommen,
jetzt das Film-Analyse-Buch, weil das einfach, ja die haben halt 70 mal Fizek da,
50 mal Passmann und 30 mal irgendjemand anders,
der noch ein Buch vollgeschrieben hat und ich kann die Bücher,
also ich, mein Kauf in lokalen Buchhandel,
Wenn ich nicht gerade in Berlin oder in Heidelberg oder sonst wo wäre,
ja, sieht ja so aus, dass ich anrufe, bei Amazon das Buch rausgesucht habe,
anrufe, das bestelle und dann hole ich das im lokalen Buchhandel ab.
Das heißt, fast alle Bücher, die ich kaufen möchte, kann ich nicht zum Beispiel in Koblenz kaufen.
Ich würde in Zweifel ziehen, dass ich in Koblenz und in einem Radius von 80
Kilometer, naja, oder sagen wir 60 Kilometer, bin ich ja schon fast in Bonn,
zum Beispiel ein Buch von Niklas Luhmann jetzt ad hoc kaufen könnte. Es ist unmöglich.
Ja, ich will das unterstreichen oder schon noch mal ein bisschen aggressiver sagen.
Amazon, genau wie Apple, da geht es ja nicht ums iPhone oder so,
sondern um diese ganze Mega-Logistik es überhaupt hinzukriegen.
Ja. Also ein Prototypen in Serie herzustellen, weil den Prototypen an sich schafft
irgendwie jeder so, aber den könnte sich dann keiner leisten.
Und Amazon hat für uns wirklich die Welt erschlossen. Wir kaufen Sachen in Shenzhen,
ohne dass wir feststellen, dass die überhaupt daherkommen.
Sondern die Alternative wäre, okay, irgendwo eine Webseite mit drei Farben,
die 1995 programmiert wurde, würde irgendwas anbieten und wir müssten es dann
auf chinesisch übersetzen, was wir suchen und dann eine E-Mail schreiben und
den sagen und dann irgendwie Bargeld da hinschicken, wie auch immer.
Also es ist alles wahnsinnig kompliziert und Amazon hat das für uns einfach
runtergebrochen, dabei auch den Rechtsstaat in jegliche Richtung einmal umgebogen
und an den Rändern ausgefranst.
Das ist aber auch wieder eine Frage der Politik.
Das ist dann wieder eine Frage der Politik, genau.
Das müsste ja alles nicht so sein.
Und bisher dachte ich eben auch, oder lange dachte ich, okay,
die machen alles für mich als Kunden.
Also ich schreibe einfach, was ich will und bis es bei mir zu Hause ist,
übernimmt Amazon die Verantwortung dafür, dass es bei mir zu Hause landet,
wenn es da Postbote mir gegeben hat, ab dann ist es meins und solange es nicht
bei mir ist, muss ich einfach nur Bescheid sagen und die kümmern sich um alles.
Weil da gibt es nämlich dann Leute, die sprechen Chinesisch und die halten Kontakt
und so weiter und die wissen, wie es läuft. So und dann bin ich auf die Buchmesse
gegangen, als ich die Altenrepublik noch unter dem Namen Rentenrepublik so auf
eigene Faust machen wollte. Also vor Corona an dem ganzen Kram.
Und bin zu dem Amazon-Stand gegangen.
Und ich bin fast aus allen Wolken gefallen. Du hast diese kleinen Stände mit
Pipapo und hier die Bücher und kaum sehen doch mal dieses. Und dann kommst du
zu Amazon und es ist komplett umgedreht. Du wirst als Autor angesprochen.
Also das ist sozusagen einer der ganz wenigen Stände, wo du feststellst, das ist eine Fachmesse.
Hier kommt man nicht nur als Leser hin, sondern und so weiter.
Und dann hast du dieses komplette Angebot, die zeigen dir, in welchen Formaten
sie drucken. Du kannst das alles einmal durchfühlen.
Du kannst dir die Cover angucken, da wird nämlich nicht nur gedruckt,
sondern auch geprägt. Du kannst dir also das, was du bildlich darstellst,
nochmal die Blume, so dass man sie erfüllen kann und so weiter.
Also da wird einfach von vorne bis hinten, bei anderen Verlagen nicht sieht
und dort bei Amazon ist das einfach im Angebot im Sinne von schick uns dein
PDF, das ist das, was du dann bekommst.
Und da habe ich gedacht, das ist schon krasser Service insgesamt,
auch weil die Druckkosten schon nennenswert, aber im Vergleich zu,
na ich mache ein Buch bei einem Verlag und werde dann mit zehn Prozent beteiligt.
Das Einzige, was Amazon nicht macht, ist der Vorschuss und da wird es interessant.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht,
Denn wenn du ein Autor bist, der schon mal in Vorleistung gegangen ist,
im Sinne von hat schon mal gezeigt, dass er ein Buch verkauft hat und so weiter,
dann kommen natürlich die Verlager auf uns, also da sage ich dann auch uns zu
und sagen, euch kann man ruhig mal Vorschuss zahlen.
Also wenn du jetzt eine Versteigerung machst von einem Buchprojekt oder ich,
dann ist klar, irgendein Verlag springt schon drauf an und dann wird auch, ja, es ist schon knapp.
Ich will hier nicht in die Details reingehen, ja. Also Vorschuss, ja.
Aber wir gehen nicht raus mit, sagen wir mal.
Ich kann auf jeden Fall sagen, dieses Filmanalysebuch hätte natürlich niemals
einen Vorschuss und auch keinen Verlag gefunden.
Außer einen ganz kleinen, speziellen Verlag, bei dem ich aber wahrscheinlich
hätte selbst erst mal 3.000 Euro zahlen müssen, damit der kein Risiko hat.
Das ist ja die Sache. Und es gibt ja ganz viele Bücher, die,
also die meisten Bücher verkaufen sich ja nicht oder 200 mal.
Das heißt, da geht es natürlich über so ein System wie Amazon das herstellt,
gibt es da gute Möglichkeiten.
Und es ist keineswegs so, als müsse man das jetzt so unglaublich verklären mit
dem, mit den Verlagen, die auch alle Geschäftsinteresse haben und feilschen noch und gleicher.
Ja, ich wollte es mal noch so ein bisschen.
Und auch mit den Buchhandlungen. Wir haben, die meisten sind irgendwelche Buchhandlungsketten.
Ich weiß nicht, wo der Unterschied ist, ob ich jetzt bei Amazon oder bei Talia
ein Buch kaufe. Da sehe ich jetzt keinen Wert.
Also das ist eine Kette, die andere Kette. Amazon hat Buchläden,
Talia verkauft im Internet. Also das ist alles das gleiche und da ist auch das
gleiche Preisdrück-Ding dahinter und so, dass da irgendwie Werbeplätze pro Zentimeter
nochmal extra vermarktet werden und wie auch immer.
Bei den Verlagen jedenfalls, die Erfahrung, die du jetzt gemacht hast,
dass nämlich zwei Leute sich hinsetzen und sich dann einfach mal ein Projekt
vornehmen und das monatlang hübsch machen. Ja, dass sie einfach wissen...
Da sind YouTube-Videos und das Ziel ist 700 Seiten. Ja.
So, das ist ja ein Weg, das macht ja Arbeit. In dem Fall hat man YouTube-Videos,
die kann man dann transkribieren usw.
Üblicherweise kommen ja einfach Leute mit einer Idee, also jetzt im Sachbuch.
Die Romane müssen eigentlich schon fertig geschrieben sein, was ich auch schräg
finde, aber gut, Sachbuch, da wo wir uns auskennen.
Nee, die Romane sind nicht fertig geschrieben. Also, was ich weiß, nee, nee.
Na gut, dann scheinst du wieder Antworten zu nennen, die die Einflugschneise haben.
Definitiv nicht so.
Bei den Sachbüchern ist es ja so, üblicherweise ist das genau das Prinzip,
du kommst hin und sagst, das ist meine Idee, ich kann sie aber nur umsetzen mit eurer Hilfe.
Und ich finde, die Verlage haben nach dem, was ich so gehört habe,
noch nicht die richtige Einflugschneise gefunden, zu sagen, wir machen das,
was wir können und nutzen darüber hinaus synergetische Effekte,
auch wenn es der Feind erledigt.
Denn ich denke, ein Verlag, der selber druckt, der sich also damit rumschlägt,
dass in Norwegen irgendwie eine Papierfabrik auf Verpackung um und deswegen
kein Druckmaterial mehr da ist oder so.
Ja, das ist durchaus eine Sache, die den Büchermarkt und so weiter und so fort,
aber ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das noch zeitgemäß ist,
dass sich die Verlage damit alleine rumschlagen oder ob man nicht,
und jetzt wäre die Frage, wie das dann juristisch und politisch zu organisieren ist.
Amazon kommt natürlich wie YouTube einfach her und sagt, das ist unsere Mediathek.
Und dann kommen die Öffis und sagen, wir würden gerne mal ARD und CDF zusammenlegen.
Dann sagt das Kartellrecht, ne, ihr dürft nicht zusammenarbeiten.
Die Zeitungen durften auch bei ihrem Anzeigengeschäft nicht zusammenarbeiten
und die Verlage dürfen wahrscheinlich auch bei den Drucksachen nicht zusammenarbeiten,
sondern man mietet sich dann so ein in diese Druckereien und rangiert dann so.
Die drucken ja auch nicht selbst im eigenen Haus, sondern auch wieder woanders.
Und da, denke ich, fehlt noch irgendwie so eine neue Idee,
so eine neue synergetische Mega-Orga als Verband,
als was auch immer, dass man diese Materialschlacht mal aus dem Produktionsprozess
so rausnimmt für die Verlage, damit die mehr Kopf dafür haben,
sich mit den Autoren und den Ideen und den Vorschlüssen und den ökonomischen
Kalkulationen zu beschäftigen.
Ja, ja, das ist ja eigentlich das, warum man bei einem Verlage ist,
dass man dadurch vielleicht Publicity bekommt, in den Buchhandel reinkommt.
Also das kann man ja dann auch über andere Bücher, populäre Bücher oder so schaffen.
Stattdessen werden die so von Papierkrisen in die Knie gezogen.
Ich sehe aber natürlich auch diesen Interessenkonflikt. Also de facto ist es
ja auch so, dass Amazon, wenn ein Buch jetzt mal so einen Tag gut läuft,
aufgrund eines Spiegel Online Artikels oder sowas, die ganz viel nachordern.
Das heißt, die Verlagen und sonst, und das muss dann in allen Lagern vorhanden
sein, damit die natürlich ihren Kunden immer bestens bedienen können.
Das flacht aber dann vielleicht dieser Hype ab, dann haben die aber viel zu
viel nachgeordert, nur auf den Verdacht hin, dass da irgendwas fehlt und dann
retunieren die das alles und geben das den Verlagen wieder zurück,
was für die Verlage auch natürlich ein enormer Verlust immer bedeutet.
Also die stehen sich konkurrenzhaft gegenüber und eigentlich sind die Autoren werden,
werden irgendwie, ja, also man ist eigentlich in einer marginalen Position als Autor dann doch,
bis auf vielleicht so Stephen King und Co,
die können dann nochmal ganz anders da reingehen, aber man, man sollte überhaupt,
glaube ich, wenn man über Buchhandel, Verlag und alles redet,
erstmal alle Romantik und allen Idealismus erstmal rausnehmen.
Das kann man sich ja dann später noch mal reinsetzen und dann eher ökonomisch
darüber nachdenken, was was bedeutet.
Also ich bin für, letzter Gedanke, ein großes Förderprogramm.
Jedes Kind, das in die fünfte Klasse kommt, muss ein DIN A4 E-Reader geschenkt bekommen.
Bespielbar aus allen Himmelsrichtungen. Dass man sich gleich dran gewöhnt,
das ist mein Lesegerät. Und ab jetzt zählen nur noch die Worte, nur noch die Inhalte.
Und dann strickt man das alles mal darum. Weil du meinst, 700 Seiten und so,
dass der Umschlag so bedruckt ist, dass ich hier aus vier Meter Entfernung 1A
lesen kann. Das ist die Filmanalyse. Und selbst mit 90-jährigen Augen würde
ich das noch lesen können.
Ist doch toll, mit einem schönen Foto von mir drauf. Lob mich doch mal.
Das Foto ist spektakulär gut. Die Farbgestaltung, dein Blick und so, alles perfekt.
Haptische Note, sag sogar ich, das Buch einzeln zu sehen. Nun habe ich aber
zwei. Und schon bei zwei solchen Dingern beginnt immer im Kopf.
Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, tausend solche Bücher. Was das für eine Materialschlacht ist.
Was da jede Nacht, wenn eine Zeitung hergestellt wird, die Zeit,
600.000 Auflage, FHZ, Süddeutsche kommen zusammen auch auf diese 600.000.
Ich kenne dein Argument.
Die Bücher und so.
Ich kenne dein Argument, aber wir wissen auch, diese ganze E-Reader und auch
die Digitalisierung, das ist alles nicht klimaneutral.
Da gibt es gerade sehr viele neue Diskussionen darüber, wie viel Verbrauch wir
da machen. Aber wir könnten für die Umwelt viel tun, wenn einmal jedes zehnjährige
Kind… Ja, dann haben die alle Geräte und diese Geräte werden nach fünf Jahren
wieder weggeworfen und das ist unglaublich viel Elektroschrott.
Und es gibt auch kein Wachstum unbedingt jetzt bei E-Reading.
Ja genau, weil die ja keine Reader haben. Nein, nein, auch in den USA nicht.
Wir haben ja über diesen Markus Dohle gesprochen in Sachen Ungleichheit,
der bei Penguin Random House war.
Und der erzählt auch da über den E-Book-Markt und wo dann auch viele dachten,
ja, jetzt ist das gedruckte Buch zu Ende.
Keineswegs, auch nicht in Amerika, kann man sich im OMR-Podcast alles nochmal anhören.
Deswegen wäre ich da doch sehr skeptisch in diese Richtung zu gehen.
Ein offener Konflikt in diesem Podcast.
Du hast ja zwei Bücher, du kannst eines verschenken, das ist doch toll,
jemandem eine Freude zu machen. Mit einem gedruckten Buch, weil du wirst ja
kein E-Book verschenken können.
Das wäre im Fortlaufenden der Diskussion dann alles zu diskutieren, wie das so geht.
Aber ich finde, man muss erst mal rein in diese neue Gesellschaft,
in der man einfach alle seine Texte, die einen interessieren,
immer, immer dabei hat. Oder haben kann.
Ich kann aber dir Hoffnung machen, Ende Oktober erscheint dieses Buch dann auch als E-Book.
Ah ja.
Da kannst du es dir eigentlich dann noch mal kaufen, wenn du möchtest.
Das werde ich auch. Ich will es ja durchsuchen.
Ja, super.
Du willst ja durchsuchen, mir Markierungen machen, ohne das Buch zu zerstören.
Das sind mir die liebsten Kunden. Wir müssen jetzt über Schlimmes reden.
Es war eigentlich ein furchtbarer Monat. Ich habe immer wieder Nachrichten-Diet
gemacht, weil ich es nicht mehr ausgehalten habe. Ich habe gedacht,
wenn ich noch einmal heute Söder irgendwo sehe oder höre, drehe ich durch.
Aber du hast dich doch noch mal ziemlich reinbegeben.
Also, der Monat startete mit All in Aiwanger, denn diese Story ging ja schon
im August los. dass dann irgendwie...
Das Flugblatt und sein Bruder und die Süddeutsche und man dachte sich so,
man hat sich so, also ihr habt alle Diskussionen verfolgt, wir gehen auf sie
jetzt nicht näher ein, wir spielen nur einen Clip dazu.
Man dachte sich so mittendrin, ah ja der Bruder, okay das sind so Erzählungen,
die kennt jeder aus allen Himmelsrichtungen, es war nicht der Bruder.
Ich glaube, das kann man ziemlich sicher sagen, das ist einfach absurd.
Hubert Aiwanger soll dieses Flugblatt geschrieben haben und dann heißt es aber,
nee, es war der Bruder. Und das ist ja eine interessante familiäre Konstellation.
Du beschäftigst dich ja jetzt in deinem neuen Buch dann mit Familie.
Mit Familie.
Also ich habe ja keinen Bruder, ich bin ja Einzelkind und ich überlege jetzt
gerade, es würde jetzt so etwas Abscheuliches ans Tageslicht gezogen werden
und ich hätte da jemand, sagen kann, mach mal.
Also das ist ja irgendwo bei Shakespeare eigentlich schon angesiedelt.
Es ist wirklich hochinteressant. Wir reden gleich ausführlicher über Thüringen.
Überall spielt Familie irgendwie eine Rolle. Aiwanger nimmt sich seinen Bruder.
Die CDU sagt, wir wollen die Grunderwerbssteuer senken für Familien,
die ein Haus kaufen und so weiter und so fort.
Also überall hast du immer so als unhintergehbare Kulisse,
die ganz illegitim herangezogen wird als Argumentation, Und die Familie,
so als, und das ist ja auch, weshalb ich es schreibe, genau,
weil die Familie kriegst du niemals raus argumentiert aus der Gesellschaft.
Ich verweise immer wieder auf, egal welches Regime, weder im Nationalsozialismus,
noch unter Stalin, noch jetzt bei den Chinesen, hat eine Familienpolitik mal wirklich ...
Es war totalitär, aber es ging nie weit so unter die Bettdicke,
dass man sagte, wir brauchen Frauen als Gebärmaschinen und danach kommen die
sofort in die Kaderschmiede und so weiter und so fort, sondern die Familie ist immer konstant.
Es gibt ein einziges Beispiel, das könntest du dir ansehen, das ist Kambodscha mit der roten Quere.
Und das ist ja so gescheitert wie nichts anderes.
Also das ist ja, also wo dann Kinder auch nochmal beweisen mussten,
wie sehr sie sich aus den familiären Zwängen erlöst haben, indem sie ihre Eltern
öffentlich denunzieren, um dann zu zeigen, sie haben sich gelöst aus dem.
Also da hat man wirklich einmal dieses Experiment gemacht, ginge es komplett ohne Familie.
Also hat das Kind, die das Kind produziert haben, so hat das alles eigentlich
gar nichts miteinander zu tun. Kann man es vollkommen separieren?
Und die Antwort ist nein.
Und sie hat natürlich viele, viele Grausamkeiten produziert.
Und die Antwort ist so deutlich immer nein, dass man es gar nicht verargumentieren
muss, sondern man erwähnt es einfach.
Dann kann jeder selber den Wikipedia-Artikel lesen. Auch das Zölibat,
diese große Erfindung von du brauchst keine Familie, du bist in Beziehung mit Gott allein.
Wir sehen auch gerade, wie das scheitert.
Das gibt es ja bei der katholischen Priesterweihe,
zumindest in der traditionellen, ist es ja so, dass der Sohn ein Band,
der dann zum Priester geweiht wird, um die Hände gebunden bekommt und es ist die Mutter,
die dann aufsteht, während dieser Priesterweihe nach vorne geht und dieses Band
löst und das Band mitnimmt und sagt, jetzt habe ich meinen Sohn der Kirche gegeben.
Genau, genau. Und da bleibt er auch. Keine weitere Frau. Ich war die letzte
menschliche Person sozusagen, die da Beziehungen mit ihm hatte und das ist und so weiter.
Naja, die Einwanderer-Geschichte jedenfalls habt ihr im Hinterkopf,
da ich finde, dass sie Markus Lanz im Podcast mit Precht sehr gut zusammengefasst hat.
Und zwar auch so ambivalent, wir wissen ja, wie...
So Leute wie Lanz und Precht, die von sich aus so Podcast beginnen mit,
okay, lass uns mal über Armut reden und dann gleich darauf verweisen,
ja, reden jetzt zwei Multimillionäre über Armut, das ist ja schon so ein bisschen verrückt und so weiter.
Also da steckt ja immer so ein großer Drang zur Versöhnlichkeit irgendwie so
drin, anders als wenn jetzt die Jungspunde oder wir darüber reden,
wo es mal gleich so ein bisschen härter zu Sachen geht.
Und Lanz hat das, wie gesagt, einmal schön auf eine Minute gebracht,
das sozusagen zur Einstimmung.
Er will also nichts erklären über diese Jugend in einer typisch deutschen Kleinstadt,
auf deren Friedhof 67 KZ-Häftlinge begraben liegen, die einen Todesmarsch aus
Dachau nicht überlebt haben.
Erst streitet er alles ab, dann sagt er einige Tage nichts, dann besteht er
darauf, als Erwachsener kein Antisemit gewesen zu sein. Später sagt er, er war nie Antisemit.
Und erst auf Druck ringt er sich zu einer Entschuldigung durch,
die ich ihm in dem Moment auch abgenommen habe, wählt aber diese relativierende
Formel, wenn ich Gefühle verletzt habe.
Und gipfelt dann aber in einem Satz das ganze Interview mit den Kollegen von der Welt.
In meinen Augen wird die Shoah hier zu parteipolitischen Zwecken missbraucht.
Also er sieht nicht die Opfer, er sieht sich als Opfer. Und das ist schlimm.
Ja, das ist schlimm, aber es spielt sich auf semantischer Ebene statt und er sagt dann später noch,
wir wollen Hubern Aiwanger nicht unterstellen, jetzt Antisemit zu sein,
wo er doch diesen wichtigen politischen Posten hat, also eine Erklärung wie,
es ist 35 Jahre her und ich bin aber geläutert, hätte durchaus funktioniert,
wenn er sich tatsächlich so gezeigt hätte.
Hat er aber nicht gemacht. Genau, wenn er nicht einfach nur gesagt hätte,
ja, das war damals, weil...
So ist es halt mit dem Holocaust. Einfach nur zu sagen, das war damals,
reicht eben nicht. Wir machen bewusst immer ein gegenwärtiges Argument dazu.
Das kam aber von ihm nicht. Deswegen auch die Sache von Knoblauch,
die das ja noch mal hart, aber dann auf diesen Nenner brachte,
es ist gut, dass Söder so gehandelt hat, wie gehandelt hat, weil ein Märtyrer
können wir jetzt auch nicht noch gebrauchen.
Und da zeigt sich ja, das ist mal wieder, ich wollte es erst ein bisschen übertreiben,
aber ich mache es jetzt doch einfach nur in lockeren Sprüchen sozusagen,
wir wissen ja 1923 war es Bayern, wo Hitler diese ersten Reden gehalten hat
und feststellte, das fällt auf Resonanz, cool, dann gehe ich mal in diese Richtung weiter.
So, und dann hat er es ja relativ zügig übertrieben, kam ins Gefängnis und Hubert
Aibanger macht ja wieder, nicht für sich, aber für uns, diese Erfahrung.
Ich stehe irgendwo im Festzelt, das musste natürlich jetzt genau diese Festzeltzeit
irgendwie treffen, wo man jeden Morgen ab 11 Uhr diese Reden austesten kann.
Und er kommt da mit diesem, was Lanz ihm attestiert, Adumas dich zum Opfer.
Der Holocaust wird hier als Waffe gegen dich verwendet. So ungefähr.
Und macht im Grunde die gleiche Erfahrung wie vor 100 Jahren.
Es gibt so eine Staatsräson irgendwie und genau, weil man ihr widerspricht,
weil man sich gegen sie stellt, hat man Erfolg.
Ist man im Widerstand automatisch. Und die Zahlen, die Umfragezahlen sind ja
erschreckend gut für ihn.
Also genau das Gegenteil. Aber da wundere ich mich auch, hatte man geglaubt,
wenn man das hervorzieht, dass das anders ist?
Also das würde ja auf einen, wenn man davon ausgegangen wäre,
nun wären die Umfragen für diese freien Wähler sehr viel schlechter Aufgrund dieses Skandals,
dann hätte man ja auf die Idee kommen müssen,
dass wir es da mit Bürgern zu tun haben, denen Antisemitismus und dessen Bekämpfung
ein ganz wichtiges Anliegen ist, was ja davon nicht auszugehen ist.
Und man sieht ja gerade, welche Leute da sich schon immer um Aiwanger gescharrt haben,
dass die jetzt bar jeder Fakten und bar jeder Vernunft und bar irgendetwas,
was man Anstand nennen könnte, sagen, ja jetzt aber erst recht.
Und da sieht man es, das haben die da alles wieder in ihren Eliten gemacht.
Die Grünen und die Linken und weiß ich nicht was.
Das ist für mich ja ganz logisch, dass sich das in diese Richtung entwickelt.
Wir hatten ja zwischen 1923 und 2023 sowohl den Holocaust faktisch als auch
danach das Gerede darüber.
Und dann Martin Walser und so weiter irgendwann dieses Auschwitz als Moralkeule.
Und Moralkeule ist ja eigentlich ein ganz interessanter Vorwurf,
wenn man jetzt mal ganz wohlwollend, gutwillig damit umgeht,
wie das damals so vorgetragen wurde als Vorwurf.
Dass man nämlich hätte auch, wenn man es so reduziert, heute jetzt sagen könnte,
naja klar, wir wollen Auschwitz nicht als Moralkeule, das muss aufhören,
wir brauchen Auschwitz wieder als die echte Erzählung, worum es wirklich geht
und nicht nur reduziert auf einen Begriff.
Und das ist eigentlich die große Lehre aus diesem September 2023 jetzt,
dass wir Antisemitismus wirklich nur noch als das singuläre Wort,
das wir einfach so einbauen in irgendwelche Sätze mit der Vorstellung,
ja, das versteht sich von selbst.
Also wenn ich jemandem Antisemitismus vorwürfe, verstehen das alle von selbst.
Und wir stellen fest, nee, es versteht sich nicht mehr von selbst.
Dieses, wir machen ein Gedenken im Bundestag und betonen noch mal,
dass jetzt aber die Generation derjenigen, die es erlebt hat, wirklich weg ist.
Das bedeutet jetzt wirklich was. Weil man kann nicht einfach nur Antisemitismus
sagen, man muss es jetzt immer erklären.
Und das fand überhaupt gar nicht statt. Ich habe im Aufwachen Podcast Clips
davon gespielt, wie Christian Sievers nach einer Woche.
Die das lief, mit Josef Schuster im Gespräch,
also dem Vorsitzenden des Zentralrats der Juden, dann plötzlich in der fünften
Frage oder so kurz darauf hinweist,
ah ja, dann wollen wir auch mal kurz auf das Flugblatt eingehen,
ich weiß nicht, ob das alle Zuschauer kennen, so, ja, und dann kommt man mal
auf die Inhalte zu sprechen.
Und das ist einfach ein absolutes, komplettes Medienversagen.
Hier kann man Hubert Allwanger alles vorwerfen, Aber dass er einen Ausweg für
sich sucht, um seine Biografie zu retten, zugestanden.
Das würde jeder und da sind die Inhalte austauschbar, würde sich eine Strategie suchen.
Und wenn es dann möglich ist, einfach zu sagen, meinem Bruder war es,
ich bin euch keine weitere inhaltliche Erklärung schuldig und er kommt damit
durch, dann ist das Medienversagen.
Ja, muss man einfach so sagen. Das sind dann einfach nur noch,
also nur noch die Medien schuld, dass das möglich ist.
Und sobald man nur den Vorwurf hat und nicht dann wirklich in das Inhaltliche
hineingeht, sind die Leute ja erst gar nicht bereit, das zu verstehen.
Also die, die eh schon in so eine eiwange Richtung gehen.
Und vielleicht liegt es aber auch nochmal daran,
also jetzt hat man, du hebst ja immer sehr darauf ab,
man hat diese alten Wähler, aber wenn man sich ja zum Beispiel Umfragen ansieht,
die dann mal ein bisschen aufgeschlüsselt sind nach Alter, dann stellt man ja
zum Beispiel fest, dass die AfD bei jungen Leuten auch einen hohen Zuspruch genießt.
Aber?
Zum Teil höher als in den alten Generationen, also 65 plus.
Aber was ist das immer gleiche strukturelle demografische...
Das demografische Problem oder Thema ist natürlich, dass die Älteren die Wahl machen.
Nee, nee, nee, ich wollte noch, also das ist nämlich ganz interessant,
dort, also die Jüngeren gehen dort AfD wählen.
Wo es demografisch trotzdem komplett ins alte gekippt ist. Also wo die Jüngeren
eine besonders kleine Minderheit, eine besonders männliche Minderheit sind.
Also diese Städten, die wir jetzt haben. Nordhausen mit der Oberbürgermeisterwahl.
Dieser südthüringische Landkreis Sonneberg als so ein etwas größeres Gebiet.
Suhl mit Hans-Georg Maaßen als Bundestagsabgeordneten für die CDU,
also wo selbst die CDU es nicht mehr schafft, nicht AfD zu sein sozusagen.
Nee, der ist ja kein Abgeordneter.
Oder Kandidat, genau. Der hat damals verloren gegen diesen Sportler,
der von der SPD noch mal, es sind ja nur noch Sammlungsbewegungen dagegen,
wie jetzt in Nordhausen auch.
Gut, aber also da, wo nicht mal die CDU schafft, nicht AfD zu sein,
glaubhaft so, da wählen überwiegend auch die Jüngeren, die nicht mal mehr in
die DDR miterlebt haben, AfD.
Aber eben in diesem demografischen Kontext.
Und zugleich ohne historisches Bewusstsein scheint mehr, also das,
was du jetzt eben ausgeführt hast, dass es nicht mehr reicht,
zu sagen Antisemitismus, dass das auch gar nicht verstanden wird.
Es mag möglicherweise auch daran liegen,
dass die alte Generation vielleicht noch auch in ihrer ganzen Trällkeit und
so dann doch intuitiv sagt, mit so Rechtsextremen nicht, machen wir nicht.
Und dann sich sehr stark aufteilt unter den beiden Volksparteien SPD, CDU.
Und für, also die haben es mal erlernt und inhaliert und so.
Da ist das so sehr internalisiert, dass das Gott sei Dank geblieben ist.
Bei den Jungen hat dies nicht mehr stattgefunden, weil auch der Abstand zu den
historischen Ereignissen ja doch dann ziemlich groß ist. Und bei denen ist das
nicht mehr eine Selbstverständlichkeit.
Und das hat man ja auch zugleich in den USA gesehen,
wo man so einen radikalisierten White Supremacy Modus hat, der sich nochmal
von dem unterscheidet, was jetzt früher konservative rechte Wähler in den USA waren.
Also dass plötzlich da wieder, wir reden jetzt auch mal noch über Gene und über
Intelligenz von Schwarzen und Weißen und sowas.
Also was sich dann selbst für, weiß ich nicht,
Leute um Nixen herum oder so verboten hätte,
ja, so ein Diskurs, ist, weil man noch den, auch einen historischen Background
hat und sagt, okay, das ist nun wirklich, geht nicht, ist aber,
kehrt jetzt wieder, wenn der entsprechende historische Abstand groß genug ist.
Also insofern aus der Geschichte lernen immer so ein, zwei Generationen,
bei der dritten scheint es schon schwierig zu werden.
Absolut. Und ich meine Björn Höcke ist ein Geschichtslehrer.
Ja. wenn wir Landkreise haben, in denen 35 oder wie in Nordhausen 45 Prozent die AfD wählen.
Dann heißt das, auch jeder zweite Geschichtslehrer wählt dort AfD.
Jeder zweite Arzt, mit dem man so rumsitzt und über die persönlichen Sachen
redet, ist ein AfD-Wähler.
Und auch jeder zweite Patient. Also es schlägt sich einfach strukturell nieder,
dass man so drauf ist. Und Jean-Philippe hat jetzt in seinem Podcast kurz mal
gefragt, gibt es überhaupt Protestwähler?
So im Sinne von, sollten wir uns weiter rausreden mit dieser,
finde ich, sehr sympathische Frage, weil die Antwort ist nein.
Und wir haben ja jetzt auch diese Mitte-Studie bekommen, wo man einfach von
einem Jahr aufs nächste eine doppelt so hohe Prävalenz für echt hart rechtes,
ultranationalistisches Denken plötzlich attestiert für die ganze Gesellschaft.
Ja, diese Denkzettelwahl, das glaube ich gar nicht. Also die Denkzettelwahl, das hat,
glaube ich, eine Zeit lang funktioniert als diese, als rechte Parteien,
es gab ja auch schon andere, so wie Schill oder so, als das mal,
da mal so ganz kurz viral war, ohne dass es das Internet damals schon gab.
Und man aber auch das wählte als Denkzettel, aber zugleich war auch klar,
dass es überhaupt keine Machtoption für die geben würde.
Da mag sein, dass da manche aus so einer, es ist immer noch falsch,
aber aus so einer Denkzettelmanier, aber hier kann ja niemand mehr sagen,
naja, jetzt haben wir mal einen Denkzettel, sondern hier geht es ja um ganz
große machtpolitische Fragen und Verschiebungen.
Und deswegen will ich das nochmal unterstreichen, also was ich jetzt nicht meinte
ist, die Leute wissen gar nicht, dass die rechts sind oder die wissen nicht,
Antisemitismus, die wissen es in dem Sinne schon, nur es hat sich davon losgelöst
von der historischen Verantwortung und all dem.
Und deswegen glaube ich auch, ja, es werden nicht mehr oder weniger Geschichtslehrer
die AfD werden, ich befürchte, da hast du völlig recht.
Genau. Und deswegen, wir bleiben mal, weil ich könnte jetzt wieder sagen,
ja, bei, wie hieß er damals in Österreich, Heider, Jörg Heider oder bei Schill.
Das ist halt so dieses, man sieht die so und findet die auch persönlich irgendwie
ansprechend und macht dann dieses, das ist mein Typ, um mal einen Denkzettel zu setzen.
Aber wir sehen ja, das hat sich schon entkoppelt von den Leuten.
Also die Leute wollen wirklich einfach AfD wählen und nicht,
Denen ist dann auch egal, ob das jetzt Höcke macht oder nicht,
also das ist einfach die Botschaft ist die Botschaft.
Also das ist eigentlich die einzige Partei.
Die mir gerade einfällt, bei der sich Personalfragen für die Wähler nicht stellen.
Also wir können schon, da kommen Sprüche aufs Plakat und so weiter.
Wir wissen die CDU hat wegen Laschet verloren.
Wir wissen, dass Habeck wahrscheinlich mehr Stimmen für die Grünen geholt hätte
als Baerbock. Also da können wir das alles so zeigen.
Kann er ja dann auch beim nächsten Mal zeigen.
Die Linken haben das Problem, dass sie gerade nicht den Kopf haben,
weil Wagenknecht, Demasi weg etc. Ja und die AfD ist die einzige Partei,
wo eigentlich völlig egal ist, wer das jetzt gerade macht.
Genau, da steht einfach wirklich einfach inhaltlich und wie man sich so fühlt,
wenn man sie wählt. Und wie man so, das wäre der Mittelpunkt.
Gut, also steigen wir mal ein, denn die Inhalte, die strukturellen Phänomene,
nicht so sehr die Person. In der Hinsicht überschlagen wir die 100 Jahre.
Regina Scheer, ich kenne sie nicht, hat ein Buch über Hertha Gordon Walcher
geschrieben, die ich auch nicht kenne. Wir bleiben bei einem Gedanken,
der rübergerettet wurde.
Im November 1929 gewann die NSDAP bei der Wahl zur Berliner Stadtverordnetenversammlung
Versammlung über 13.000 Stimmen und errang zwei Sitze.
Und zwei Wochen später bei den Landtagswahlen in Thüringen bekam sie schon sechs der 53 Sitze.
Jetzt hatten es die Nazis auf Landesebene in die Regierung geschafft.
Das war nur durch eine Koalition mit bürgerlichen Parteien möglich geworden.
Für Tellmanns Anhänger waren noch immer die Sozialfaschisten die Hauptfeinde.
Die Sozialdemokraten aber machten ihnen die Feindschaft leicht.
Geschichte wiederholt sich nicht. Aber Schär macht deutlich,
es kann sich lohnen, einmal innezuhalten und sich zu fragen,
hatten wir das nicht schon einmal?
Eindrücklich erzählt sie, wie sich die Linke in der Weimarer Republik in den
inneren Kämpfen so verstrickte, dass sie blind war für die eigentlichen Auseinandersetzungen.
Also ein Buch, das in Andruck vorgestellt wurde mit so einer Idee.
Geschichte wiederholt sich nicht, wir wollen nicht und so weiter.
Magisches Denken. Aber hatten wir das nicht schon mal? Hatten wir nicht schon
mal, dass jemand in Bayern die großen Reden schwingt? Und hatten wir nicht schon
mal, dass so strukturell vorbereitet wird in Thüringen?
Damals war der NSDAP ganz gezielt, wir testen das jetzt aus in Thüringen und
so. Lässt sich ja auch super interessant nachlesen.
Ja, man kann ja sogar so weit gehen, dass man sagt, der bayerische Wahlkampf
ist nicht nur der bayerische Wahlkampf, sondern es ist gerade so der Wahlkampf
für die AfD im Osten, wo die Wahlen erst später anstehen.
Aber die machen jetzt die Vorarbeit, ohne dass AfD-Figuren da uns in Erscheinung
treten, sondern das machen Söder und Aiwanger selbst für den Osten.
Weil der Osten sich das ansieht und sagt, seht ihr?
Und hier haben wir die beste Möglichkeit, weil in Bayern würde das mit der AfD nicht funktionieren,
weil die CSU so extrem verwurzelt ist, aber im Osten kann man dann sagen,
genau, wir haben ja hier auch unser Angebot, ihr bereitet das schon mal für uns vor.
Genau, und dann spielt ja jetzt aktuell Merz noch so eine Rolle,
über den kommen wir dann gleich, den weben wir gleich ein.
So, eine zweite Stimme, die uns so den Ton setzt, kann Schirach,
hat ja gerade wieder ein neues Buch, wie auch immer, er spielt jetzt irgendwie,
also er spielt selber Theater zu
seinem Buch, also ich habe es nicht genau verstanden, aber ist auch egal.
Das Heute-Journal war natürlich wieder
ganz fasziniert, das dieser Mega-Million-Bestseller-Autor und so weiter.
Und auch hier nehmen wir uns einfach nur so einen Gedanken mit.
Auch wieder im Hinterkopf, der Typ guckt ein bisschen anders auf die Jahre 23
bis 33 bis 39 bis 1945, weil er den ganzen Keller voller Familienfotos hat,
wo sein Opa oder wer auch immer an Hitlers Seite durch den Wald streunt und die Pläne schmiedet.
Also da ist man so ein bisschen anders sensibilisiert. Schirach sagt folgendes.
Schirach probt seine Bühnenpremiere auf Schloss Elmau. Schöner geht es kaum
als in der bayerischen Alpenkulisse.
Doch der 59-Jährige macht sich
Sorgen ums Land. Sein Großvater war die Nazi-Größe Baldur von Schirach.
Der Enkel warnt nun davor, die Gefahr eines AfD-Ausstieges zu unterschätzen.
Wenn wir diese Partei in irgendeiner Form in die Regierungsverantwortung bekommen,
dann ist das Land verloren.
Das ist überhaupt keine Frage. Da können wir auch keine Späße drüber machen. Das ist wirklich ernst.
Ja, das Land ist verloren.
Und zwar in jeder Hinsicht.
Ja, also man sieht ja jetzt schon, dass Landstriche verloren sind.
Ja, ich meine, Nordhausen ist jetzt mal wieder bundesweit bekannt,
weil jemand von der AfD nicht gewählt wurde, aber es drohte.
Und wir wissen alle, wie das jetzt ökonomisch da weitergeht,
nämlich so wie in Sonneberg. Also da zieht man nur noch weg.
Ja, so und wir haben jetzt aus Suhl, ich hatte es ja auch auf der Bühne kurz
gezeigt, Diesen Tweet von Bodo Ramelow, der noch mal, oh ja,
wir haben unsere Bevölkerungsvoraussetzungsberechnung jetzt für Thüringen bekommen.
SUL bis 2040, also in der Zeit, wenn man heute ein Kind bekommt,
es volljährig ist, in diesen 17, 18 Jahren, ist für SUL minus 40 Prozent im
Erwerbspersonenpotenzial prognostiziert.
Das ist beispiellos für die ganze Welt. Also das kennt überhaupt niemand.
Das kann man auch nicht politisch gestalten oder verhindern oder sonstiges.
2040 leben in Suhl Menschen, die irgendwie im Durchschnitt 65,
66 Jahre alt sind, ohne einen Arzt.
Im Umkreis von 30 Kilometern, ohne Einkaufsmöglichkeiten,
ohne Getränkeautomat, nicht mal das wird sich rechnen, dort strukturell,
also das können wir uns noch gar nicht vorstellen, was das einfach bedeutet,
so insgesamt, aber das ist halt, das sind so diese strukturellen Sachen,
mit denen man jetzt einfach, da kommt es echt nicht drauf an,
wer da regiert oder so, das ist einfach die Zahlen sprechen da für sich.
Gestattet mir mal eine Minute den Teufel an die Wand zu malen.
Also hätten wir jetzt irgendwann eine Regierungsbeteiligung.
Nehmen wir mal an, es wäre jetzt im Bund so etwas CDU, AfD, AfD Junior Partner
und oder und dazu kommen dann noch in den Landtagen würde sich das ähnlich verhalten.
Wahrscheinlich würde ja dann so ein ganz merkwürdiger Mobilisierungseffekt stattfinden.
Also viele Leute werden auch das Land verlassen, also die die Besseren,
die die die Besserverdienenden vielleicht, wenn sie die Möglichkeit haben.
Und dann ist auch die Frage, wo dann genau hin?
Und dann glaube ich aber würde wahrscheinlich das,
was wir jetzt so in einzelnen Regionen schon sehen können, also dieses Wegziehen
irgendwo in der Stadt, würde wahrscheinlich dann sich doch so sehr aufspalten,
dass man sagt, dass man hat solche urbanen, sagen wir kosmopolitischen Metropolen,
in denen man sich dann so rumtreibt.
Da gibt es dann auch noch so ein paar Kanten in der Stadt, wo man sagt,
da lieber mal nicht hin. Also das ist ja auch schon mit unter Dresden oder so,
dann wird einem das ja schon so gesagt, wenn man da mal eingeladen ist.
In linken Veranstaltungen wird, kriegt man das ja schon so ein bisschen erklärt.
Und dann haben wir so zwei Deutschlands eigentlich.
Aber dann nochmal so ganz stark dadurch, dass man auch sagen kann,
wo man es immer in Prozenten dann sagen kann, da sind so und so viele oder ist
das Parlament folgendermaßen aufgeteilt und dann ist das so getrennt.
Und dann lebt man so nebeneinander her und hat dann nur noch so manchmal den
Verdacht, wenn man irgendwo im Restaurant sitzt, naja, könnte einer sein,
aber weiß man noch nicht.
Ich will es mal so beschreiben. Ich habe ja Familie ganz weit im Osten.
Thorgau, Dommitsch, Städte, die kennt man gar nicht.
Und es gibt ja auch in den Gegenden Menschen, die Menschen mögen.
Es ist ja nicht, also ich will es nicht zu spirituell oder sowas machen,
aber ich finde es schon interessant, dass wir ja eigentlich in den Romanen und
so weiter, auch wenn wir Fernsehen gucken, Sturm der Liebe, wir kriegen doch
bundesweit immer vorgelebt, wie es gut ist.
Seid nett zueinander. Genau.
So was. Jetzt hat man aber da eine Situation in Domiz zum Beispiel.
Stell dir vor, so dieses kasernenartige Wohnen, also drei Stockwerke,
Satteldach oben drauf, im Dachgeschoss wird die Wäsche aufgehängt,
es ziehen in vier Hauseingängen jeweils auf jedem Stockwerk zwei Familien ein und so weiter.
Alles voller Leben, Kinder spielen draußen, nur die Kinder werden erwachsen,
die ziehen weg und so weiter und alle werden gleich alt.
Also da wohnen alle noch vom Erstbezug drin, aber sind 70, 80 Jahre alt und
rundherum, wie die Kinder, ist alles weggezogen.
Diese Menschen kriegen schon fünf Schläge mehr Puls und eine gewisse Alarmierung,
wenn nur ein Auto die Straße entlang fährt, das sie noch nie gesehen haben.
Also da beginnt schon des Nachdenkens, was ist denn jetzt, hier ist jemand,
den kennen wir gar nicht, also hier ist jemand mit so einem Auto vorgefahren.
So, da muss kein Ausländer aussteigen, da muss auch niemand erkennbar anders
aussehen oder so weiter.
Und ich denke mir dann immer, also ich übertreibe es jetzt eigentlich nicht,
auch wenn es sich so anhört, aber ich bin sehr gespannt, wie die höhere Reaktion zu uns ausfallen.
Selbst wenn du die wohlmeinendsten, noch menschenfreundlichsten Menschen aus
diesen Regionen nimmst und mal auf der Hauptwache in Frankfurt aussetzt einfach,
kommen die damit nicht klar.
Die sehen auf einmal 300 Menschen um sich. Das kennen die gar nicht.
So die gehen üblicherweise aus da und dann, ah guck mal da drüben kommt auch
gerade der Egon raus so, ja. Und dann treffen sich zwei Leute und die unterhalten
sich dann, wie sie es seit 30 Jahren machen und so weiter.
Also diese Spaltung in Deutschland zwischen Leben im urbanen Zentrum und 70
Jahre alt zu sein und in Dommisch zu leben, ist größer als zwischen hier und Nigeria.
Also es übersteigt einfach, also die alten republikanischen Ausprägungen sind so groß mittlerweile.
Und ich glaube aber, das würde ich nochmal stark machen wollen,
ich glaube, dass das nicht nur das Alter ist, also du hast das jetzt gerade
sehr gut skizziert, wie die dann alle dort wohnen bleiben.
Aber wenn ich jetzt so denke, wenn du hier in den ländlichen Raum,
in den wirklich ländlichen Raum von Rheinland-Pfalz fährst und hast dort Familien,
die sich dort zurückgezogen haben, hier ein Familienhaus und so,
weiß ich nicht, ob das so viel anders ist.
Ja, die haben vielleicht ein bisschen mehr von der Welt gesehen,
sind ein bisschen mehr gereist oder so oder hören auch mal einen englischen Podcast.
Aber ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob wir nicht da auch genau dieses Potenzial,
das sich ja dann auch in diesen Umfragen für die AfD zeigt, das dort finden.
Also für die ist, ich glaube, wenn, wenn, wenn die jetzt mit uns einen Abend,
und wir machen ja wirklich nichts Spektakuläres mit uns in Frankfurt, Wir gehen was essen,
gehen in die Oper und gehen dann noch in eine Bar und dann mit den Leuten,
mit denen wir dort sind, das ist für die wie ein Zoo sich ansehen. Was machen die da?
Ja, weil alle so krasse Sachen anhaben. Also ich habe auch manchmal schon das
Gefühl, wenn ich so durch die Eifel fahre.
Aber Dommitsch ist echt nochmal ein anderes Kaliber. Also es ist,
wenn du da ankommst, selbst in Thorgau, ich habe es glaube ich schon mal beschrieben,
Thorgau die erste neu geweihte evangelische Kirche, die nicht umgeweiht wurde,
also wirklich ein unter diesen Kirchen, auch kirchenpolitischen,
kirchenhistorischen Gesichtspunkten wichtige Stadt.
Die erste deutsche Oper, die dort uraufgeführt wurde, in deutscher Sprache,
Torgau, die Russen und die Sowjets und die Amerikaner haben sich in Torgau auf der Brücke begegnet.
Damit waren die Fronten geschlossen. Deutschland war faktisch besiegt, auch in Torgau.
Man denkt so das Zentrum der Welt in so vielen Hinsichten,
aber du fährst 14 Uhr samstags nach Thurgau auf den Marktplatz,
also ins Zentrum dieses, wie ich jetzt eben versuchte darzustellen,
nicht ganz unhistorisch, historisch unbedeutenden Fleckenschenzenlands.
Und es hat nichts mehr offen. Der Bäcker hat schon eine Stunde zu und das Hotel
zur Glocke oder wie es heißt, kostet die Nacht 65 Euro und du kriegst drei Zimmer.
Das ist die Insights von allem, was man sich vorstellen kann und das ist dort noch.
Ein Mittelzentrum sozusagen. Also es ist wirklich hochgradig dramatisch.
Die Stimmungslage ist entsprechend. Also wenn der Schirach so was sagt,
der kennt sich aus, der ist jenseits dieser, der tourt durch ganz Deutschland,
der sieht das überall, der weiß, wie die Stimmung ist.
Wenn die Regina Scheer sowas schreibt, gibt sie das wirklich zu bedenken.
Und wir hören jetzt noch so einen Dritten.
Sascha Kowalczuk war im Freitagssalon bei Jakob Augstein zu Gast.
Die machen das ja dann auch als Podcast, sodass wir es alle nachhören können.
Zu ihm auch nur kurz, er ist, ich weiß nicht genau, sehr viel DDR-Geschichte,
vielleicht auch so mit bürgerrechtlichem Einschlag, ich hab's schon wieder vergessen,
spielt aber auch nicht diese große Rolle.
Ich hab nur noch im Hinterkopf, wie er während des Podcasts sagte,
ja, und der Dirk Oschmann hat ja auch dieses Buch jetzt geschrieben,
das hat er ja vor allem von mir inspiriert bekommen.
Er bezieht sich immer auf mein Buch, er sieht sich selber als Vordenker sozusagen
für diese neue Debatte und Augstein stellt ihm mal so die letzte Frage dieses Gesprächs.
Sie haben gesagt, der Osten ist ein Laboratorium für das was im Westen auch passiert.
Ich habe das jetzt chronologisch sozusagen nicht verfolgt und nicht im Überblick.
Jedenfalls Tatsache ist, dass rechte Parteien schon lange, also jetzt nicht
erst neuerdings, sondern schon seit langer, langer Zeit ja auch im Westen auf dem Vormarsch sind.
Wir haben in Italien eine im Prinzip faschistische Premierministerin,
in Frankreich kann man sich kaum vorstellen, dass es abzuwenden ist,
dass es eine rechtsextreme Präsidentin es geben wird.
Das heißt, dann haben sie Kernlande von Westeuropa, die im Prinzip rechts regiert werden.
Die Frage ist jetzt hilflos und doof, ich kann sie nicht besser formulieren,
aber was bleibt uns dann eigentlich noch übrig.
Also wahrscheinlich wird genau das in diesen Bezugsländern von Deutschland dazu
führen, dass der Erosionsprozess in Deutschland weitergeht.
Und ich habe ja eingangs auch gesagt, ich bin niemand, der von irgendjemandem
geliebt werden will oder von irgendjemandem gewählt werden will.
Ich hätte mir vor 30 Jahren meine Ängste von heute nicht vorstellen können,
nämlich dass ich zu meinen Lebzeiten unter Umständen nochmal in einem autoritären
Staatssystem aufwachen werde. Ich halte diese Gefahr heute in Deutschland für sehr, sehr groß.
Ja, vielen Dank, Herr Kowalczuk.
Da gehe ich jetzt einfach nur noch mit geborgtem Haupt raus,
sozusagen aus diesem Gespräch.
Da wurden ihm nochmal die Worte geraubt zur Verabschiedung.
Aber ja, so muss man dann rausgehen aus der Veranstaltung, rein in die Welt.
Das ist dann das Gefühl, was da irgendwie bleibt.
Ich sage mal so, auf der einen Seite, ja, wir sehen,
In Frankreich ist es wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht abzuwenden,
es wird die EU zerstören,
aber so wie wir bei der UN gesehen haben, ja, dann findet das halt alles in
G20 statt und man nimmt feierlich Afrika in die G20 auf und eigentlich weiß
man, bei der UN ist nichts mehr außer Theater, zumindest im Sicherheitsrat haben
wir jetzt auch gesehen und so.
Es diffundiert dann so weiter, aber es bleibt irgendwie entscheidungsfähig und
ja, so ist es halt. Wenn Matthias Döpfner jetzt das große Buch des Freihandels
schreibt, sagen wir halt, der Freihandel ist nicht vorbei, aber es ist halt
jetzt chinesische Prägung, also wir können nicht mehr komplett bestimmen, wie du die Sachen sind.
Und als zweiten Gedanken zu diesem 1923 Vergleich, damals war ja die große Gefahr, dass die 10,
20, 30-Jährigen, die die größte, mit Abstand größte Gruppe der Gesellschaft
gestellt haben, durchorganisiert wurden und man dann wirklich einen Weltkrieg macht, wo man sagt,
Frankreich reicht uns nicht, wir fallen gleichzeitig noch in Polen,
in England und überall. Wir versuchen alles und dann hat man sich da übernommen.
Nur, was ist die Prognose für Thüringen und Sachsen und Sachsen-Anhalt,
wenn da die AfD mitregiert.
Da ist niemand zu mobilisieren und da hat auch keiner Lust auf Gewalt.
Ich denke, dass der neuer, also ein alten republikanischer Faschismus würde sich so gestalten,
dass die gegen alles,
was Moral und Menschenrechte mit sich bringt, aber auch alles,
was die ökonomische Vernunft gebietet,
dort eine Abschottungspolitik und Anti-Ausländer-Politik machen werden.
Wo sie sagen, ja, wenn ich hier ein Herzkasper bekomme, kann mich niemand mehr
holen. Ich werde dann hier alleine in meiner Wohnung sterben.
Aber immerhin habe ich hier keinen Ausländer mehr gesehen.
Also ich vermute, auf diesen Irrsinn wird es hinauslaufen. Also der Faschismus
war ja jetzt nie besonders für seine Rationalität bekannt.
Und die Irrationalität wird sich dann anders ausgestalten.
Aber es wird keiner Lebensraum im Osten oder wo auch immer suchen.
Es wird diese Abschottung halten.
Also es ist sozusagen, es hat so ein...
Nee, also dass die jetzt, also ich glaube man muss jetzt nicht glauben,
dass die nochmal nach Polen einnehmen wollten oder so. Also wir sehen ja auch
gerade, das ist ja eher die große Gefahr, wir hatten ja,
Damals zwar auch noch andere Faschismen, also Spanien und Italien,
aber wenn wir jetzt sehen, in Italien ist jetzt schon Meloni da,
wenn Le Pen kommt und dann wird sich das in anderen Ländern vielleicht auch noch ergeben,
dann hat man so eine, und das ist ja auch das eigentlich, was Maximilian Krah
da will, der will ja nicht mehr aus der EU oder so raus, sondern der will so
eine EU der Vaterländer und des Patriotismus, bla bla bla.
Und dann werden es darüber Vernetzung geben und das wird aber immer auf eine
gesamte europäische Abschottungspolitik hinauslaufen, was ja jetzt schon von
den liberalen und grünen Kräften in die Wege geleitet wird.
Und dann wird natürlich weiterhin Druck nach unten abgegeben und werden sicherlich
auch einige Errungenschaften wieder zurückgestellt werden.
Ehe für alle wäre ich mir unsicher, aber zumindest was so andere queere Formen
angeht oder so, wird es einfach sehr sehr unangenehm werden.
Und da denke ich, ist das.
Aber das ist jetzt eben schon in Thüringen, ne?
In Thüringen ist das jetzt schon, aber da kann man noch sagen,
gut dann gehe ich halt aus Thüringen raus, gehe nach Berlin oder sonst wohin.
Das wird ja zunehmen dann.
Und ja, dann ist halt die Frage, wie lange sich das noch so dann verträgt,
also dass man dann sagt, man hat dann so einzelne Zonen, in denen man sich dann
auffällt und diese verlässt man dann nicht.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie das internationale Kapital darauf blickt,
also ob die zurückziehen dann, wenn die CDU mit der AfD zusammen koaliert,
wird das internationale Kapital weiterhin mitmachen.
Also da glaube ich nicht, dass sich da viele Investoren abspringen.
Da sind vielleicht ein paar hippe Startups, aber ich sehe, also du glaubst doch
nicht, wenn jetzt hier AfD und CDU die Mehrheit hätten, dass dann Tesla,
Intel oder irgendwas abwandern würde.
Aber das ist eben, das ist ja genau das strukturelle Merkmal.
Das internationale Kapital, das auf Investitionssuche ist,
und wir wissen ja, wie viel es davon gibt, geht ja mit der Bevölkerung,
also die suchen sich ja jetzt auch ganz gezielt diese afrikanischen Regionen,
es sind ja nicht mal mehr Länder, man denkt ja so mehr in Regionen.
Wo sind junge Leute, wer ist überhaupt
noch in der Lage, also eine Million Menschen müssen iPhones bauen.
Wenn die Chinesen das nicht hinkriegen, so viele Menschen zur Verfügung zu stellen,
sind es die Inder, die als nächstes dran sind. Wenn es die Inder nicht,
dann macht man es in Nigeria, mir ist ja egal.
Da ist zwar auch Know-how-Transfer und so weiter, aber da muss man halt mal investieren,
sehen wir jetzt auch in Ostdeutschland, kommt halt TMC, was in Dommage niemanden
interessiert und niemanden merken wird,
ob jetzt die Anlage, die Fabrik herstellt, in Dresden und Umgebung oder in Taiwan
steht, also Dresden ist für die genauso weg wie Taipei, wenn man sich das so anschaut.
Naja, aber diese Länder oder diese Regionen, die das jetzt in Deutschland als erstes trifft,
wahrscheinlich von der AfD mitregiert zu werden,
die werden ja im Gemütszustand und entsprechend auch in dieser regionalen sozialen
Mobilität diesen neuerlichen Exodus,
Ostdeutschland hat ja schon mal einen Exodus, und jetzt noch mal,
denn wir kommen gleich darauf zu sprechen, es bleiben ja immer noch 70 Prozent
über oder 60 Prozent, die das nicht mitmachen wollen.
Und wenn wir im Fernsehen sehen, wer sich wie freizügig vor der Kamera äußert,
um ein Loblied auf die AfD zu singen, dann schauen doch auch die Investoren
zu und fragen sich, kriegen wir mit dem eine Zukunft organisiert, ja oder nein?
Und wir haben es im Gefühl, wie diese Antwort aussieht. Und in deren Sicht,
du hast die Leute bei SternTV gesehen und so weiter, Aber Spiegel TV, die...
Was meinst du jetzt?
Ich würde gerne die NSDAP wählen. Leider habe ich nur die AfD und so weiter. Achso, ja, ja.
Mit denen ist keine Zukunft zu machen. Klar, das sind jetzt diese ganz drastischen
Beispiele. Aber wenn Alice Weidel beispielsweise, Latino Chupalla.
Es kam bei Adam Tooth, wir haben das Buch ja gelesen, Welt im Lockdown im Salon.
Und da gab es ja diese tolle Passage, wo er sagte, ja es sei bemerkenswert gewesen,
dass sich das amerikanische Kapital, Corporate America, hinter Biden versammelt
hat, damit nicht nochmal Trump gewählt wird.
Aber fragt er dann sich auch schon, wie wäre denn das eigentlich so gewesen,
wenn es die Wahl gegeben hätte, Sanders und Trump.
Hätten die sich auch hinter Sanders gestellt?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Und deswegen, wenn sich für die da noch irgendwelche steuerlichen
Erleichterungen ergeben, und da glaube ich, wird die AfD ja liefern,
das haben wir ja bei Krage gesehen, ich bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Also ich würde sagen, die Anpassungsfähigkeit des Kapitals,
also wir haben diese Debatte, das ist jetzt der Vogue-Kapitalismus oder so,
den gibt es auch definitiv, aber inwieweit der ausschlaggebend am Ende sein wird.
Es ist, wird Larry Fink ein Machtwort sprechen und sagen so,
hier ich ziehe jetzt hier alles ab und Wengert macht das auch.
Aber jetzt nochmal die Demokratie.
Das wäre interessant.
Klar, die würden das sofort machen, wenn es lukrativ wäre. Wenn Christian Lindner
Ihnen als Bundesfinanzminister im Rahmen seiner Möglichkeiten,
und weiter konnte er auch nicht gehen, ein Wachstumschancengesetz verspricht,
wo für Sie sieben Milliarden drin sind, bedeutet das runtergebrochen,
Wolfgang Heuskamp hat ja ausgerechnet 0,07 Prozent prognostizierten Wachstum in der BIP-Rechnung.
Die muss ich erstmal für einen selber in der Branche oder sogar im Unternehmen niederschlagen.
Diese politischen Regelungen spielen nicht die große Rolle.
Die Frage ist, habe ich Menschen, die arbeiten? Habe ich Fachkräfte?
Diese Diskurse, die wir gerade hören mit, wer alles faul ist und wer und hier
und da und so weiter, die kommen ja nicht von ungefähr.
Diese Unternehmen interessiert irgendwann nur noch, kostet mich die Stellenbesetzung
50.000 Dollar oder 500.000 Dollar und wir sind in Deutschland schon dabei angekommen,
dass ein DAX-Konzern immer sechsstellig kalkulieren muss, um eine Stelle zu besetzen.
Und zwar nicht im Management, sondern in jeder Art von Stelle.
Du hast völlig recht, also um das ganz deutlich zu sagen, wir sind jetzt schon
dabei mit dieser nicht einsetzenden Industriepolitik und mit Schuldenbremse
uns zu ruinieren und wenn noch die AfD in der Regierung sitzt,
dann wird das erst recht kulinös.
Dann ist das Land am Ende.
Also das Land ist dann am Ende und das bedeutet aber nicht, dass die Leute aus
einer rationalen Entscheidung heraus das Gegenteil wählen.
Also wir werden, das, das ist ja, da wirklich den Untergang,
also das haben wir in Japan auch gesehen, das ist, wir sind ja unterschiedlicher,
von unterschiedlichen Richtungen kommen doch am Ende immer auch welche,
die hier ein bisschen verzweifelt ausrufen,
ja aber warum wird dann wenigstens nicht mal ein bisschen ökonomisch logisch
gedacht, ja, warum, warum, warum versucht man nicht mal den Kapitalismus zu
verstehen, wie er funktioniert, und dann kann man ja schon mal,
dann wäre ja schon mal viel gewonnen, dass man nicht schon,
Da schon die größte Irrationalität beginnt.
Und das muss aber nicht sein. Also klar, wir haben alle Zahlen auf dem Tisch.
Wir wissen, wie viel Zuwanderung uns bringen würde.
Piketty sagt ganz deutlich in seinem großen Buch, wenn die Demografie schrumpft,
schrumpft das Wirtschaftswachstum.
Es ist so, aber trotzdem sehen wir das nirgends diskutiert.
Also SUL minus 40 Prozent und wir haben eine Diskussion über falsche Anreize,
Pullfaktoren und sowas ja.
Also das kann man nicht zusammenbringen, da braucht man auch nicht viel IQ oder so, das hat keinen Sinn.
Und ich finde auch, man muss das nochmal ganz deutlich, ich will das hier nochmal
ganz deutlich sagen, weil hier ja auch Journalisten zuhören oder auch Politiker,
vielleicht so aus der, ja, wer weiß, wer hier alles zuhört.
Also es ist wirklich unter aller Würde erst einmal,
aber es ist vor allem auch intellektuell unredlich oder man muss sagen es ist
saudumm, wenn man sich überhaupt einlässt auf diese Pullfaktor-Debatten und diesen ganzen Unsinn.
Und ich habe noch ein extra Kapitel geflucht nach diesem Tierpingding.
Das ist einfach das Unvernünftigste, was man machen kann.
Und wenn man das nicht auf ökonomische vernünftige Füße stellen kann,
seine Argumentation, dann muss man sie einfach lassen. Oder man sagt dann einfach,
ja, aber ich bin aber trotzdem rechts. Dann kann man das so machen. Das ist so AfD-like.
Aber für Journalisten oder auch sonstige Politiker, die nicht in der AfD sind,
muss sich das verbieten.
Ich will immer wieder auf die Pointe zurückkommen, die Japaner wurden gefragt,
willst du lieber früher sterben oder von einem Vietnamesen gepflegt werden und
die haben sich dafür entschieden, früher zu sterben.
Also wir entscheiden uns tatsächlich bewusst für den Tod, also wir Menschen.
Bevor wir hier auch nur mal kurz innehalten und nachdenken.
Gut, aber wir schwenken mal so ein bisschen um, denn ja, sehr viele AfD-Wähler,
aber es gibt ja noch die anderen.
Der Sascha Kowalczuk hat hier noch eine Anmerkung.
Also selbst wenn 35% in Sachsen die AfD wählen sollten,
und wir müssen immer noch mal davon ausgehen, wir reden hier über Prognosen
und nicht über tatsächliche Ergebnisse, Dann gibt es 65 Prozent derjenigen,
die zur Wahl gehen wollen, die nicht wählen.
Und meine Kritik setzt an einem anderen Punkt ab.
Seit Jahren lässt sich die demokratische Öffentlichkeit die Themen von der AfD
aufdrücken und häschelt den Themen der AfD hinterher.
Ist das nicht, der politische Diskurs funktioniert ja nicht genau so.
Naja, der politische Diskurs in der Demokratie sollte vor allen Dingen erstmal
so funktionieren, dass man die Demokratinnen, die alltäglich für die Gesellschaft
einstehen, in hunderttausenden Ehrenämtern, dass man die stärkt, macht man aber nicht.
Tatsächlich müssen wir permanent sozusagen uns neuerdings auch damit auseinandersetzen,
dass immer viel mehr Leute das Handtuch schmeißen, weil sie nicht würdigt werden,
weil sie nicht erachtet werden und weil auch das Geld dafür fehlt.
Ja und wenn man gerne mal einen Dank haben will oder einen Applaus oder wie
auch immer Aufmerksamkeit, da muss man halt zu den Devianten rübergehen,
die aus, kennen wir ja, wie das in den Medien funktioniert, entsprechende Attraktivität mitbringen.
Also machen wir es auch so, wir gucken uns das Thüringer Zeug an und hören nur dem Antagonisten zu,
nur Bodo Ramelow, wir müssen jetzt nicht nochmal die AfD und hier und was sagt
die CDU dazu und so weiter, wir kennen diese Argumentation, können auch nochmal
im sozusagen Exkurs darauf eingehen, aber wir hören immer Ramelow zu,
also Ramelow regiert in Thüringen.
Unter den erschwerten Bedingungen keine Mehrheit zu haben. Er könnte also von
der Opposition immer überstimmt werden. Bisher wurde es nicht,
weil das ja hieße, da müssten ja CDU und AfD zusammenarbeiten.
Und das haben sie in diesem Fall jetzt erstmals so deutlich getan und zwar auch
inhaltlich vorbereitet.
Die Frage, haben sie sich abgesprochen, das finde ich so absurd.
Also sowas, wie die da durchgezogen haben, kriegt man gar nicht hin,
ohne, dass man sich auf eine Beschlussvorlage einigt, die man dann gemeinsam abstimmt.
Das ist völlig bescheuert, überhaupt eine Diskussion zu führen.
Ähnlich dumm wie mit dem Bruder. Ja, war es wirklich der Bruder?
Leute, kurz IQ einschalten und einfach mal sagen, das war der Bruder.
Und jetzt können wir mal bitte die Diskussion führen. Naja.
Ich dachte, das wäre so ein bisschen, als würden wir sagen, wir haben uns heute
hier zufällig getroffen.
Ja, genau. Wunderbar, dass du da bist, Wolfgang. Ich habe hier zufällig Mikrofone
und so weiter. Jetzt machen wir einfach mal einen Podcast.
Also, Ramelow war am Deutschlandfunk zugeschaltet und wir hören uns vier Clips
dazu an. Er beschreibt mal dieses Prozedere aus seiner Sicht.
Wenn wir, wie im Beitrag gerade gehört, den heutigen Tag Revue passieren lassen,
muss ich davon ausgehen, dass das in meinem parlamentarischen Leben,
und das ist ein ziemlich langes, der schwärzeste Tag aller Tage ist,
weil die CDU inhaltlich mit uns eigentlich hätte reden können,
wie wir das gewünschte Ziel, Familien zu unterstützen, mit einem gemeinsamen
Förderprogramm hätten absichern können.
Ich will nur noch mal darauf verweisen, dass die CDU hier sich einfach wahllos
ein Thema suchte, bei dem sie mit Familie argumentieren kann,
ist an Perfidie nicht zu übertreiben und wurde nirgendwo explizit mal thematisiert.
Es lief einfach überall nur so mit und es hat mich mal wieder bestärkt,
nee, ich muss über Familie noch mal schreiben, weil das gehört ja auch dazu.
Dass uns Familie so wichtig ist und wir sie deswegen im politischen Diskurs
so leicht missbrauchen können. Und hier wurde sie nun wirklich mal missbraucht.
Aber keine Ahnung, was mit den Journalisten da los ist.
Ohne dass es so eine Abstimmung bedurft hätte und was ich ausgesprochen schwierig finde,
dass tatsächlich die Opposition, die ja im Thüringer Landtag eine Mehrheit hat,
Diese Opposition auch am Freitag im Haushalt- und Finanzausschuss den Antrag
auf Überprüfung und Begutachtung durch den wissenschaftlichen Dienst auch niedergestimmt hat.
Also Tage vorher lag der Antrag schon wörtlich vor und es war klar,
den werden CDU, AfD, FDP gemeinsam durchwinken.
Die Regierungsfraktion hat dann gesagt, wollte das nicht zumindest nochmal vom
wissenschaftlichen Dienst begutachtet haben und daraufhin wurde das abgelehnt.
Also wenn da, nee das ist keine Zusammenarbeit, sondern so, also das kann man
einfach, diesen Haken kann man machen.
Das heißt die Verrücktheit im Parlamentarismus, dass eine Opposition,
die üblicherweise die Minderheit ist, auf einmal gegenüber den Regierungsfraktionen
sogar Anträge zur Begutachtung, ob ein Gesetz verfassungskonform ist,
einfach niederstimmt, um dann...
Einfach niederstimmt. Also bevor sie ein gemeinsames Gesetz gemacht haben,
haben sie schon für die, wie nennt
man es dann, für die Verfahrensordnung zusammengearbeitet, Tage vorher.
Anschließend im parlamentarischen Gang die Abstimmung durchzusetzen und das
obwohl es Alternativen mit der gleichen Zielrichtung,
die die CDU vorgibt und sagt, dass sie Familien stärken wollen,
dass wir gesagt haben und ich habe meine Haushaltsrede heute damit begonnen,
dass ich ausdrücklich Herrn Professor Vogt angeboten habe,
wir wollen das Ziel gemeinsam erreichen,
das Sie beschreiben und Sie können immer gerne sagen,
es ist CDU-Familienpolitik, aber dafür alternativ auf einem wackeligen Antrag
eine Mehrheit mit der AfD und der FDP und den fraktionslosen Abgeordneten abzustimmen
und dann sagt jeder von den Einzelnen,
sie hätten gar nichts damit zu tun, dass die AfD auch mitgestimmt hat.
Dabei sagt Herr Brager, das ist der parlamentarische Geschäftsführer,
das kann man morgen in der Zeitung lesen, dass auch der Tagesordnungspunkt davor,
der abgeräumt wurde, damit man diesen Tagesordnungspunkt vorziehen konnte,
dass das alles mit der CDU abgestimmt war.
Also, man hat dafür gesorgt, dass der wissenschaftliche Dienst nicht nochmal
verzögert, indem man die Begutachtung nicht zulässt. gemeinsam entschieden.
Und dann hier dieser Punkt, den er am Ende machte,
man hat sogar am Tage die Tagesordnung nochmal Gemeinschaft,
also in dieser Stimmengemeinschaft gemeinschaftlich abgeändert,
damit da nicht vorher noch was anderes und so weiter, sondern man alle Aufmerksamkeit
auf diesen Antrag, für den man die Mehrheit schon organisiert hat.
Und das finde ich so witzig irgendwie. Also wirklich, das ist wirklich amüsant.
Wir haben jetzt so und so viele Jahre Bundesrepublik.
Wir hatten vor zwei oder drei Jahren 70 Jahre Grundgesetz und so weiter,
diese große Feierstunde im Haus der Geschichte, Ausstellung dieses Jahr der Kompromiss.
Was bedeutet der Kompromiss? Ah ja, in Deutschland regiert niemand mehr allmächtig,
sondern man muss immer Koalitionen schmieden, sich zusammenfinden,
das vorher klären und dann wird im Parlament quasi nur noch feierlich abgesegnet,
was das Kabinett, die Ausschüsse usw.
So, wir wissen also, im Parlament gibt es keine Entscheidung,
die einfach durch Zufall, ah ja, keine Ahnung, die waren halt auch Sympathisanten
unserer Idee oder sowas, sondern es hat immer einen Vorlauf,
das ist immer eine Kompromissfindung.
Also die AfD und die CDU und die FDP haben ja einfach einen Kompromiss gefunden
und haben den dann feierlich mit einer gemeinsamen,
wir stehen hier alle auf und winken das durch, völlig absurd,
dass das nicht so thematisiert wurde, Sondern dauerhaft mit dieser Frage,
ja ist das jetzt eine Zusammenarbeit oder nicht?
Wo ich frage, wie soll denn eine parlamentarische Entscheidung,
die Gesetzeskraft erwirkt, ohne Zusammenarbeit gelingen? Also dann können wir
das Parlament wirklich zusammen würfeln. Ja, wenn einfach jeder so mit,
ach heute habe ich mal diese Laune, ich rede aber mit niemanden und jetzt gehe ich mal abstimmen.
Ja, mal gucken, einfach was geht. Ja, finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Und ich will nicht diesen Clip von Mohammed Ali spielen, die das ja gerechtfertigt
hat mit, ja so ist der parlamentarische Prozess. Man macht halt einen Antrag
und dann sympathisiert man mit denen, weil man mit denen am Morgen gelesen hat
und denkt, könnt ihr mal mitstimmen. Ja, da habe ich auch gedacht,
liebe Linke, einfach auflösen.
Formal juristisch mag das ja stimmen, aber das sind ja nicht die Attäckchen.
Wenn man sich mal in diese AfD-Perspektive hineinversetzt.
Die machen ja auch nichts der CDU zuliebe oder so. Also die wollen ja auch ihre
Agenda und wollen auch bei dieser Frage wollen die natürlich auch mitreden.
So entsteht so was nicht alles aus der Luft.
Ja, ich meine, es war ja eigentlich ein AfD-Antrag. Die CDU hat den ja aus der
parlamentarischen Geschichte der letzten Monate genommen, hat CDU draufgeschrieben
und dann hat die AfD mitgemacht. Also es ist ja noch viel schlimmer eigentlich, als man immer so denkt.
Es ist absurd. Ramelow gesteht sich trotzdem einen kleinen Scherz zu.
Die Frage ist doch, ob wir jetzt wieder an dem Punkt angekommen sind,
den wir bei der Kemmerich-Wahl hatten, wo hinterher alle beteuert haben,
sie hätten gar nichts damit zu tun gehabt.
Und hier kann sich jetzt keiner rausreden und sagen, mein Bruder hat für mich abgestimmt.
Sehr gut. Hier nochmal seinen Verweis auf die Familien. Es ist wirklich interessant.
Aber was mich noch immer sprachlos macht, ist, dass das Ziel,
das die CDU erreichen wollte, Familien zu stärken, mit der Regierungsmehrheit
hätte erreicht werden können und die CDU hätte sagen können,
wir haben unser Ziel erreicht, nämlich die Familien zu stärken.
Und jetzt haben wir einen Scherbenhaufen im Parlament.
Dass es überhaupt Überschriften gab, in denen AfD, CDU, Stimmen für Steuersenkung
für Familien getitelt wurde, ist absurd. Ich will keine Namen nennen,
aber es ist einfach, das darf nicht sein.
Wurde es getitelt, ja?
Ja, und zwar nicht im privaten Medienbereich, um was ein bisschen einzugreifen.
Also es ist wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schlimm.
Gut, er stellt ja noch mal klar, ist natürlich, wir könnten ewig lange über
Grunderwerbssteuer reden, das ist sowieso ein Thema für sich.
Grunderwerbssteuer, hast du da gerade Zahlen für uns? Also man kann ja davon
ausgehen, wenn jetzt dieses berühmte Eigenheim gekauft werden soll,
dort in Thüringen, dann ist man da vermutlich mit einem Grundstück bei 100.000,
150.000 da.
Und das Haus kostet irgendwas zwischen 400.000 und 450.000, das heißt,
wir reden hier also über eine Summe, die fällig wird aufgrund der hohen Baukosten
und all dem von 500.000 bis 600.000,
Euro und hinzukommend eine Zinslast, die jetzt etwa bei 4,5 Prozent ist,
das heißt, muss man da 400.000 oder 450.000,
selbst finanzieren und hat 100.000, 150.000 Eigenkapital. müsste man roundabout 3.000, 3.300,
Euro im Monat abtragen können, um dieses alleinstehende Eibenheim zu machen.
Und da kann man sich ja schon mal überlegen, wer kann im Monat 3.300 Euro abgeben
für das Abzahlen eines Hauses.
Das sind schon wieder nur bestimmte Familien mit Gemeinde, um es mal so zu sagen.
Also das sowieso. Also wenn du heute, wenn du sagen wir mal 5% Zinsen zahlst
und du brauchst 20 Jahre um den Kredit abzuzahlen.
Und du liegst mit Grundstück und Gebäude ein bisschen über einer halben Million
und der typische Eigenkapitalanteil ist ja immer weiter gesunken zuletzt,
was ja auch zu Sorgen führte.
Sagen wir mal, man zahlt einen rechtsstaatlichen Kredit von 500.000 Euro ab, die man bekommt.
Heißt das, man muss am Ende eine Million Euro zahlen? Also das verdoppelt sich einfach.
Diese Finanzierungskosten zwischen 1 und 4 Prozent oder 5 liegt einfach eine
Verdoppelung der Gesamtkosten auf die 20 Jahre bezogen.
Und diese Grunderwerbssteuer fällt ja ganz am Anfang mit an,
nämlich bei diesen Kauf, Bau, wie auch immer Nebenkosten.
Je nach Land, in Thüringen wurde es halt jetzt um 1,5 Prozent gesenkt,
sind da so ein paar Prozente. Ich will es mal auf einen Nenner bringen,
den kann sich jeder merken und den kann man auch immer gut anbringen.
Typischerweise sind die Gebäude durch Zufall einfach immer genau so groß,
dass die Grunderwerbssteuer, wie sie anfällt, reicht, um die Solaranlage zu bezahlen.
Der Staat könnte also dabei bleiben zu sagen, wir kassieren die Grunderwerbssteuer,
wir erlassen euch das nicht, damit es insgesamt billiger wird für euch,
sondern dafür bezahlen wir euch die Solaranlage.
Also egal, wie du dein Haus gestaltest, machst und so weiter,
die Solaranlage ist inklusive.
Das heißt aber, wir reden jetzt im Ganzen gesehen über einen Kleckerbetrag.
Ja, so 10, 12, 13.000 Euro für eine Familie würde ich mal sagen.
Okay. Und diese Grunderwerbsteuer wurde jetzt gesenkt um?
1,5 Prozent. Also man bezahlt jetzt in Thüringen nicht mehr 7,
sondern 5,5 oder nicht mehr 6, sondern 4,5. Irgendwie so in diesem Fall.
Und da kann man sich natürlich ausrechnen, das wird einen wahnsinnigen Bauboom geben.
Es betrifft ja vor allem nicht nur Familien. Grunderwerbsteuer wird ja nicht
spezifisch, sondern die ist einfach, die hat einen bestimmten Wert,
Egal, wer es ist, es ist eine gute Erwärmung.
Also die Einzigen, denen das wahrscheinlich nützt, sind wirklich größere Unternehmen,
die da jetzt nochmal anderthalb Prozent oder so gespart haben.
Wobei, ja.
Und, und, also es wird zumindest ja diese geringe Senkung, also dass man da
jetzt am Ende 2000 Euro spart bei einem Haus, das 500.000 kostet,
wird ja jetzt niemand dazu bringen, na gut, dann baue ich doch.
Ja, man könnte so ein Argument machen zu sagen, ja, die CDU hat ja irgendwie
recht, es betrifft schon Familien insbesondere.
Ja, klar, weil die ganzen Leute, die mehr Geld haben, haben natürlich Share Deals.
Also sie verkaufen ja keine Grundstücke, sondern verkaufen ja Firmen,
denen Grundstücke gehören und damit keine Grundstücke, sondern Firmen,
wodurch durch diesen Vermögensübertrag eben keine Grundsteuer,
Grunderwerbssteuer anfällt.
Ja, also hat so ein gewisses Perfidien auch mal drin.
Aber es ist, es ist also das Thema auf Familie zu münzen, Gerade jetzt,
wo eh niemand sich was kauft, außer Leute, die es einfach Cash haben,
weil denen geht es gerade richtig gut, die Preise sinken, weil die Finanzierung
so steigt. Also das ist auch mal ein riesiges soziales Scheren-Argument.
Wir haben nachher noch ein paar Presseclub-Clips vielleicht zum Thema Wohnen.
Also es ist wirklich absurd.
Und Ramelow sagt dazu noch mal kurz was mit dieser Grunderwerbsteuer und Familienbezug und überhaupt.
Der Haushalt beginnt zum 1. Januar 2024.
Die Entscheidung, die heute getroffen wurde, soll angeblich zum 1. Januar 2024 gelten.
Warum hätten wir nicht die drei Monate nutzen können, während der Haushaltsdebatte,
das Familienförderungsprogramm der CDU in den Haushalt hineinzupacken,
die Haushaltsstelle und den Haushaltstitel zu definieren und zu veranlassen
und dann auch zu definieren, wie viel Geld kostet das,
weil das ist deutlich weniger als die 48 Millionen Und wir würden die Kommunen nicht schädigen,
weil mit dem Vorgehen, den die CDU jetzt gemacht hat, mit der AfD und der FDP
zusammen, heißt es, dass 18 Millionen den Kommunen verloren gehen, in Thüringen.
Konkret. Das ist der Vorgang, der heute abgestimmt worden ist.
Und der hätte in der Haushaltsdebatte anders geführt werden können,
ohne dass die Kommunen geschädigt werden und zum 1. Januar trotzdem die Familienförderung einsetzen kann.
Also, wozu heute diese Entscheidung, dass man nicht den Haushalt verzahnt mit
dem Anliegen, die Grunderwerbsteuer zu verändern? Und nochmal zur Grunderwerbsteuer selber.
Damit sind alle Immobilienverkäufe gemeint und nicht nur die von denen,
die CDU jetzt spricht. Die CDU versucht das jetzt allen einzureden,
dass nur damit die Familien gemeint sein, die zum allerersten Mal eine Immobilie erwerben.
Das ist aber genau die verfassungsrechtliche bedenkliche Seite,
weil alle, die sich mit Steuern auskennen, wissen, dass nur der Steuertatbestand
für alle gelten kann und nicht nur für eine besondere Personengruppe.
Also wer Familien fördern will, muss Familien fördern und nicht Gebäudeverkäufe.
Zum Beispiel mit einer Kindergrundsicherung.
Zum Beispiel, da gibt es ja einige Einflugschneisen. Gut, jetzt hatte ja der
Sascha Kowalczuk davon gesprochen, es gibt ja noch so ein paar Demokraten,
über die könnte man ja auch mal und so weiter.
Also machen wir das doch mal, Linken haben wir abgehakt, jetzt die CDU.
Was ist mit dieser CDU los, die ja durchaus ein Bollwerk noch sein könnte.
Die Fernsehberichterstattung war wirklich sehr amüsant. Wir sehen hier mal heute
schon mal vom 17.09. Ich kann mir richtig vorstellen, wie die morgens in der Konferenz so ...
Heute, das war wirklich lustig. Wir müssen diesen O-Ton noch mal rausholen von
März vor ein paar Tagen. Da war sowas Witziges. Das will ich noch mal anmerken. So ungefähr.
Neulich im Bundestag. Friedrich Merz posiert für Gruppenfotos.
Da ist sie gerade eine Sommerpause alt. Seine Ansage zur AfD.
Diese Partei ist ausländerfeindlich.
Diese Partei ist antisemitisch. Wir haben mit diesen Leuten nichts zu tun.
Hinter seinem Rücken auf der anderen Seite der Scheibe sitzt in diesem Moment Mario Makowiak.
Mitglied einer CDU-Gemeinderatsfraktion und hier als Teil einer sächsischen
Reisegruppe auf Einladung von, ausgerechnet, AfD-Chef Tino Chrupalla.
Herr Merz hat gesagt, mit diesen Leuten haben wir nichts zu tun.
Ist das auch Ihr Eindruck? Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Wir reden völlig offen, wir arbeiten völlig offen zusammen. Und wir haben null Brandbauer.
Merz macht ein Fotoshow mit irgendwelchen Kindern und hinter der Glasscheibe
schon trifft sich die AfD und die ganzen CDUler fahren dahin und machen mit bei dem Treffen.
Ja, es gibt überhaupt keine Brandbauer.
Es ist wirklich absurd. Gut, Merz tönt natürlich da groß rum.
Wir haben mit denen nichts zu tun. Wir arbeiten mit denen auch nicht zusammen.
Gretschmeyer, dasselbe da in Sachsen.
Eins ist von vornherein ausgeschlossen, dass es irgendetwas mit der AfD gibt,
solange ich hier noch was zu sagen habe.
Damit ist das Ziel ausgerufen, dann hast du nichts mehr dazu sagen und dann
ist die Brandmauer offen. Also absurde Kommunikation.
Gut, das ist die Parteispitze. Wie sieht's im Einzelnen aus?
Wir hören hier Martina Schweinsburg, eine CDU-Landrätin aus Greiz.
Ich habe gestern noch den kleinen Scherz gemacht und Greiz mitgenannt auf Twitter,
als ich Bodo Ramelow nochmal empfahl, man kann auch renaturieren.
Man muss sich nicht den politischen Kopf so zerbrechen. Man kann auch einfach
Bäume pflanzen und den Leuten sagen, es gibt andere schöne Orte.
Und dann sah ich diesen Clip, so und hab auch gedacht, na ja,
das macht schon Sinn, denen das nochmal zu sagen.
Zu Besuch in Kreiz, Thüringen bei der CDU-Landrätin. Womöglich nach der Landtagswahl
in einem Jahr dann im Landtag.
Was sagt sie zum formalen Beschluss der Bundespartei?
Keine Zusammenarbeit mit der AfD.
Dieser Beschluss ist überflüssig wie der Schmutz zu Ostern.
Und Sie werden keine klare Definition für so etwas finden.
Das Konrad-Adenauer-Haus sollte sich tunlichst zurückhalten,
wie die ehemalige SED-Parteileitung in Berlin die Doktrin vorzugeben,
was man denken und zu fühlen und zu tun und zu lassen hat.
Das ist keine passive Aggressivität, sondern das ist Verbitterung, ja, Wut.
Ich lasse mich mit mir reden, von euch lasse ich mir gar nichts sagen,
ihr habt mich nie gefragt.
Ich bin, ich will euch ärgern, so. Da ist nichts zu gewinnen mit diesen Leuten.
Die Regierenden dieser ostdeutschen Ländereien da, im Namen der CDU,
das ist ununterscheidbar von der AfD. Die wollen der Bundes-CDU da eins auswischen.
Und ehrlicherweise muss man dazu sagen, die westlichen Landesverbände lassen
die natürlich auch machen.
Hendrik Wüst und so weiter, die halten jetzt alle schön die Hände still,
denn das ist das Süppchen, das da gerade gekocht wird, um dann nach diesen drei
Landtagswahlen nicht nur März abzuräumen, sondern die CDU wirklich neu zu erfinden.
Es war ja klar, dass auf Merkel erstmal so eine Zwischenfrage folgt.
Oder Merz bereitet sich jetzt dann doch mit seinen Äußerungen darauf vor,
dass er eine solche CDU dann leiten kann?
Ich meine, wenn er da sagt, die Deutschen bekommen die Zähne nicht gemacht,
weil die Ausländer da alle sind.
Nein, nein, nein. Also mein Denkangebot dazu, und man kann nur Denkangebote
machen, weil die sich alle ganz bedeckt halten. Man sieht gerade niemanden bei
der CDU ehrlich kommunizieren.
Aber meine Vermutung ist, die lassen Merz gerade mit voller Wucht gegen die Wand fahren.
Weil sie alle strukturellen Gegebenheiten, ökonomischen Überlegungen und so
weiter einpreisen und genau sehen, wo geht's nicht.
Ja, aber hast du den Eindruck, dass das medial so sehr gespielt wird?
Das wird medial ja gar nicht gespielt.
Dass man jetzt März, äh, also,
Also wenn ich jetzt sehe hier irgendwie so Leute wie dieser,
Moment, jetzt muss ich mich wieder vorsichtig ausdrücken, dieser Premium-Journalist
Schippmann von Funk, der.
Vorhin hast du wieder über den aufgeregt.
Ja, und der würde ja immer noch sagen, ja, also da hat, da ist,
mehr hat's bestimmt mal übers Ziel hinaus geschossen.
Aber der ist ja nicht in der NPD.
Sonst ist er ja vernünftig und hat da auch einen Punkt oder hat auch gute Punkte.
Und da frage ich mich halt, wie weit dieses, also wenn da selbst irgendwie die
Jungen schon in diesem komischen Funksystem sagen,
na ja, aber gut, wir müssen jetzt mal, also ob man da nicht so mit so einer
neuen Pragmatik, Vernunftrichtung so das irgendwie auslegen wird.
Also mir ist das noch alles sehr offen, wohin sich das entwickelt.
Ich kann mir da viel Schlimmes vorstellen.
Ein Denkangebot und ein Cook-Angebot. Thorsten Frei, der ja gerade sich so als
Sprachrohr für die CDU, so weiter, war bei Markus Lanz am 8.9.,
sehe ich hier bei den CDF-Texten, also könnte der 8.9.
Oder wie auch immer, also Thorsten Frei war am Anfang des Monats bei Markus Lanz.
Lanz quält ihn unglaublich lange und wirklich tiefgehend mit der Frage,
ja wann entscheidet denn die CDU jetzt darüber, wer Kanzlerkandidat wird?
Ja.
Thorsten Frei so, da haben wir doch alle Zeit der Welt, das können wir doch
nächstes Jahr ganz locker machen, wo haben sie da ein Problem,
das ist doch gar kein und so weiter.
Und Lanz dann, ja vor oder nach den Wahlen im Osten.
Also das müssen wir doch jetzt gar nicht, das ist doch ganz unerheblich,
wir sind doch frei, wir sind doch eine eigene Partei, wir machen das doch,
was wir wollen. Wir lassen uns doch nicht davon irgendwas und so.
Und dann geht das so ein bisschen hin und her und dann zückt Lanz den Joker
und spielt Markus Söder im Sommerinterview,
wie er ganz deutlich, auch mit so einem schämischen Grinsen,
sagt, nächstes Jahr müssen wir das ganz ordentlich machen, wir können nicht
zu viele Fragen auf einmal behandeln, wir machen erst mal diese Wahlen im Osten
und danach entscheiden wir, wer Kanzlerkandidat wird.
Und es ist dieser einzige Moment, wo mal so ein CDU-CSUler nicht hinterm Berg
hält, was die Strategie in dieser Partei und zwar flächendeckend ist.
Sie brauchen einen Sündenbock für historisch einschneidende Ereignisse,
die dieses Jahr passieren.
Drei mal wird die CDU von der AfD geschlagen.
Und die CDU muss danach trotzdem eine Regierung bilden. Gegen die AfD oder mit ihr.
Das ist sozusagen, da muss man jetzt gucken, Moment of Surrender würde ich sagen,
je nachdem wie die Zahlen fallen.
Aber die Bundes-CDU kann das nicht mitmachen. Es wird eine neue Separierung des Ostens geben.
Ja, das ist die Frage, also ob man dann zwei, ob man eine Spaltung hat,
denn es gibt ja noch diese Laschet-CDU, die ja jetzt manche sicherlich nicht passen.
Das ist nicht die Laschet-CDU, das ist die Wüst-CDU und Wüst regiert halb Deutschland gefühlt.
Ja, ja, aber es gibt ja, mit Laschet-CDU meine ich diese Art des rheinischer
Katholizismus und Frohsinn, vielleicht auch mal an manchen Stellen unangebracht.
Aber man ist jetzt nicht so sehr, dass man, dass man, ja, also man würde da
vermutlich, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, nicht mit der AfD oder sehr sicher sogar nicht mit der AfD.
Und ich meine, man kann ja, also es ist ja diese extreme aufgeheizte Stimmung,
man ist ja dann immer sehr dabei, wenn so eine Regression von rechts droht,
darüber nachzudenken, mal kurz progressive Ziele hinten anzustellen.
Anzustellen. Ich bin nicht sehr dafür, in so einer Strategie zu verfallen,
aber man kann ja mal so durchspielen. Ich glaube, wir hätten ja das alles jetzt
nicht, wahrscheinlich, wenn wir so eine große Koalition mit Laschet hätten, oder?
Dann wäre da einfach nicht der Dampf im Kessel, den es braucht,
damit das überhaupt jetzt so alles in die Luft fliegen kann.
Ja, also man hat ja immer keine Laborsituation, man kann jetzt nicht einfach
das Experiment nochmal starten und so, aber die Art und Weise,
wie Merz es nicht kann, finde ich wirklich atemberaubend.
Ja und wie es aber auch die Ampel nicht versteht, vernünftige Ansprachen zu
machen. Also das kommt ja dann auch hinzu und das dann, äh, äh, man, man.
Die stehen alle zu nahe vor ihrem Panorama, die müssen jetzt alle mal einen
Schritt zurück machen, jetzt wirklich mal einen Monat lang, es geht nichts kaputt,
macht einen Monat Urlaub und dann kommt mal zurück mit.
Die kommen ja gerade aus dem Urlaub wieder, ist aber nicht passiert.
Wir hören jetzt hier mal, Daniel Günther hat ja diesen Spruch gemacht.
Ich bilde keine Mehrheiten mit Extremisten und wenn ich darauf angewiesen bin,
dann weiß ich in dem Augenblick, ich kann meine Hand nicht dafür heben.
Daniel Günther weiß, er wird nie Kanzlerkandidaten. Dafür hat er einfach nicht
diese mediale Figur, Statur, wie Hendrik Wüst zum Beispiel.
Und er kann deswegen einfach so freischießen und zeigt damit so ein bisschen,
was die Partei eigentlich denkt.
Und jetzt hat Merz diesen riesigen Fehler gemacht. Ich verstehe das einfach gar nicht.
Hört euch mal den Machtwechsel-Podcast mit Robin Alexander an und Dagmar Rosenfeld.
Die können sich nicht erklären, warum Merz diesen Spruch gemacht hat.
Und Merz macht ... Nee, also diesen Zahnarzt- und so weiter Spruch.
Der war ja gestern aktuell und haben die Podcast gemacht dazu.
Die haben extra eine Stunde 14 Podcast gemacht, doppelt so lang als sonst immer.
Die fallen da aus allen Worten, die können sich's nicht erklären.
Man sieht auch, dass sie händeringend nachdenken. Wir können uns ja nicht nur an die FDP ...
Die finden die Ampelscheiße und die AfD auch und jetzt die CDU können sich nicht
erklären. Also da sieht man auch mal diese Desillusionierung so insgesamt und
diese Haltlosigkeit in der die da die Konservativen sozusagen gerade sind.
Aber niemand kann sich mehr als gerade erklären. So jetzt macht Daniel Günther
diesen Spruch und sagt ich stimme nicht mit Extremisten.
Wenn die im Parlament aufstehen bin ich grundsätzlich dagegen.
So ich arbeite dann näher lieber mit der Regierung die auf der Suche nach wechselnden
Mehrheiten ist zusammen. was ja irgendwie nahe liegt, weil so funktioniert,
als mit der AfD. Und Theo Koll referiert jetzt mal, was Merz zu diesem Spruch
von Daniel Günther gesagt hat.
Aber Daniel Günther ist mitnichten eine Einzelmeinung.
In der anschließenden Pressekonferenz wurde heute zwar von breiter Zustimmung
für die Thüringer Linie gesprochen.
Genaue Angaben, wie viele aus der Parteiführung sich wie geäußert haben, gab es aber nicht.
Erstaunlicherweise hat sich meines Erachtens Friedrich Merz mit der Aussage
über Günther als Einzelmeinung eine unnötige Flanke geöffnet.
Denn die Partei ist in der Frage des Umgangs mit der AfD gespalten.
Und jetzt kann jeder, der wie Daniel Günther denkt, mit einer öffentlichen Äußerung
die Merz'sche Darstellung leicht torpedieren.
Ja.
März kommt ins Bierzelt nach Bayern.
Die ganze CDU, CSU hat sich darauf geeinigt, das Eiferstellen ist abgeschlossen.
Zum Glück haben wir es über die Bühne bekommen und fängt an Söder öffentlich
dafür zu loben. Das hast du brillant gemacht, das hätte man nicht besser machen
können und so weiter. Und alle so, was macht er da? Wir haben gerade einen ganz
großen grünen Haken dran gesetzt und jetzt macht er das wieder zum Thema.
März macht hier diesen Spruch. Merz macht gestern diesen Spruch bei WeltTV und
so. Das ist einfach der Typ.
Aber man kann ihn jetzt nicht abräumen, weil irgendwer muss noch diese Suppe
nächstes Jahr erklären. Und das macht am besten er dann. Also es geht da wirklich
drunter und drüber. Wir hören jetzt mal Stimmen aus dem Wahlkampf in Sachsen.
O-Töne oder ist es Sachsen oder wie auch Wir hören so die typischen ostdeutschen Stimmen.
Jeder Traum.
René Bochmann, ein AfD-Bundestagsabgeordneter, der für Sachsen im Bundestag
sitzt und hier so Sprüche klopft.
Klopft. Jeder Traum.
Ist eigentlich der Ursprung eines Ziels. Und wenn wir weiter so machen,
und ich glaube, das wäre leistbar, können wir diese absolute Mehrheit erreichen.
Wähler und Abgeordnete bestätigen sich gegenseitig in ihren Meinungen gegen
die da oben in Dresden und in Berlin.
Persönlich habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme, bloß ich bin so wütend auf diese
scheiß Politik, die hier betrieben wird.
Dass Deutschland eigentlich nur bergab geht, wirtschaftlich.
Nicht bezahlbarer Wohnrahmen für viele Leute. Es ist eigentlich alles in Schieflage gekommen.
Arbeit muss sich lohnen. Und was noch für ein Spruch? Nichts ist eingetreten, gar nichts.
Das regt mich so auf. Ich bin enttäuscht. Enttäuscht und wütend.
So, das ist die Schwungmasse, die man jetzt so oder so irgendwie mit der man arbeiten muss.
Ja, ist aber auch ein Versäumnis der Ampel.
Absolut. Also hier sind ganz viele Versäumnisse, aber man muss halt sagen,
es ist jetzt wie es ist. Das ist die Stimmung, bis zum, was weiß ich,
wann die da wählen in Sachsen.
Das ist jetzt ein Jahr so. Und die AfD wird alles dafür tun,
dass es noch mehr so gedacht wird.
Dass die Leute da stehen, ich habe jetzt eigentlich kein Thema,
was mich irgendwie betrifft, aber so grundsätzlich finde ich es scheiße, wie die Politik ist.
Das ist ja auch, es ist eigentlich, muss man ehrlicherweise sagen, wenn du so aufgrund von,
keine Ahnung, Freunde und Familie sagen dir, du hast doch irgendeinen Leidensdruck,
willst du nicht mal ein Gespräch suchen und dann gehst du irgendwo hin und beginnst
so ein Gespräch und da sitzt ein Therapeut vor dir.
Ich will jetzt nicht die Große zwischen politischen und persönlichen,
aber was würden wir intuitiv als erstes machen?
Wir wären doch völlig, wir würden uns sagen, also du hast gerade gesagt,
dir geht's gut, aber du findest es trotzdem scheiße.
Da müsste man doch ganz von vorne anfangen.
Wo geht es dir denn gut? Kannst du es benennen, wo es dir gut geht?
Und dann kannst du es benennen, wo es dir scheiße geht.
Aber sie benennt ja jetzt, sie benennt ja am Ende sehr konkret,
wo es schlecht geht oder die Dame davor, die dann sagte, kein bezahlbarer Wohnraum.
Und das ist jetzt, kann man natürlich eher mal erklären, dass mit der AfD das
eher schlechter werden wird.
Das könnte man dann machen, genau.
Aber die Sache ist ja auch, es wird ja auch andersrum nicht besser.
Also das ist ja, diese Vision sieht ja auch niemand. Also es ist ja eine völlig
visionslose, nicht so gut orientierte Politik.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, man hat keine Vision.
Bei der man auch jetzt nur hinterherläuft. Also ich finde das war doch jetzt
in diesem Monat sehr gut zu beobachten,
wie die Grünen so das letzte, was noch irgendwie die Grünen ausgemacht hatte,
war, dass die so ein bisschen liberaler gegenüber Migration standen,
als jetzt ihre Koalitionspartner.
Und das haben sie dann auch noch weggenommen, in dem dann Ricarda Lang dasteht
und sagt, ja, Nancy Faeser soll mal Rückführungen durchführen,
also Abschiebungen heißt das ja mit anderen Worten.
Was sie nicht verstehen ist, wie sehr sie uns alle verärgern und verunsichern.
Und sie hat das ja nur für die interne Diskussion gemacht. So im Sinne von,
ich komme morgen in die Sitzung und habt ihr gesehen gestern,
wie ich für die Sache eingestanden bin?
Nur wir bekommen das ja nicht mit, wie sie das dann verwendet oder was auch
immer. Wir sehen ja einfach nur und fragen uns.
Sie haben ja schon diesen Asylkompromiss zugestimmt und gehen ja dann noch weiter
in diese Richtung. Also da ist ja auch überhaupt nichts zu erwarten in irgendeiner Weise.
Wäre man ja von genau diesen Leuten vor drei Jahren geschlachtet worden,
hätte man so einen Vorschlag gemacht und jetzt machen sie ihn selbst.
Wir haben jetzt ein Jahr lang Wahlkampf für Thüringen, Sachsen,
Anhalt und dann haben wir ein Jahr lang Bundestagswahlkampf.
Also wir sind jetzt eigentlich, man braucht nichts mehr erwarten.
Es kommt jetzt eigentlich nichts mehr.
Es ist so, wie Lennart gesagt hat, das war das Letzte, was wir gemacht haben.
Das war's. 0,07 Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum und irgendwas für die Kinder.
Ist das jetzt ein flächendeckendes Phänomen? Ich fand es ganz interessant.
Wir gehen noch mal in die Andrucksendung zurück.
Sabine Riedel hat ein Buch geschrieben. Reise durch ein verstörtes Land.
Eigentlich würde ich sagen, das ist so Elke Heidenreich oder wie sie heißt. Elke Heidenreich.
Ich habe da mal so eine Idee. Ich war auf Reisen. Ich will ein paar Eindrücke
mitbringen. Ich bin nicht so ein guter Fotomacher. Ich schreibe es auf. So ungefähr.
Ihr Antrieb war, es gibt doch jetzt ein 9-Euro-Ticket, ich steige mal ein und
dann steige ich mal irgendwo aus und rede mal mit den Leuten.
Und das ist so, ich glaube, die Essenz.
Offenbar soll hier so etwas wie die deutsche Provinz im O-Ton mehr oder weniger
ungefiltert zu Wort kommen.
Quantitativ überwiegen dabei Stimmen von älteren Vertretern der deutschen Mehrheitsbevölkerung.
Ein Orgelbauer in Friesenheim, Baden-Württemberg, der die Grünen wählt und sich
Klimawandel und Ernährungsfragen zu Herzen nimmt.
Ein Milchbauer in Paar Städten Bayern, der zu Tierschutzauflagen und ländlichem
Flächenfraß hauptsächlich Jamai zu sagen hat.
Die Leiterin einer internationalen Privatschule in Glauchau,
Sachsen, die der Reporterin die vom Westen grundverschiedene Prägung der Ostdeutschen
in Dingen wie Geschlechterrollen, Erziehung und Bildung erklärt.
In Zerbst, Sachsen-Anhalt, schimpft eine Hotelleiterin über Wohlfahrtsstaat
und Arbeitsverweigerer und ein Pfarrer fühlt sich als Sprachrohr der kleinen
Leute gegen die urbanen Eliten.
In Bienenbüttel, Niedersachsen, sorgt sich ein ehemaliger Bürgermeister um die
Zerstörung der Heimatlandschaft durch eine geplante neue Bahntrasse.
Das sind so die Sorgen der Leute, Und dieses regionale Meinungs-Allerlei ist
gewiss als dokumentarisch konzipiert.
Doch drängt sich die Frage auf, ob man das meiste davon nicht schon zur Genüge gehört hat.
Da kann man auch einfach einmal eine Regionalzeitung kaufen, oder?
Kann man auch. Ich frage mich natürlich, ist das Gejammer jetzt überall?
Wir haben gerade so eine Ostdeutsche, also so eine Ossi-Diskussion,
von der ich denke, die ist interessant, weil es ist mal nicht nur Gejammer.
Orschmann macht da zugespitzt, sagt das auch und so weiter. Es geht zur Sache.
Wir haben so eine Investitionsoffensive und so weiter.
Und jetzt höre ich in diesem Buch, naja, wenn man dann mal so rumfährt durch
Westdeutschland, hat man im Grunde diesen ostdeutschen Tonfall mittlerweile überall.
Und der Rezensent beschwert sich schon, da haben wir davon nicht schon zu viel.
Und ich denke mir so, oh Gott, ja, irgendwie das ganze Land fängt jetzt an zu
jammern, die nächsten 20 Jahre.
Also Altenrepublik, vielleicht hätte ich doch dieses Kapitel schreiben sollen.
Der Osten ist Vorreiter. Das, was wir im Osten beobachten, wir müssen nur zehn
Jahre warten, dann ziehen die altersmäßig im Westen nach und dann ist es genau das Gleiche.
Also es wird alle so ein Jammer rein stürzen. A.
Man muss aber nochmal hier differenzieren zwischen Jammer und Kritik.
Also was uns eigentlich fehlt ist eine sinnvolle Kritik an den herrschenden
Verhältnissen und an der Ampelregierung.
Und das Jammern führt ja zu einem unentwegten Lamentieren, das am Ende nur bedeutet,
ja irgendwie die da oben machen das nicht so richtig. Und das stimmt natürlich immer auch irgendwie.
Aber ich glaube, Ich glaube, was ja nicht stattfindet,
ist eine Kritik, die sich zum Beispiel mit den ökonomischen Verhältnissen auseinandersetzen
würde und dann aber auch zu Schlussfolgerungen kommen könnte,
die zum Beispiel sagen, mehr Zuwanderung, staatliches Bauen etc.
Und genau das ist aber das, was ja überhaupt nicht angeboten wird,
auch nicht von der Ampelregierung.
Also wir haben einen Wirtschaftsminister, der auch eigentlich nur noch sagt,
ja, wir müssen jetzt mal sehen, dass wir irgendwie durchkommen.
Und dann hat man Christian Lindner, der nur die Schuldenbremse verteidigt für irgendwen.
Also ich sehe das nicht und der Kanzler sagt, naja, es sieht aber auch alles
gar nicht so düster aus, wie es scheint.
Und das sind die Antworten, die man bekommt.
Ich würde ja sagen, zu diesem Märzaufschlag mit den Zahnärzten,
selbst wenn er recht hätte inhaltlich und wirklich kein Deutscher noch einen
Zahnarzttermin bekäme, weil da das ganze Wartezimmer voller Asylbewerber säße,
selbst dann wäre es die falsche Diskussion. Ja, ja eben.
Selbst dann müsste man nochmal, ja wo ist denn das Geld, um diese Problemlage
abzuwenden. Fehlen tut es jedenfalls nicht. Es ist halt irgendwo,
wo man auch mal reden könnte oder sowas.
Also es ist sozusagen völlig falscher Diskurs.
Hier mit dem Sascha Kowalczyk wird diese Frage aufgeworfen, die ich jetzt so
ein bisschen attraktiv finde.
Ja, gibt's den Osten so eigentlich, wenn die im Westen jetzt genauso rumjangeln?
Und er kommt so auf so ein ganz, also wir hören ihm mal so fast zwei Minuten
zu. Es ist ganz interessant.
Also man wird nicht zum Ostdeutschen, nur weil man 30 Jahre lang in Leipzig gewohnt hat.
Die meisten Westdeutschen, die nach Ostdeutschland... Das ist,
ihr könnt mir an dem Gedanken nur kurz mal innehalten. Also es gibt keine ostdeutschen
Konvertiten, sozusagen.
Man muss als Ostdeutscher geboren sein. Nee.
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die sind mit zehn Jahren aus der DDR zum Beispiel in
die Bundesrepublik ausgewandert, geflüchtet.
Die sind in aller Regel keine Ostdeutschen mehr. Und warum nicht?
Ostdeutsche sind durch gemeinsame kulturelle und soziokulturelle Erfahrungen
geprägt, die sozusagen zwischen Capacona und Suhl ganz ähnlich waren.
Es gab die gleichen Schulbücher, es gab die gleichen Medien.
In ganz vielen Dingen war alles ziemlich ähnlich und gleich.
Da war es ziemlich wurscht, ob Sie in Trinwellershagen oder in Annaberg-Buchholz
groß geworden sind. Die Grunderfahrungen waren gleich.
Diese Grunderfahrungen, die werden Sie nicht durch einen Systemsturz einfach
los, und dann wird es irgendwann auch egal, ob Sie nun in Leipzig leben oder in Stuttgart.
Interessanter ist für mich die Frage, kann man diese Erfahrungen weitergeben?
Da sind wir bei einem ganz anderen Problem.
Natürlich kann man die weitergeben. weitergeben. Die wichtigste Sozialisationsinstanz,
die wichtigste Erzählinstanz im Leben von den meisten von uns allen ist der
Familientisch, der Armbrotstisch.
Und da werden auch die Erzählungen weitergegeben über die Vergangenheit,
über die Familie, über das gegenwärtige politische System, über die Erfahrung.
Und deswegen sozusagen gibt es eben solche ostdeutschen Diskursräume,
in die sozusagen Leute von außen relativ schwer reinkommen. Das ist Aber wissenschaftlich
betrachte ich überhaupt nichts Ungewöhnliches.
Wenn Sie sich irgendwie irgendwelche dörflichen Regionen in Österreich anschauen,
da können Sie sozusagen irgendwann auch hinkommen. Da werden Sie in 100 Jahren noch der Fremde sein.
So, wir führen ja ganz verquere Diskussionen, weil wir das Gebiet,
die Region, das Land immer zu sehr in den Vordergrund stellen.
Ukraine-Krieg, es gab seit einem Jahr keine nennenswerten Bewegungen mehr zwischen der Front.
Aber große Fortschritte jeden Tag.
Genau.
Das wird ja reportiert unermüdlich.
Genau, und wir kriegen ja mit, worum eigentlich gekämpft wird.
Vormachtstellung im globalen Süden, Energie, Chips, der ganze Kram.
Nee, nee, das geht nur um Freiheit.
Genau, es geht nur um, wir brauchen Panzer, damit da 100 Meter weitergefahren werden kann als bisher.
Und so ist das ja vielleicht auch bei der Frage, was ist jetzt eigentlich Ostdeutsch,
wie gehen wir mit der AfD-Problematik um, der Gemütszustand und so weiter.
Danny hat ja mit Alex zusammen den Ost-Kinder-Podcast und er versucht ja auch,
mich auf die Seite zu ziehen, mich wieder für den Osten zu interessieren,
Ich bin zwar im Osten geboren, aber ich bin da weggezogen. Ich habe mit dem
Osten im Grunde nichts zu tun. Das sind auch nicht meine Leute.
Und er hat eine Postkarte. Hey Stefan, Ostdeutschland ist da, wo wir sind.
Ja, das sagt der Thomas Mann auch. Deutschland ist wo ich bin.
Hier steht, Grüße aus Ostdeutschland. Abgebildet ist in München die Frauenkirche,
der Kölner Dom, die Elphi in Hamburg,
dann hier so ein gruben Ding aus dem Pott irgendwie.
Weißt du, was das hier in der Mitte ist?
Die Skyline von Frankfurt noch und naja, steht jetzt auch nicht drauf.
Aber nochmal so ein anschauliches Gebäude, könnte Freiburg oder so sein.
Eindeutig Westdeutschland.
Eindeutig Westdeutschland, aber es ist Ostdeutschland. Und vielleicht brauchen
wir genau so eine Diskussion auch.
Und da gibt es ja zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder die ostdeutschen wählen lassen
nächstes Jahr und sagen die gehören nicht mehr zu uns und zwar mit der rigorosen
Entscheidung vielleicht auch der Bundes-CDU zu sagen, wir stellen euch alle vor die Wahl.
Ihr müsst mit einem bewussten Akt neu in unsere CDU eintreten,
ansonsten gehört ihr nicht mehr dazu.
Und dann hat Gras sein Ziel erreicht, die müssen sich entscheiden zwischen AfD
und CDU und dann gucken wir mal wie viele wandern.
Oder wir sagen, in den neuen Ländern wird gewählt. Es sind unsere neuen Länder.
Das Problem, was wir da haben, haben wir grundsätzlich überall.
Es sind unsere 20 Milliarden, die wir da in Chips
fabriken. Es ist unser Braunkohleausstiegsbudget oder was auch immer.
Also das ist so die Schicksalsfrage, vor der wir stehen nächstes Jahr.
Es geht also richtig zur Sache.
Es wird nicht einfach nur so eine Wahl sein. Und jetzt ist die Frage insgesamt
dann, wie geht man denn mit Krisen um, um Sachen abzuwenden?
Und der Sascha Kowalczuk macht hier so eine Anmerkung zum Thema.
Ich darf noch eine Sache sagen, ich glaube diese neu gekundete CDU kann dann
nochmal dieses alte Leib und Magen Thema von AKK und Co.
Aufnehmen und zwar Solidaritätszuschlag für alle abschaffen.
Dann können die das nochmal so neu unterfüttern, damit wir nicht da die Rechten finanzieren.
Zum Beispiel, das wäre ein Argument, dem ich dann auch nachgänge oder man münzt ihn halt groß um.
Ja, ja, das wird nochmal als großes Projekt.
Ich meine, der Solizustag ist ja eh schon eine regionale Förderung,
die jetzt gar nicht so den Osten im Blick hat oder nimmt bewusst.
Naja, Sascha Kowalczuk kommt hier mal auf die Ossis, haben eine Wendeerfahrung
und den Westdeutschen steht sie jetzt gerade bevor.
Sie machen sie jetzt gerade. Irgendwie ist die Welt im Umbruch und wir müssen ja trotzdem irgendwie.
Und ich würde sagen, unter dieser Maßgabe ist dieser Clip hier nicht sehr optimistisch zu lesen.
Nirgendwo im postkommunistischen Raum war der Transformationsschock so brachial wie in Ostdeutschland.
Aber auch nirgendwo sonst ist die Gesellschaft sozial so weichgefallen wie in Ostdeutschland.
Dazu gibt es kein Pendant in Osteuropa.
So, der Wandel war brachial. Er wird ja jetzt auch gerade als brachial empfunden.
Wir kommen später noch auf unseren Bundespräsidenten im Geiste zu sprechen,
der uns ja auch schützen möchte vor den großen Veränderungen dieser Welt und so.
Und gleichzeitig wurden aber die Ostdeutschen auch aufgefangen,
wie in keinem anderen Land.
Wir haben eben nur noch eine Lücke von 17 Prozent oder so zum westdeutschen Niveau und nicht 300.
So wie Polen oder gar nochmal Faktor 3 drauf mit der Ukraine.
Was bedeutet das jetzt für die ganzen Förderprogramme und hier nochmal ein Notding
und hier nochmal wir bezahlen eure Mieter und hier nochmal eine Gaszulage und
so weiter, mit der man die Westdeutschen
gerade versucht aus einer AfD Gemütszustandslage rauszupampern?
Es wird gar nicht funktionieren. Die historische deutsche Erfahrung sagt,
das funktioniert nicht.
Die Leute kriegen 10.000 Euro extra vom Staat überwiesen oder in den Briefkasten
gesteckt und sie sind trotzdem unzufrieden.
Also, diese Gefahr besteht auch bei dem großen, wir haben jetzt eine digitale,
demografische und eine Klimawende vor uns, die irgendwie bewältigt werden muss.
Ja, das finde ich ja nochmal ganz gut, dieses Argument. Also ich bin auch nicht
jetzt dafür, auch wenn ich jetzt eben sage, es gibt diese realen Probleme und
die müssen angegangen werden und die sind ja auch, egal ob die AfD droht oder nicht, ja anzugehen.
Ja, Wohnraumknappheit und so etwas.
Aber ich glaube, du hast völlig recht, wenn du deutlich machst,
dass es jetzt nicht einfach die Kalkulation wäre, hätten die alle mehr Lohn,
würden die alle nicht AfD wählen.
Das glaube ich tatsächlich nicht, denn du hattest eben dieses Beispiel aus Japan,
lieber sterben, bevor mich ein Vietnamese pflegt.
Und genau diese Haltung ist ja so da.
Und das kannst du ja auch jenseits dieser AfD-Diskussion unglaublich gut nachvollziehen,
dass man sich darüber empört.
Deutschlandweit und in allen Regionen, wenn das Bürgergeld erhöht wird,
Dann gibt es da große Gruppen, Mehrheiten in Deutschland, die sagen,
ja, was sind die alle faul?
Warum muss ich die jetzt unterstützen?
Arbeit muss sich ja lohnen. Das bedeutet für die nie zu sagen,
ja die Löhne sind aber auch verdammt niedrig in Deutschland,
da müsste sich etwas dran ändern.
Das heißt, die ökonomische Lage, die ja eigentlich die ist, die am meisten lenkbar
ist, sowohl politisch als auch dann noch individuell und wirtschaftlich, wird.
Flächendeckend von einem Großteil der Deutschen als naturgegeben angenommen.
Ich kann das ändern an der Anzahl von Migranten. Ich kann mich weigern,
den Klimawandel anzuerkennen.
Da wird plötzlich geglaubt, da gibt es überall Stellschrauben.
Aber die ökonomische Ungleichheit, das niedrige Lohnniveau, das ist einfach so, wie es ist.
Und wir hatten ja jetzt diese Familienunternehmer im Salon.
Dann wird das immer noch so ein bisschen mit ja hier
wird noch was für das land getan hier arbeiten alle
zusammen ja aber die meisten zu ganz ganz schlechten
löhnen ja das wird aber alles so hingenommen also das ist das ist erstaunlich
dass wir ja daraus abgeleitet überhaupt keine ökonomische debatte finden und
als ich das wirtschaftskapitel von kra vorstellte im letzten salon dachte ich
ja als ich begann zu lesen jetzt wird er wahrscheinlich schon mal zu löhnen
und so irgendetwas sagen.
Wir machen so, wir holen ein Clip jetzt nach vorne, weil wir eh nicht zum Presseclub heute noch kommen.
Nur um mal in diesen Gemütszustand kurz reinzuschnuppern, den du gerade beschrieben hast.
Das gottgegebene, naturgegebene, nicht so hinterfragende ökonomische Gefüge, wie es halt ist.
Jörg Schönborn ist ja nun ein Journalist, den wir alle kennen.
Wir haben auch schon mit ihm gesprochen, wir waren ja auch schon mal im Presseclub.
Ja, er ist wirklich ein sehr guter Fragensteller, gerade für so offene Runden,
von denen man weiß, ja die Leute reden dann schon und so, wenn da vier Journalisten vor ihm sitzen.
Aber trotzdem, Jörg Schönborn kennt sich mit Zahlen aus, er präsentiert nämlich
immer diese Wahlumfragen und die ganzen demoskopischen Sachen.
Er ist selber, glaube ich, auch auf Intendantensuche gewesen.
Also wir reden über jemanden, der wirklich dieses ganze Gefüge des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Journalismus Journalismus über diese politische Journalismus Einflugschneise kennt.
Der 55 Minuten lang den Presseclub moderiert zum Thema Wohnen.
Und wir haben uns ja auch ein bisschen drüber lustig gemacht,
weil die Helena Steinhaus in ihrem Buch so geschrieben hat, wie das so ist,
wenn dann der Journalist plötzlich feststellt, ach so, ja, diese Dimension hat das Thema auch noch.
Und wir hören einfach nur den Sing-Sang, wie er sozusagen bevor den letzten
Zuschauer noch zuschaltet, also die Sendung ist schon gar nicht mehr in der
ARD, wir sind schon in dieser Viertelstunde dann nur noch bei Phoenix und so,
wie er plötzlich dieses kleine, spontane Fazit für sich zieht.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht bei der Vorbereitung der Sendung, dass wir so viel über
Markt und Staat sprechen.
Unbedingt, das ist der Schlüssel. Ich glaub, das ist auch dieser Punkt,
deswegen alle an einen Tisch.
Unemotional, es geht um Wohnen, es geht um Umgang von Grund und Boden.
Und wenn dann der Sozialismusvorwurf kommt, bitte nach Wien schauen oder in
die Schweiz, die schon seit Zürich verkauft, seit Jahrzehnten. Aus dem Netz noch.
Ja, das ist der totale Wahnsinn. Es geht um Markt und Stadt.
Also ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht, um was es sonst beim Thema Wohnen gehen kann.
Also außer wir können über Inneneinrichtungen diskutieren.
Das Thema Wohnen. Wenn wir jetzt mal, in Frankfurt leben 700.000 Leute.
Hier arbeiten im Dunstkreis 5 Millionen.
Das ist also wirtschaftlich bedeutend.
Hessen auf Augenhöhe mit Griechenland, was die volkswirtschaftliche Kraft angeht.
Und Frankfurt ist im Zentrum, wir sind eins der europäischen Top-Five-Regionen
und so weiter und so fort.
Egal auf welche Art und Weise hier Geld umgesetzt wird, ob es weil jemand das
Rechenzentrum betreibt in der alten Neckermann-Anlage oder hier die Bankentürme
oder in Eschborn die Börse oder was auch immer.
Die Hälfte dieses Geldes fließt am Monatsende beziehungsweise dann am darauffolgenden
Monats Anfang in Miet- oder Kreditableistung zum Thema Wohnen.
Dann reden die in der Sendung über das Wohnen, das wirklich die Hälfte ausmacht,
die Leute, 50 Prozent des monatlich verfügbaren Einkommens geht ins Wohnen.
Und dann stellt er fest, ah ja, so viel Markt und so viel Staat spielt dabei
eine Rolle. Und du denkst, nee, das ist der Markt, das ist der Staat.
Das Thema Wohnen ist das Thema.
Das Ernährungsthema, und wir wollen alle überleben, wird nicht getoppt davon.
Dass wir uns sehr teure iPhones kaufen, spielt gar keine Rolle im Vergleich.
Also das ist kaum sichtbar.
Die Leute verwohnen alle zwei Wochen hier ein iPhone in Frankfurt.
Und dann so eine Feststellung zu machen, nach 55 Minuten Diskussion,
auf die man sich vorbereitet hat, die in der Luft liegt, als Thema und so weiter
und so fort, finde ich einfach absurd.
Ich war ja in Peine an einer Schule, um dort über KI zu diskutieren und sollte
so einen kurzen Impulsvortrag halten und erfuhr, dass dort viele Schüler,
vor allem ja die Jungs, glauben, dass sie Millionär werden.
Und ich hatte mir vorher sowieso gerade diese ganzen Zahlen nochmal so mit Einkommen
so angekommen. Dann habe ich meinen Vortrag damit begonnen, dass ich sage,
ja, wie sie hier alle sitzen, kann ich ihnen sagen, sie werden alle nicht arbeitslos werden.
Sie werden sich immer das neueste iPhone leisten können.
Sie werden aber sehr wahrscheinlich nur ein kleiner Teil von ihnen wird sich
ein Eigenheim leisten können.
Und dann war schon so ein kleines Verschonen habe ich gesagt,
ja und wahrscheinlich wird höchstens einer von ihnen Millionär werden,
aber der gibt den anderen nichts ab. Und dann war das mal so rausgenommen direkt, ja.
Ja, ja.
Ja und die anderen werden natürlich im großen Teil Jobs haben,
wo sie 40, 50 Prozent des Lohns an die Vermieter übergeben.
Du wirst dir aussuchen dürfen, wo du, wo, es sagt dann immer,
du darfst dir aussuchen, wo du arbeitest, musst aber für zwei arbeiten und deine
Miete kostet für vier, also das ist einfach, der Drops ist gelutscht.
So, wenn also, du hast jetzt schon Visionen und so weiter angesprochen,
ich würde es auch nochmal strapazieren, wenn keine Perspektive da ist,
weil niemand mal, ach der Staat und der Markt ist ja mal Thema,
sollte es sein, ohne das kriegen wir es nicht hin.
Die Stellschraube nützt nicht, wir müssen uns das ganze Gefüge anschauen.
Das ist ja sozusagen, was da drin steckt.
Dann droht uns hier Ungemach und solange das nicht stattfindet im Diskurs.
Findet ja trotzdem Diskurs statt, aber dann eben so, wie er stattfindet.
Und Sabine Renevans auch zum Thema Ostdeutschland und so weiter,
sie ist glaube ich auch Autorin oder wie auch immer.
Die Namen kann man heute, kann jeder selber nachgoogeln, uns geht es heute nur
um die Ideen, die vorgetragen werden.
Nur um die Essenzen. Sie ist im heutigen Halt zugeschaltet und sagt zu diesem,
was passiert da mit der AfD und der Unterstützung und dem Gemütszustand und so weiter, folgendes.
Wir haben immer wieder moralische Empörung gezeigt in den letzten zehn Jahren.
Trotzdem ist die AfD immer stärker geworden. Und das Problem ist einfach,
je stärker der moralische Abscheu ist, diese Dämonisierung auch der AfD,
desto größer ist, glaube ich, in Teilen der Bevölkerung der Reiz,
sie dann erst recht zu wählen.
Weil dann hat man das Gefühl, okay, ich bin dann wenigstens böse,
aber nicht unwichtig oder schwach.
Ja, man möchte sich wichtig und bedeutend fühlen und zwar völlig zu Recht.
Und man hat auch ein Recht auf eine Vision und ihre, sagen wir mal,
in Griffweite darf sie sein.
Und wenn das nicht da ist, ist es die Aufgabe der Politik, dafür zu sorgen,
dass sie in Griffweite kommt. Und wenn die Politik das nicht schafft,
machen die halt irgendwas anderes. Die gehen dann in den ...
Es ist nicht der Protest, sondern es ist diese Abkehr einfach.
Dieses ... Ja. Dann steh ich außerhalb. Und wenn ihr sagt, das ist außerhalb,
will ich nicht weiter mitmachen und so weiter.
Und dann positioniert man sich da. Und die AfD macht jetzt dieses Angebot,
das haben vorher die Linken gemacht.
Jeder möchte ja auch ein bisschen vielleicht dann doch subversiv sein.
Und das ist so ein Subversionsangebot, weil das andere ja auch überhaupt nicht
subversiv ist oder sich natürlich auch besonders nochmal so hervorstellt.
Nee, das geht nicht, das geht nicht, das geht nicht. Also ist ja auch,
glaube ich, nochmal sehr reizvoll, wo alle so auf vernünftig tun.
Gut. Kommen wir auf deine Mobilität und so weiter zu sprechen,
bevor wir dann nochmal später zum Thema Flucht ein bisschen daran anknüpfen,
was wir eben schon versprochen haben.
Wir wollen über chinesische Autos sprechen.
Wir kommen erst später zu von der Leyen, was sie gesagt hat.
Das war aber für mich der Anlass zu sagen, wir reden mal über diese Autos.
Und der zweite Anlass war die IAA.
So heißt sie nicht.
Nein, so heißt sie nicht mehr.
Es scheint Ihnen sehr wichtig gewesen zu sein, dass sie nicht IAA heißt.
Es ist jetzt eine Mobility-Fair. Ihr werdet jetzt gleich mal hören,
was das eigentlich bedeutet.
Es soll keine Automesse mehr sein.
Zunächst aber fällt etwas anderes auf hier in der deutschen Welle, wird es reportiert?
Viele Chinesen, also dort, wenn ich, ja. Aber meinte sie jetzt,
die Deutschen Autobauer rekrutieren viele Chinesisch Sprechende oder lernen
tatsächlich viele Deutschen jetzt so Chinesisch, dass sie aus ihrem deutschen
Bildungsweg dann für VW fahren können?
Viele Chinesen also dort.
Aber meinte sie jetzt, die Deutschen Autobauer rekrutieren viele Chinesisch
Sprechende oder lernen tatsächlich viele Deutschen jetzt so Chinesisch,
dass sie aus ihrem deutschen Bildungsweg dann für VW Chinesisch sprechen können?
Auch.
Ja. Das ist erstaunlich.
Müssen sie. Also bei Cupra scheint es auch der Fall zu sein.
Und wenn ich zu dir sage, build your dreams, weißt du dann, was ich meine?
Inzwischen ja. Ja, es ist der abgekürzte BYD, der größte E-Mobilitätsautobauer
der Welt. Tesla überholt.
Ja, und zwar kann man sagen der BYD hat zum ersten Mal Volkswagen von der Spitze
der Automobilunternehmen in China verdrängt.
Und das sorgt natürlich für Unruhen. Und diesen Unruhen wollen wir nachgehen.
Was ist denn nun mit dieser chinesischen E-Mobilität?
Europa-Premiere bei Build Your Dreams, kurz BYD. Der CLU ist eines von zahlreichen
Elektroautos made in China.
Neben Teslas im ZS, die den Ton angeben.
BYD ist schon heute der weltgrößte Hersteller von E-Cars. Die Erfolgschancen
sind gut, denn die Fachwelt ist sich einig.
Autos aus China sind günstiger im Preis und technisch besser als vergleichbare
E-Autos aus Deutschland oder Frankreich.
So kommen die Manager mit großen Erwartungen und Selbstbewusstsein nach München.
Ja warum das günstiger ist, das werden wir uns nachher noch mal genauer ansehen,
aber jetzt können wir festhalten BYD hat diesen großen Vorteil früher einmal
Batteriehersteller gewesen zu sein,
also wir haben es jetzt nicht mit so einem gewachsenen uralten Autokonzern zu tun,
der sich jetzt zufällig neu entwickelt hat, sondern BYD kommt aus der Batterieherstellung
und die benötigten Ressourcen für Batterien und auch für E-Autos,
die sind in China eigentlich alle vorhanden. Das heißt, die müssen da ganz wenig importieren.
Ja, aber war das auch irgendwie Thema, dass in China mittlerweile mehr Batterien
hergestellt werden auf allen Ebenen, als der Weltmarkt gerade abkaufen kann?
Also da scheint so eine extreme Verdrehung, was ja immer die deutsche Wette
war, der Autobauer, dass sie nämlich das nicht in-house machen müssen,
weil der Weltmarkt es irgendwann zur Verfügung stellt.
Ja, es gibt Überkapazitäten. Also es gibt auch, vielleicht haben wir da noch
Zeit für, es gibt auch E-Auto-Friedhöfe in China.
Was ich aber zum Beispiel nicht wusste ist, dass weil diese E-Autos so günstig
sind in China, Tesla in China auch ganz andere Preise machen muss.
Zum Teil sind da die Teslas 40 Prozent günstiger in China als in den USA und
natürlich ist als Herstellungsort China nicht unerheblich für Tesla.
Es geht rundherum drüber, Eschenheimer Tor hier in Frankfurt ist eine sehr große Ladenfläche.
Wo Autos drinstehen und ich fand das so crazy, weil ich gucke auch gerade,
ich habe jetzt einfach mal gegoogelt chinesische Automarken Logos,
aber ich habe es jetzt nicht auf den ersten Blick wieder.
Es war jedenfalls so crazy, nicht nur, dass da vier Autos auf einer Ladenfläche stehen,
in der ansonsten auch 40 Autos hätte stehen können oder, also es war extrem
pompös, was einfach diesen Luxus, wir haben hier mal Raum und Sie können das
Probefahrt quasi fast im Laden machen und gleichzeitig stand gar kein Markenname
dran, es war nur das Zeichen.
Und man hat so gedacht, das muss irgendein Chinese sein. Aber es ist nicht BYD,
ich muss das nochmal an dem nochmal nachdenken.
Vielleicht Neo oder X-Peng.
Das ist viel spektakulärer.
Es war so ein fast geschlossener Kreis mit einem Dreieck, der unten so reinragt.
Irgendwie so habe ich es in Erinnerung.
Weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht. Wir hören mal weiter. Du hast es schon angesprochen.
Es ist ja gar nicht mehr die Automesse.
Ich habe einen höheren Wunsch. Ich bin sehr häufig mit meinem Fahrrad unterwegs
und kann aber auch S-Bahn fahren.
Ich finde keine App, in der ich das so kombinieren kann, dass ich einfach mal
einen cleveren Weg mit dem Fahrrad zur S-Bahn, das ist entweder der Fußweg,
das heißt 900 Meter gilt dann schon als weit und wird ab dann schon nicht mehr
empfohlen, was ich blöd finde.
Ich fahre auch gerne drei Kilometer zur S-Bahn, aber ich möchte gern wenig umsteigen.
Ich will einfach Fahrrad, S-Bahn, Fahrrad. Und keine Ahnung,
ist es eine Mobilitätsmesse?
Also hier scheint immer noch das Auto Mittelpunkt zu stehen.
Oder ganz, ganz teure E-Scooter.
Sonst hätte ich ja längst so eine App, die Mobilität ohne Auto gibt.
Aber es gibt bestimmt irgendwo Apps, die das machen. Also in deren Sicht nicht
nur für mich, sondern grundsätzlich gerne Empfehlung.
Wir hören mal weiter.
Eine neue Phrase kommt von deutschen Auto-Exekutiven auf. China-Speed.
Das ist, wie schnell sie fühlen, dass sie sich in die chinesische Auto-Industrie
bewegen müssen, die sich in eine Batterie-gepowerte Juggernaut entwickelt hat.
Also als Juggernaut wird das schon beschrieben. Also das Juggernautrad ist ja,
das kommt ja auch bei Marx vor, also das hat eigentlich keinen Führer,
sondern das vergrößert sich immer weiter und weiter frisst so alles in sich
hinein, wird immer größer und ist dann auch nicht mehr zu stoppen.
Die Amerikaner nennen das eigentlich Firewheel, das ist das Geschäftsmodell
von Amazon, das sich so selbst ernährt und so weiter.
In Theorie, ja. Ich würde mir ein chinesisches Elektroauto kaufen.
Ich fahre immer noch einen Mercedes zu meinem Alter. Ein toller Auto und ein Kombustionmotor.
Aber ich muss in die Zukunft schauen. Also wenn ich es vergleiche, ist Elektro schon toll.
Das ist ja spektakulär. Ich habe gar nicht drüber nachgedacht,
aber klar. Das ist ja die Automesse in Deutschland.
Wenn du die Chinesen fragst, wollt ihr da hin? Sagen die natürlich,
aber hallo, klar wollen wir unsere Autos da zeigen.
Und zwar kamen die mit der größten Delegation. Ich habe in Tagesschau,
war es aufgeschrieben, 70 Aussteller kamen aus der Volksrepublik und überhaupt
40 Prozent aller Aussteller in München stammen aus Asien.
Also wir sehen da diese Verschiebung ganz eindeutig und dann gibt es eine.
Toyota konnte man noch dulden so. Aber jetzt, wenn die ja wirklich übernommen.
Ja, das ist die große Frage. Also Kontinente, der Automobilzulieferer hat eine
Umfrage gemacht, können sich denn deutsche Autofahrer vorstellen,
überhaupt ein chinesisches Auto zu fahren. Denn da weiß man ja immer,
war immer so, ja willst du wirklich so.
Und angeblich, also laut dieser Umfrage, weiß nicht wie repräsentativ die ist,
45 Prozent. Und das ist ja richtig viel. Das hätte man überhaupt nicht gedacht.
Am Strich zähle ich, weil das ökonomisch nicht geht.
Also ich gehe auch irgendwie so Diskussionen von so Leuten, die sagen,
naja, so ein französisches Auto, ich weiß ja nicht oder so, also ich will immer ein deutsches.
Das ist offenbar ohne Berührungsängste jetzt und hier, die deutsche Welle hat
nochmal so einen Vergleich.
Der deutsche Regierung schüttelt sich, auf die Produktionsbedingungen in Europa zu reagieren.
Letzte Woche hat er 32 Milliarden Euro für vier Jahre an Verkaufsverluste für
die größte Produktion in Europa geholfen.
Diese Woche hat er Pläne eröffnet, EV-Ladestationen weltweit zu vergrößern.
Und die Regierung proposiert auch, die Anzahl der Papierarbeit,
die von Unternehmen benötigt wird, abzuschneiden.
In einem Land, in dem 80 Prozent der Firmen noch Fax-Maschinen benutzen,
ist es unklar, ob deutsche Odometer jemals China-Speed erreichen werden.
Der ein paar Monate alt ist, zur Automesse in Shanghai. Damals war das ZDF vor Ort.
Der Kampf um den wichtigsten Automarkt der Welt könnte kaum deutlicher sein
auf der wichtigsten Automesse, der Auto Shanghai.
Früher mussten chinesische Hersteller hier oft viel Geld bezahlen,
um einen Stand neben einer deutschen Premium-Marke zu ergattern.
Heute sind die Chinesen die Messestars und füllen ganz alleine mehrere Hallen.
Sie strotzen vor Selbstbewusstsein.
Ich glaube, wir haben einen neuen Industriestandard gesetzt bei der künstlichen
Intelligenz, sowohl beim autonomen Fahren als auch bei smarten Cockpits.
Und unsere Rechenleistung ist jetzt schon die stärkste der Welt für Serienfahrzeuge.
Ich habe die Clips jetzt nicht noch mal mitgebracht. Wir hatten mal so ein paar
davon zumindest kurz angespielt, wie es darum geht, dass das Cockpit immer mehr zum Computer wird.
Und das ist dort am stärksten ausgereift in China. China. Es ist auch so ein
großer Wunsch, dass man alles...
Per sprachbefehl bedienen kann ob sinnvoll ist oder nicht aber diese ganzen
spielereien würde man sagen die sind dort unglaublich ausgereift und der smartphone
auf rädern was er schon vor jahren mal so genannt wurde und was aber dann von
der deutschen autoindustrie ja nicht so richtig gesehen wurde also außer vielleicht
von jemand wie herbert dies.
Das hat sich dort so schnell alles entwickelt, weil sie ja nicht von der Autoindustrie
her kommen, sondern einmal von der Smartphone-Industrie.
Huawei hat ja jetzt wohl ein sehr konkurrenzfähiges Smartphone herausgebracht,
so waren zumindest so Tech-Blocks zu entnehmen.
Also es gibt jetzt eins mit einem eigenen chinesischen Chip.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob es Huawei oder Honor oder sowas war.
Was die Leistung steigert und was nicht so kann, verglichen mit dem iPhone,
wurde das herausgestellt. Und dann Batteriemarkt und all das.
Das ist schon sehr schwierig. Wo liegt das Problem für die deutsche Autoindustrie?
Wir hören hier noch mal Deutsche Welle.
Auch Europas Autobauer setzen auf Elektro.
Aber ihr Umstieg vom Verbrennermotor auf Batterie dauert Jahrzehnte.
Hunderte Fabriken müssen umgebaut, und unzählige Automodelle komplett neu entwickelt werden.
Die Milliardensummen müssen immer noch mit Benzin- und Diesel-Autos verdient werden.
Man hat da immer noch die Cash-Cow, muss damit aber diese Cash-Cow erledigen. Die Zahlen sind ja ...
Das ist ja auch ein bisschen ...
BYD verkauft jetzt mehr Autos in China als VW, während VW aber zu 95 Prozent
oder so noch Verbrenner verkauft.
Ja schon mehr.
Oder 90 Prozent.
Also schon, ja, also die, das Problem ist.
Weil die so verschwinden geringer als jedes Mal im Fernsehen.
Ja, ja, aber in China verkaufen die natürlich mehr Ehe-Mobilität. Ja.
Als in Deutschland. Ja. Anteilig, ja, ja. Aber es ist auch noch nicht so wirklich.
Nein, nein, nein. Es reicht es noch nicht so viel, weil die Autos teurer sind und.
Offenbar nicht so beliebt sind. Man kann es ja mal über die Subventionen gucken.
Also wir haben jetzt gehört, wo das Problem ist.
Also der chinesische Staat hat ja sehr stark subventioniert.
Und zwar ist das hier bei Le Monde nachzulesen,
der Staat habe seit 2009 nahezu 100 Milliarden US-Dollar in den Aufbau eines
Produktionssektors für E-Autos investiert.
Also 100 Milliarden US-Dollar, das ist jetzt einmal so unser Bundeswehr-Sondervermögen
für die nächsten zehn Jahre, das haben die nur für diese Branche getan.
Und da sind aber nicht nur...
Aber für 1,4 Milliarden Menschen, ne?
Ja gut, aber die fahren ja auch nicht alle Auto, ne? Aber 100 Milliarden ist schon viel.
Und die Subventionen gehen ja nicht nur dahin, dass es Kaufsubventionen gibt,
also wie eine Abfragprämie bei uns,
Sondern auch eben für die Produktion tatsächlich hat man da sehr viel.
Aber ich bin froh, dass du das relativierst und sagst, wir kommen jetzt gleich
zu diesem Subventionsthema im Ganzen.
Denn 100 Milliarden, ja, das ist schon viel Geld,
aber andererseits ist es vielleicht auch wiederum nicht so viel Geld,
beziehungsweise nicht so viel Geld, wie jetzt gewisse Leute annehmen und davon,
naja, wir gehen jetzt gleich mal rüber, gehen wir erstmal zu BYD.
Wir hören hier das Wall Street Journal.
Um BYDs schnellste Wachstum in China zu sehen, schaut nur auf die Verkaufsplätze.
BYD, das von Warren Buffett unterstützt wird, ist von 13. Platz im Jahr 2021
auf den höchsten Platz im Jahr 2022 gesprungen.
In diesem Zeitraum sind die Gesellschaften mehr als verdoppelt,
sie haben 1,86 Millionen Autos.
Das sind etwa 500 Millionen mehr Autos als Tesla. Wir haben viel Respekt vor den Autos in China.
Sie sind die größten Komponisten der Welt. In Bezug auf Volumen,
ist die Top-Auto-Firma, die EVs in China produziert, definitiv BYD.
Der Hinweis ist, dass es noch kein cooles EV-Modell ist.
Deshalb haben sie eine neue Serie von Autos mit Spezifikationen vorgestellt,
die Autokommentatore sagen würden, die Tesla Model 3 zu passen.
Während dieses Sealsedan für ungefähr 30.000 Dollar verkauft wird,
Manche BYD-Modelle verkaufen eine Hälfte davon.
Also wesentlich günstiger. Jetzt hier noch mal zu Teslas Nachteil.
BUID hat drei Hauptbereiche des Geschäfts. Es produziert Autos,
es produziert Batterien für seine Autos und es produziert auch Chips.
Bevor BUID eine elektrische Fahrzeugfirma war, war ihr Hauptfokus Batterien.
Und diese Batterie-Branche des Geschäfts sichert Stabilität auf der Verkaufschaft,
selbst während Verzerrungen ihre Gegner verfolgen.
Vergleichen Sie das mit Tesla, die die Mehrheit ihrer Batterien von außerhalb
der Verkaufschaften weiter ausführt.
Es gab eine Stimmung um Tesla von Anfang an über die Möglichkeit, Säle zu bekommen.
Die Idee war, dass sie so viele von ihnen kaufen würden, dass sie einen Preisabstand
haben und die Kosten niedriger werden könnten. Es kam nicht so niedrig wie sie
wollten oder so niedrig wie sie dachten, aber es kam dramatisch niedriger.
Obwohl das US-Gesetz in diese Bereiche des Geschäfts investiert,
braucht es auch Ausgaben, um die rauen und mittleren Zutaten,
die Batterie-Säle ausgestalten, zu produzieren.
Wenn man sich an die Zutaten für diese Säle denkt, Es ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt eine China-Spiele.
Ich denke an Lithium. Etwa 70 Prozent davon ist in China gereinigt.
Das ist für die Menschen hier in den USA ein bisschen beängstigend.
Ja, und das wird sich ja so schnell nicht ändern, beziehungsweise fragt man
sich dann schon, wie das eigentlich so zusammengeht mit dieser Konfrontationspolitik Amerikas.
Wie steht da Tesla dann etwa zum Beispiel dazu?
Das ist ja sowieso auch das iPhone.
Ja genau, das wertvollste Unternehmen und dann hat man sowas,
was man jetzt neben diesen Subventionen sagen kann ist, dass,
Die Regierung in China, die Hersteller gezwungen hat, eine Quote von E-Autos
zu erfüllen. Hier ja undenkbar.
Wir reden ja hier über Quoten, vielleicht mal bei Frauen im Aufsichtsrat oder so,
und die machen Produktionsquoten und sagen also ihr könnt das hier nur weiter
machen, wenn ihr eine gewisse Quote erfüllt.
Da kann man ja auch mal drüber nachdenken, wo wäre das alles angesprochen, sowas zu machen.
Die Quote war immer acht Prozent. Und dann ist Sigmar Gabriel als Wirtschaftsminister
nach China geflogen, um dagegen zu oponieren. Er hat gesagt,
reicht nicht vier Prozent. Unsere deutschen Autobauer kommen da nicht ran an
diese acht Prozent Flotten-E-Mobilität.
Und dann sind die Chinesen da das erste Mal hart geblieben. Und das war dann
auch für die Deutschen das Signal, Nee, die machen uns keine Zugeständnisse mehr, weil die 10,
15, 20 Jahre vorher lief das nämlich so, dass die Deutschen unbedingt auf den
chinesischen Markt wollten und der Automarkt stand ihnen einfach frei.
Die Chinesen haben dann nur gesagt, naja, aber bei der Solarbranche und so,
da müsst ihr ein paar Abstriche, also wir tauschen sozusagen die Branchen.
Ihr dürft unseren Autokäufermarkt haben, aber wir wollen die Solarbranche haben.
Deutschland kam ja dann nach Rot-Grün damals von 50 Prozent Markteinteil Solarenergie
auf alles abgestorben, alles nach China gewandert und im Tausch dafür war die
Autobranche in China so willkommen. Und dann haben die Chinesen gesagt,
nö, die 8 Prozent stehen.
Wir wollen Peking sauber haben und so weiter. Wir haben hier Smog-Probleme.
Seht ihr doch, uns geht's noch mehr um Umweltschutz als um Klima.
Und das war dann für alle das Signal, die meint das wirklich ernst.
Nun werden auch in China besonders günstige Autos gefördert.
Also es ist so, dass man diese Förderung zwar auslaufen lassen will auf Dauer,
aber es ist jetzt nochmal erstmal verlängert worden, also für Autos zum Preis von.
Umgerechnet weniger als 19.000,
Euro soll es dann sogar bis 2027 noch weitergehen, dass diese Autos besonders gefördert werden.
Ja, es ist völlig verrückt, wenn man jetzt Ursula von der Leyen hört.
Die hat ihre State of Union gehalten und dort ist eigentlich nichts Interessantes
gefallen, außer das hier, was ich mitgebracht habe. Wir hören mal rein, wie das beginnt.
But competition is only true as long as it is fair.
Zu oft sind unsere Firmen aus dem Börsenmarkt ausgeschöpft oder sind sie Opfer
von verdächtigen Praktiken.
Sie sind oft untergekürzt von Komponenten, die von enormen Staatsbeschränkungen ausführen.
Wir haben nicht vergessen, wie
Chinas unfaire Handlungsbedingungen unsere Solarindustrie betroffen haben.
Viele junge Unternehmen wurden von stark beschlossenen chinesischen Komponenten ausgedrückt.
Pioneering Companies had to file for bankruptcies?
Promisierende Talente, wenn sie nach Glück abseits suchen. Das ist der Grund,
weshalb Gerechtigkeit in der globalen Ekonomie so wichtig ist,
weil sie Leben und Lebensmittel beeinflusst.
Ganze Industrien und Gemeinschaften hängen davon ab. Wir müssen also klar über
die Risiken, die wir befinden, aufmerksam sein.
Ich würde sagen, China hat eine super Industriepolitik gemacht.
In Absprache mit den Deutschen. Wir leider nicht. Und das haben wir nun davon.
Vor allem diese Art von ökonomischen Kolonialismus, ja das ist unser Modell.
Da ist wieder diese Kränkung drin. Ja, ja. Gehen mit uns so um wie wir.
Also diesen ganzen Kram habe ich jetzt nicht mitgebracht, wo das auch immer
so steht. Ja und da die, aber mit unseren Maschinen oder was weiß ich.
Ja, das ist nun mal Weltmarkt. Genau. So, jetzt kommt der Sprung.
Also sie ist noch traumatisiert von den Solaranlagen und wir haben jetzt ja so verrückte Quoten,
dass dann China eigentlich 70 Prozent der gesamten,
der globalen Bedarfe an Photovoltaikanlagen einfach liefern könnte.
Also in China leben 1,4 von 8 Milliarden Menschen. Das ist grundsätzlich einfach ein hoher Anteil.
Ja, das stimmt.
Dann mit dieser, wir wollen hier so eine Aufstiegsgeschichte organisieren,
wir brauchen Märkte, die wir neu schaffen, statt erobern zu müssen.
Und dann sucht man sich halt diese Sachen aus. Ja, ist ja logisch.
Wir hören weiter von der Leyen.
And as we do not accept this distortion from the inside in our market,
we do not accept this from the outside.
So I can announce today that the Commission is launching an anti-subsidy investigation
into electric vehicles coming from China.
Also diese Sprache ist ja völlig falsch und das versteht ja jeder.
Distortion of our markets.
Nee, da werden ja nicht die Märkte zerstört. Die Märkte funktionieren ja wunderbar.
Wir sehen es ja, wie die Nachfrage ist und so weiter.
Und die Leute wollen ja sogar diese Autos haben.
So ganz gezielt. Das kann sie auch mal so deutlich sagen. Es sind die Unternehmen,
die kaputt gehen, denn wir wollen ja einen E-Mobilitätsmarkt.
Wir wollen ja, dass sich jeder an E-Mobilität, wenn schon nicht das Auto verzichten,
dann wenigstens ein E-Auto, wenn neu angeschafft wird.
Nur die Leute, die nicht viel Geld haben, sollen gefälligst so lange warten,
bis irgendwann sich Audi auch entschließt, mal ein günstiges Produkt zu machen.
Und da werden wir uns dann natürlich als Politik nicht reinmischen.
Und ich frage dich jetzt auch, hast du den Eindruck, wenn du über die deutsche
Autoindustrie nachdenkst,
dass dort nur der freie Markt, also ich erinnere mich da an so Stefan Weil Aussagen,
herrlicher, zu Corona Zeiten auch ganz tolle Aussagen und Abwrackprämie.
Ich meine bei Subventionsdiskussionen, wenn wir diese Betriebsstilllegung wegen
Corona, oder wir bezahlen euren Lohn.
Das Bundesministerium für Arbeit und Soziales bezahlt den Lohn,
der ansonsten tarifmäßig komplett durchgepamperten und so weiter,
das sind doch auch alles Subventionen.
Wir bezahlen doch viel mehr, als ich finde.
Diese 100 Milliarden ist doch geschenkt, wir haben doch 30 Milliarden alleine
jährlich und zwar in absoluten Zahlen,
immer noch auf Verhältnis Bevölkerungsgröße und so weiter, was wir investieren
für Dienstwagenprivilegien hier und irgendwelche, ja klar könnt ihr eine eigene
Bank gründen und so weiter, Zugeständnisse und klar bezahlen wir eure Löhne und so.
Und ach bei euch habt ihr jetzt irgendwie diese neuen Werkverträge und die müssen
aufstocken? Na klar stocken wir für euch auf.
Dienstwagen, ach Porsche ist auch ein Dienstwagen. Ja ja ist auch ein Dienstwagen. Ja wunderbar.
Wir hatten mal diesen Ausschnitt irgendwann hier in den 29er von diesem Kelenius,
also vom Daimler Chef, der dann so sagte, ja ich weiß nicht ob unsere Gewinne
nächstes Jahr nochmal so hoch werden,
weil ja nächstes Jahr dann kein Kurzarbeitergeld mehr gezahlt wird.
Dass du ja ganz klar sagst, die haben uns das hier subventioniert.
Also es ist eine völlig verlogene Diskussion, die hier aufgemacht wird.
Und da muss man erst mal ein bisschen Abstand nehmen und was anderes sich anhören.
Dann habe ich bei Al Jazeera mir dort drei Experten angehört.
Andi Mock, der ist von so einem Globalization Think Tank. Steven Erlanger von den New York Times.
Und Ferdinand Dudenhöfer, den kennen wir, unser Autopapst, war dort auch zugeschaltet.
Und wir hören jetzt mal rein, als erstes Andy Mock skizziert nochmal das Dilemma.
It's incredibly difficult to cannibalize your existing businesses.
Ja, sich selbst zu diskutieren, kann man sich vorstellen, ist schwierig,
aber wir sind hier ganz im Feld des freien Marktes.
Also eigentlich muss man sagen, ja, das ist das Dilemma, das der Markt mit sich
bringt und man kann dieses Dilemma dadurch etwas auflösen,
indem man zum Beispiel dann staatlich Quoten macht und entsprechende Förderungen
und das hat man ja lange Zeit versäumt und macht es ja auch jetzt nicht richtig.
Ja genau, jetzt vor allem, wo ich drüber nachdenke, wir haben Audi,
BMW und Mercedes, also diese, wir machen mit Tesla, also wir suchen nach Tesla Publikum.
Und alle drei machen im Gleichschritt nicht die E-Mobilitätswende.
Das ist doch ein Fall für das Kartellamt eigentlich. Also da gibt es doch Absprachen.
Da wurde doch eine Brandmauer gemeinsam hochgezogen gegen die E-Mobilität.
Das haben die doch nicht jeder für sich gemacht und sich zufällig dann bei der
Automobil Mobility Messe getroffen, um sich abzufeiern, wie gut ihre Märkte funktionieren.
Steven Erlanger von der,
New York Times sagt, Credits to China.
Die vorher keine Autos hatten, macht einen großen Teil Sinn.
Also, alle Kredite an China.
Und natürlich, die Subsidien, wie Sie wissen, funktionieren beide Wege,
weil westliche Länder oder die Konsumenten für elektrische Autos verkaufen.
Darum muss es eigentlich gehen, dass Leute, wenn man sagt, das ist jetzt unser
Konzept, also man kann ja auch in Frage stellen, ob das so sinnvoll ist mit
dieser E-Mobilität und wie viel Umweltverheerung damit auch wiederum einhergeht.
Und man kann natürlich auch mal überlegen, ob man nicht tatsächlich mal eine
Mobility Fair macht und mal darüber nachdenkt, wie kann man dann den Individualverkehr
möglichst reduzieren, also nur noch dort, wo er tatsächlich vor Nöten ist, installieren.
Für die innerstädtischen Verkehr.
Für die innerstädtischen Verkehr, aber da gibt es ja in den Städten ist ja sehr
viel, was man ausbauen kann, was möglich wäre.
Also hier in Frankfurt läuft es ja ziemlich gut und hier steht man ja eher eine
halbe Stunde mit dem Auto für zwei Kilometer und wäre mit der S-Bahn besser
gefahren. Aber man kann ja noch mal über viele Konzepte nachdenken,
auch Stichwort Bahn, also das wären ja auch noch alles andere Angebote.
Aber wenn es nun jetzt irgendwie Staatsdoktrinen ist, dass man sagt E-Mobilität
ist unser Ding, dann um die Umwelt zu schützen, dann muss man ja sagen,
dann macht das ja China genau richtig.
Ferdinand Dudenhöfer, den ich ja eigentlich immer sehr schätze,
ist auch hier sehr, sehr und zugleich fassungslos über das, was von der Leyen da gemacht hat.
Wir denken, es gibt unfaire Wettbewerbsmethoden, aber keine Beweise.
Niemand kann so ein Statement verstehen.
Warum kommt es nicht mit Beweisen? A.
Ja, sehr gut. Finde ich wunderbar. Und wir wissen jetzt noch gar nicht,
warum Sie das jetzt so auf die Agenda gesetzt haben.
Also bei der State of Union ist ja wirklich sehr viel geredet,
so wir als Europa und unsere lange Geschichte und dann kommt sie aber mal mit sowas Konkretem.
Das war ja sonst nicht so viel dieser Art zu hören in ihrer Rede dort.
Ach, das wollte einfach Matthias Döpfner hat das den Autokonzern oder eingeredet, wie auch immer.
Also Dunhöfer hat jetzt eine andere Erklärung. Also man weiß ja eigentlich,
Macron will ja einen anderen China-Kurs, geht da hin und sagt ja Handel und
so weiter, ist auch wichtig. und jetzt,
Wir haben ja natürlich auch die deutsche Autoindustrie im Verdacht,
dass die jetzt hier mitgemischt hat und dann vielleicht nochmal Herr Döpfner
ist auch nochmal als Autoliebhaber da irgendwie reingesprungen.
Aber Dudenhöfer hat da nochmal eine andere Erklärung.
Und wurde EU-Präsident. Die französische Automobilindustrie ist sehr, sehr schwach in China.
Sie hat im Prinzip keine Verkaufe, sie ist nicht sichtbar.
Also für Frankreich ist es kein Risiko, wenn wir in Europa Verhandlungsgrenzen
und Tarife gegen die Chinesen installieren. Sie können nichts verlieren.
Sie können nur gewinnen, weil sie ihre teureren Fahrzeuge verkaufen können.
Für die Abwendung der Folgen des Klimawandels planen wir eine Verschuldung von
10 Prozent BIP ein. Wir haben verglichen, das wären in Deutschland 350 Milliarden.
Wieso sind die Franzosen in der Lage das zu fordern und wir nicht?
Und letzte Woche oder so haben ja die Franzosen dieses große Programm vorgestellt.
Beispielsweise kickstart der wärmepumpen und so weiter also dieses riesige
programm das so wenn man so grob irgendwie ja das scheint
so dieses zehn prozent bittverschuldungsprogramm irgendwie zu sein und
damals spielte ja an dem text schon eine rolle dass die franzosen das
neue volksauto suchen ja dass es diese große ausschreibung
und so weiter gab und das wäre natürlich super attraktiv wenn man jetzt eine
zollschranke hat die alle preise die die chinesen rein subventionieren wieder
drauf legt um darüber diesen französischen wir kaufen hier unser französisches
volksauto für den innerstädtischen und kurzen verkehr und so weiter anschiebt.
Was ich auch ehrlicherweise politisch gesehen ziemlich clever finde,
weil klar beim auto ist es noch ein bisschen einfacher als jetzt bei der milch,
aber wir haben so viele weltmärkte, also was so branchen und produkte angeht,
die brauchen wir gar nicht alle.
Und bei der mobilität, also wenn man gleichzeitig eine klimawandel ein bisschen
abwendung macht, ist immer noch Individualverkehr, aber wenigstens E-Mobil.
Und man macht gezielt ein kleineres Auto und man beschränkt den Markt dann auch
darauf, das ist das Angebot.
Ja, ich befürchte allerdings, dass das nicht so sein wird, denn Reuters hat am 20.
September folgende Meldung veröffentlicht. Frankreich hat am Mittwoch neue Regeln
für die Förderung von Elektroautos veröffentlicht, die in China hergestellten
Elektroautos ausschließen.
Auch wenn die europäischen Autohersteller keine erschwinglicheren Konkurrenzmodelle
auf dem französischen Markt anbieten.
Die französische Regierung bietet den Käufern derzeit einen Anreiz von 5000
bis 7000 Euro in bar für förderungswürdige Modelle, um mehr Elektroautos auf die Straße zu bringen.
Gesamtkosten dann eine Milliarde Euro pro Jahr.
Und man möchte nun jetzt nicht, dass diese staatlichen Subventionen den chinesischen
Autoherstellern zukommen und wenn man, also was ich so gelesen habe,
Experten gehen jetzt nicht davon aus, dass man da jetzt bei dieser Überprüfung
in dem Sinne viel finden wird, weil ich meine, es gibt diese Forderungen da
in China, aber die sind jetzt nicht so verrückt hoch, dass man sagen kann,
die können es halt einfach wesentlich günstiger machen aufgrund von niedriger Lohnkosten.
Die Sachen sind vor Ort. Das Know-how wurde lange Zeit nur dahingehend aufgebaut.
Und was aber trotzdem passieren kann, ist, dass man einfach das so als fadenscheinige
Argumentation nutzt, um dann Schutzzölle zu machen von 27 Prozent oder so.
Also es gibt ja bereits auch schon 10 Prozent Zoll drauf.
Das heißt, es ist ja gar nicht so, dass man da gar nichts jetzt gerade hat.
Also es ist wirklich sehr merkwürdig.
Aber hier Dudenhöfer sagt, gut für Frankreich macht das jedenfalls keinen Unterschied,
wenn man sich da mit den Chinesen anlegt, was aber auch wiederum,
also du sagst, es ist schlüssig und das ist es auch in diesem Modell ja.
Und dann wieder höchst widersprüchlich, weil Macron immer wieder Europa gesagt
hat, wir müssen mehr mit den Chinesen und das gehört nicht so sehr auf die Amerikaner.
Also es steht und fällt alles, ob man jetzt wirklich ein Angebot machen kann,
ein E-Mobil, das attraktiv ist und unter 20.000 Euro kauft.
Wenn es das gibt, würde ich sagen, es hat absolut Sinn, dann so eine Zollschranke
einzuziehen, so wie wir das ja auch beim Stahl und so weiter.
Wenn wir ihn mit klimaneutralen Erhitzungsmethoden hergestellt kriegen,
sollten wir das, was die anderen darüber sparen, dass sie es immer noch mit
Kohle, Gas und wie auch immer herstellen, einfach drauf packen.
Gut, dass wir eine Zollstranke haben, die dem Klima hilft. Hier geht es glaube
ich mehr um eine wirkliche Abschottung der Industrie.
Aber das geht ja von Anfang an einher, ne?
Ja, ja.
Roseland von der Leyen hat es ja vorgestellt als die Wachstumsstrategie.
Ja, ja. Und dieses ökonomische Argument ist natürlich auch das Passierende.
Naja, wir hören mal hier weiter. Es ist sehr schön, bei Al-Jazeera wird Professor
Ferdinand Dudenhöfer da einfach mit Ferdi angesprochen.
Aber die Deutschen würden verlieren, oder, Ferdi, weil Volkswagen,
der größte europäische Fahrer, EVs, elektrische Fahrzeuge, in China produziert.
Gibt es da wirklich Einigkeit, Ferdi, innerhalb der EU, sogar in dieser Frage
eines Handelskampfes über Sechsen?
Absolut. Die deutschen Fahrer, selbst BMW und Mercedes, verkaufen ca.
30-40% ihrer weltweiten Verkaufe in China.
Ja, und damit will man jetzt wem helfen gerade? Deswegen ist Ferdi auch sehr
verwundert, wie Habeck auf den Vorschlag von von der Leyen reagiert hat.
Das Strange ist, dass unser Sekretär der Ökonomie, Herr Habeck,
das Publikum gesagt hat, dass es eine gute Sache ist, dass die EU-Kommission
eine Analyse machen wird.
Niemand versteht Es ist ein großer Risiko für die deutsche Kohleindustrie und,
um ehrlich zu sein, man kann besser sein, wenn man Barrieren schafft.
Man wird besser sein, wenn man mit mehr Wettbewerb kommt und in Höhe geht und
nicht in Handelsbarrieren. Es könnte sein, dass Europa in eine Handelskrieg gegen China geht.
Das könnten die nächsten Schritte sein, wie Donald Trump es vor einigen Jahren gemacht hat.
Verschuldet sich dafür, um sich Mobilität zu kaufen und macht sich da sehr viele
Gedanken darüber und das aufsummiert 500 Millionen Menschen in Europa potenziell,
dass man glaubt, das könnte man politisch steuern irgendwie, ist ja absurd.
Jackie Wong hat im Wall Street Journal geschrieben, die europäische Autoindustrie
beginnt wie ein Reh im Scheinwerferlicht eines chinesischen Elektrofahrzeugs zu wirken.
Das ist ein gutes Bild. Ja nochmal Steven Erlanger von der New York Times.
Das Beste für den Vereinigten Staaten wäre es, chinesische EVs in den Markt
zu lassen. Das wäre das Beste für amerikanische Konsumenten.
Sie hätten günstige, sichere und gut ausgestattete elektrische Fahrzeuge,
die gut für den Planeten sind.
Natürlich wäre dies nicht so gut für einige inkumbente amerikanische Automaker.
But again, politics is all about prioritizing and if indeed climate change is such a big threat. A.
Und ich meine, die Süddeutsche hat im August über eine Studie berichtet,
dass dieses Ziel mit E-Mobilität von 2030 in weite Ferne rückt.
Also eigentlich sollen ja 15 Millionen Elektroautos auf deutschen Straßen unterwegs sein.
Man erwartet jetzt, dass es wohl die Hälfte werden. Das könnte wieder ein Baufiasko
geben und wenn man das jetzt noch mit Zöllen und so weiter hinbekommt,
dann sind es vielleicht noch weniger.
Meine persönliche Erfahrung ist, ich habe ja kein Auto und keinen Führerschein.
Ich fahre also immer mal Uber, sagen wir mal so viermal die Woche.
Ich habe sogar eine Standardfahrt, die ich immer mache und meine Beobachtung
ist, ich steige eigentlich nicht mehr in ein reines Verbrennerauto.
Also da, wo wirklich viel gefahren wird, wo Umsatz da ist, wo man die Flotte
relativ schnell durchleiert, sind die schon aussortiert, diese Verbrenner.
Also der Markt ist schon so viel weiter, als es politisch noch zugestanden wird.
Wäre jetzt irgendwie...
Also Dinge nicht mehr auf, wäre noch so der Hilferuf des.
Ja, das sind wieder die Partikularinteressen, die man dann damit befriedigen
kann, wobei hier noch gar nicht klar ist, welche oder gibt es überhaupt diese
Partikularinteressen oder ist es allein das Primat des politischen.
Haben wir hier in sehr enger Absprache mit von der Leyen und Biden noch mal
eine Anti-China-Strategie, die ganz gut zu fahren ist über die Autoindustrie.
Dudenhöfer hier noch einmal mit einem ganz klaren Gedanken.
Batterien zu formen, eine neue Area zu formen, in der die Kosteneffizienz im
Batteriefeld interessant sein wird.
Sieh, W, zum Beispiel, hat einen Link zu Gaosheng, eine chinesische Firma,
die Batterien produziert.
Sie arbeiten also zusammen. Warum sollten wir nicht zusammenarbeiten?
Ja, darum muss es eigentlich jetzt gehen, wenn man tatsächlich den Klimawandel priorisiert.
Olaf Scholz war natürlich auch auf der Mobility-Messe, hat auch nochmal,
das habe ich aber jetzt nicht mitgebracht, das müsst ihr mir glauben,
dann gesagt, ja, wir können, also die Protest, Klimaprotest,
das kann er schon verstehen, also es gehört auch zu einer Demokratie dazu,
Aber er kommt sich da schon, er sei etwas irritiert, weil hier würde man doch
sehen, wie klimaneutral jetzt schon die Autos werden können.
Und dann denke ich immer, ja, aber am allerwenigsten die deutschen oder europäischen.
Und außerdem sei es ja eine Mobility-Messe jetzt.
Ja, also viele Klimaaktivisten, denken wir darüber nach. Aber auch sonst, Scholz, besänftigend.
In den 80er Jahren hieß es, jetzt überrollen japanische Autos alle anderen Märkte.
20 Jahre später waren es Autos made in Korea.
Heute sind es vermeintlich chinesische Elektroautos.
Ja, auch außerhalb Deutschlands werden gute Autos gebaut und entwickelt.
Schön, dass so viele internationale Hersteller und Zulieferer hier in München
sind. Willkommen! Und zugleich steht doch die internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
des Autolandes Deutschlands völlig außer Frage.
Also, die Automobilmesse Mobility findet ja in München statt,
weil sie in Frankfurt sich nicht mehr willkommen gefühlt hat.
Beispielsweise, weil wir einen Bürgermeister hatten, der sagte,
ich sollte eine Eröffnungsrede halten. Nö.
Ich fahre an dem Tag Fahrrad.
Peter Feldmann hat damals gesagt, also sagen wir es mal so, er hat dort eine
Eröffnungsrede gehalten und dann war die Branche sich einig,
wir brauchen eine neue Stadt dort. Wir haben sie also richtig vertrieben aus
Frankfurt und das finde ich auch gut.
Ja, Scholz ist sich da ja sicher. Wir wissen ja schon, bei Demografie hat er
ja auch so seine eigenen Zahlen im Kopf. Also ich sag mal so,
rund 35 Prozent der weltweit exportierten E-Fahrzeuge stammten im vergangenen Jahr aus China.
35 Prozent im Jahr davor waren es nur 25 Prozent.
China hat im letzten Quartal Japan als den größten Auto-Exporteur der Welt abgelöst.
Hängt auch damit zusammen, dass man natürlich sehr viel jetzt nach Russland
exportiert von chinesischer Seite aus.
Aber zu sagen, dass da irgendwie man gar keine Sorgen haben muss,
ich sehe das jetzt gesagt.
Zehn Prozent Sprung in einem Jahr, wo ist das Problem?
Ich sehe das irgendwie ein bisschen anders und auch Ulrike Malmendinger.
Malmendier, also die Wirtschaftsweise macht sich jetzt nicht direkt Sorgen um
die Autoindustrie, sondern sie legt auch mal den Fokus noch auf was anderes.
Ja, also was die Automobilindustrie selber, die großen deutschen Automobilfirmen
betrifft, mache ich mir im Augenblick nicht die größten Sorgen.
Sie sind jetzt halt sehr langsam in diesen Sektor der E-Autos reingegangen.
Fangen da auch mehr so am oberen Marktsegment an.
Bedeutet, es gibt mengenmäßig nicht so viele Umsätze, das könnte allerdings
gewinnmargenmäßig keine schlechte Idee sein. Ich denke, die haben das schon gut durchgerechnet.
Da habe ich eigentlich noch ziemlich großes Vertrauen, dass wir es schaffen.
Also das heißt, wir reden hier überhaupt nicht darum, kriegen wir eine Verkehrswende
hin? Also wir reden nur darum, können die weiterhin noch ihre Gewinne maximieren?
Und das geht natürlich mit Luxus-Demosiden besser.
Idealerweise gebündelt damit, dass wir in Deutschland die Super-Super-Batterie
entwickeln oder dass das Netzwerk für Ladestationen oder die Plug-and-Ladestationen
dann dominiert, so ähnlich wie im Computerbereich man mit Operation Systems dominieren kann.
Das wäre dann schon die Hoffnung, das bräuchte es dazu.
Allerdings mache ich mir schon ein wenig Sorgen um die angegliederten Industrien,
die Zulieferer, wirklich darauf
spezialisiert sind, die Komponenten für Verbrennermotoren zu liefern,
die wir im Augenblick noch brauchen, dass da in den Regionen,
in den Firmen Umschulungen stattfinden, dass da umgeschwenkt wird auf zukunftsorientierte Produktion.
Da mache ich mir ein bisschen mehr Sorgen, ob wir da vielleicht Insolvenzen
und Firmenpleiten sehen werden.
Also das deutsche Berufsschulsystem, das duale System, auf das alle so stolz
sind, Von dem wir jetzt schon wieder hören, naja, so viele Schulabbrecher wie
nie, so viele Akademiker wie nie, dazwischen wird es irgendwie zum Niemalsland und so weiter.
Da stehen doch eigentlich die Schüler schon seit Jahren dort den Lehrern auf
den Tischen und sagen, zeigt mir nicht jetzt ein Jahr lang, wie der Diesel funktioniert.
Lass uns doch mal über Batterien reden. Dann hast du fast wie nach der Wende
so, ich weiß, ihr wollt alle Englischunterricht haben, aber wir haben noch so viele Russischlehrer.
Und dann hängen alle fest so in diesem...
Naja und für die Zulieferer wird das natürlich ein großes Problem und das ist
dann auch für die für die Arbeiter dort ein Ding.
Ich war gerade gestern bei der, vorgestern bei der IG Metall mit Ole zusammen
um über Wachstum und Wachstumszwang und sowas zu sprechen und da waren natürlich
auch Leute dann die in Zuliefererbetrieben arbeiten und da ist dann schon die
Sorge groß und es ist dann für die,
dass sie auch gar nicht wissen wer richtet sich jetzt nach uns.
Ich glaube, da sind auch wieder Verwerfungen, die drohen in ganz erheblichem Maße.
Aber trotzdem, ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen, die zwei großen Zulieferer,
die wir so kennen, Bosch und Intercontinental.
Bosch, also jedes E-Fahrrad, das ich sehe, sagen wir 95 Prozent,
ich kenne eigentlich nur von Specialized.
Also der Fahrradmarkt Specialized, dass sie ihre eigenen Motoren verbauen.
Alle anderen kaufen bei Bosch. Also wir haben da schon so eine große Wende zur,
nicht nur E, sondern eben auch Mobilität.
Und bei Continental, also die haben jetzt irgendwann auch schon vor Jahren diesen
Elektromotor, der im Autoreifen selbst verbaut ist.
Also du machst einfach das Ding ans Auto dran und alles, was du brauchst, ist da reingebaut.
Du musst nur Strom zuliefern, ja und dann ist da einfach ein entsprechender
Motor drin. Also klar, es gibt dann immer noch hunderte andere,
weil es geht ja auch um Polsterbezüge und wie baut man das Cockpit und so weiter.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass man jetzt das so abschieben kann auf die Zulieferer
und so weiter, die dann irgendwie.
Wir springen jetzt mal ein bisschen, was könnte die Rettung sein?
Und zwar, die Deutsche Welle hat dann nochmal gesagt, ja, die Marke,
die Brand, die könnte natürlich etwas sein, was für uns relevant wäre.
Also die Brand als unique selling selbst wenn man technisch noch nicht so weit ist?
Wir hören von den Legacy-Fahrern, dass sie hoffen, dass ihre Markenverständnis
und ihre Geschichte sie durch diese große Veränderung sehen werden.
Naja, ob das denn so sein wird, wir haben diese Umfrage, 45 Prozent der Deutschen
wären auch bereit ein chinesisches Auto zu kaufen.
Wird das in 10, 20 Jahren noch so sein, dass man sagt, wow, ist aber ein Mercedes?
Im Ausland war das immer so, aber inzwischen hat man ja gesehen,
wie schnell Tesla das verschieben kann und man sagt, oh, der hat sogar einen Tesla.
Also bei der Frage kommt es echt nur darauf an, wie du das operationalisierst.
Und deswegen gucken wir uns jetzt auch mal was aus dem Premium-Segment noch
an oder hören uns das an. Ich kann es aber mal empfehlen, wirklich sich das
hier anzusehen. Es gibt einen YouTube-Channel, der sich nur mit Autos beschäftigt, also ein YouTuber.
Dieser Channel heißt Fully Charged Show und wir sehen uns, hören uns jetzt an.
Er testet einen Xpeng P7.
Das ist ein Auto, das würde ich sofort nehmen.
Und jetzt kommt meine Pointe, wenn es noch ein Verbrenner wäre.
Also Koblenz kommst mit E-Mobilität sagen wir mal noch nicht so weit,
um mich auch gleich zu rechtfertigen. Aber es hat Flügeltüren,
die so nach oben rauf gehen.
Und es ist so eine Mischung aus Batman und James Bond, wie du darin,
also es sieht spektakulär gut aus. Also ich glaube, du wärst beeindruckt,
wenn ich das nächste Mal hierhin komme nach Frankfurt und das Auto fahren würde.
Wir hören uns aber jetzt mal hier den Profi an, was er zu diesem Auto sagt, was das alles kann.
Ich buche es derzeit mal für mich.
Ja, ja, schau dir das Ding mal an.
Ich kann nicht warten, bis das Ding in Europa anfängt. Ich kann nicht warten,
bis die ersten Kunden mit diesem Auto ankommen.
Denn es wird den Hell aus den Legacy-Autoherstellern, die ihren süßen Zeit haben, beschweren.
Es wird sie total erschrecken, denn das ist das Auto, das wir von BMW, von Audi gesehen haben.
Ein besprochenes EV auf einer richtigen EV-Plattform mit riesiger Range und
großartiger Technologie.
Nicht ein Relikt von letztes Jahr, das ein paar Batterien auf den Knochen gelegt
hat. This is the real deal.
Oh, dieses Auto wird ein bisschen wehtun. in 6,7 Sekunden, in der stärkeren
Variante 4,3, also wie auch immer, cooles Ding.
Wir hören noch rein, was das so kann, wie du mit dem kommunizieren kannst, mit diesem Auto.
Also das bricht dich jetzt ja an. Weil wenn ich nämlich die Bilder drin,
das sieht toll aus. Also man kann den Arm einfach mal in der Mitte ablegen,
ohne dass jemand, ich muss aber schalten, kannst du das machen so?
Nee, das musst du natürlich nicht mehr schalten. Hier, wir hören mal,
wie du dieses Auto steuern kannst, da ist deine Alexa nix gegen.
Es gibt keinen Schalter, um zwischen Eco- und Sport-Mode zu wechseln.
Wo ist es? Wie machst du das? Musst du dich in die Einstellungen einigen und
viele Dinge drücken? Ja.
Oder du kannst das beste Geräuschkommandosystem, das ich je in einem Auto erlebt habe, benutzen.
Hands down the best. Watch this.
Engage Eco-Mode, öffne mein Fenster. Engage Sport-Mode. Das ist so schnell!
Ich dachte nicht, dass das so gut funktionieren würde, mit diesem sorten Mongrel-Auto,
das chinesisch ist, aber in den Niederlanden und in der UK registriert ist.
Aber es funktioniert perfekt. Es ist unglaublich gut. Und wenn du Software mit
dieser Qualität hast, kannst du alles in den Touchscreen verstecken,
weil du es nicht so viel brauchen wirst. Du brauchst es nicht zu beobachten.
So wir feiern übrigens auch 41 jahre nightrider.
Toll ja das passt doch gut und wie hat dich das jetzt angesprochen vielleicht
dass du doch noch einen führerschein machst und dann bei mir auto fährst ja
denn ich habe keine alexa.
Du meinst jetzt, deine Alexa.
Du hast eine Siri oder was ist das bei dir?
Ich habe eine Siri und ich führe wirklich einen sehr guten Siri-Lifestyle.
Also man kommt doch ziemlich weit und Leute sind dann doch immer wieder beeindruckt,
was sie bisher nicht wussten, wie sie mit dem Telefon reden können und was es für sie so tut.
Und das ist natürlich hochattraktiv und ich muss auch sagen,
wir haben jetzt diese ganze AI-Wende, die potenziert das ja alles nochmal. Also Spracherkennung.
In drei Jahren wird sich jeder auf Spracherkennung verlassen.
Auch bei 150 Kameras auf der Autobahn. Es wird wahrscheinlich nicht sehr laut
sein in dem X-Peng. Aber selbst wenn es laut würde, wäre, das Mikrofon hängt
über dir. Es ist alles geregelt.
Es passt genau in die Zeit, dass wir jetzt diese Verknüpfung.
Alle Unternehmen machen das jetzt.
Ja, sehr gespannt.
Ich glaube, ich kaufe mir vielleicht nicht ein Auto, aber ich werde doch noch
mal mir das genauer anschauen, wie man so... Also ich werde keinen Führerschein
machen, aber ich will schon mal ein bisschen rumcruisen.
Also du willst fahren lassen?
Ja, aber trotzdem alleine im Auto sein. Ich kenne ja überhaupt nicht das Gefühl,
in ein Auto zu steigen und wohin zu fahren. So alleine.
Und ich glaube, das werde ich aber noch vor meinem Rentenalter erleben.
Du wirst es noch erleben, ohne den Führerschein gemacht zu haben?
Wochenendausflüge, genau. Ohne Führerschein, aber trotzdem Wochenendausflüge
alleine in meiner eigenen individuellen Mobilität.
Ich möchte zum Rhein fahren, dort wandern gehen und wieder zurück. So.
Ich bin gespannt.
Die Chinesen treiben das jetzt so hart nach vorne. Ich glaube,
es dauert wirklich nicht mehr lange.
Und ich habe auf TikTok, nee nicht auf TikTok, auf Instagram Videos gesehen,
wie die selbstfahrenden Taxis in der Bay Area da in San Francisco und so weiter
Schlange stehen. weil sie sich einfach gegenseitig blockieren und dann den Knoten nicht mehr und so.
Also die sind auch dran, die letzten Hürden noch zu nehmen, glaube ich.
Wir werden sehen.
Zurück zu unseren etwas trübsinnigen Themen und wir wählen aus den vielen,
die hier diesen Monat eine Rolle spielten, mal die Flucht aus.
Denn einen Punkt kann man ja doch mal machen, ich habe ja noch der Bühne kurz
gemacht, aber wir steigen mal ein mit so einer Tagesthemenberichterstattung,
Moderation, was ist los Deutschland 2023.
In diesem Jahr haben bereits mehr als 200.000 Menschen einen Asylantrag in Deutschland gestellt.
Heute erreichte dann auch die politische Debatte darüber wieder die Regierungskoalition in Berlin.
Die FDP verließ einmal mehr den gemeinsamen Koalitionsweg und fordert eine härtere
Gangart, um die Flüchtlingszahlen runterzukriegen.
Viele Kommunen haben längst Alarm geschlagen. Sie wissen nicht mehr,
wie sie weitere Migranten unterbringen können. Frank Jahn berichtet.
Dies ist das letzte Grundstück, das
Bürgermeister Spitzhauer für eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft auftreiben konnte.
In Vaterstädten bei München wissen sie nicht mehr, wohin mit den Geflüchteten.
Es fehlt Wohnraum. Der Landkreis hat in den letzten 12 Monaten gut 700 Menschen
aufgenommen. Und es kommen immer mehr.
Also, es fehlt Wohnraum. Ja, es fehlt Wohnraum. Das hat mit Flüchtlingen gar
nichts zu tun. Es fehlt einfach Wohnraum.
Wo man halt wohnen will. Und jetzt hat ja der Fuß da gesagt,
200.000 Menschen haben einen Asylantrag gestellt. 200.000 Menschen.
Ist das eigentlich viel?
Wie soll man sich das verdeutlichen? 200.000 ist natürlich viel.
Es ist zweimal Koblenz.
Es ist zweimal Koblenz. So wir haben 80 Städte in Deutschland,
die als Großstädte gelten.
Ab 100.000 ist man Großstadt.
Das heißt, wir reden jetzt in dem Range, okay, es sind so viele Flüchtlinge gekommen wie in die 80.
Und die 79. größten Städte Deutschlands passen. Da kommen also noch sehr viele Städte.
Wie viele 70, 80 Städte sind, kann man sich überlegen bei der einfachen Frage.
Das ist kein Stadt-Land-Fluss, nimm dir irgendwelche Buchstaben,
aber nenn mal 80 Städte in Deutschland.
So, schafft das jemand? Also klar, irgendwie schon, aber das würde wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen dauern. dauern, habe ich die schon oder nicht und so weiter.
Und bei manchen Städten wie Berlin, Hamburg, Frankfurt, Stuttgart,
Essen, Dortmund und so weiter, da hat man immer gleich so Millionen abgerechnet.
Ich habe mich nicht mal Köln genannt zum Beispiel.
Also wir sind so groß. 200.000 Menschen sind nichts, ein Vogelschiss könnte man ja mal entgegnen.
Es findet, eigentlich sollte das keine Rolle spielen.
Gut, aber es sind 200.000 da und wir haben diesen medialen Stress und so weiter
und sofort und es ist wahnsinnig interessant, finde ich, wie der wieder in so
eine Wahlkampfzeit irgendwie fällt.
Also wir haben Wahlen in Hessen und in Bayern und es fühlt sich an,
wie in der, vor der Präsidentenwahl oder vor den Kongresswahlen,
jedes Mal kurz vor den Wahlen in Amerika ist so ein riesiger Flüchtlingstrack
unterwegs, der die ganze Zeit medial begleitet wird, Dann ist es wieder weg.
Es sind wieder Wahlen, dann ist wieder ein riesiger Flüchtlingsstrike,
der aus Honduras kommt. Und so ist das ja hier auch.
Statistisch gesehen findet das ja alles gar nicht statt. Das Jahr 2023 fällt
überhaupt nicht auf in den Vergleich zu den folgenden Jahren.
Aber gut, 200.000 gilt hier irgendwie als viel.
Was nicht heißt, dass auch in den Kommunen Politiker und Verwaltung reale Probleme
haben, die sind aber zum Teil hausgemacht und zum Teil sind sie einfach vom
Bund gemacht, weil der Bund nicht entsprechende Gelder zur Verfügung stellt, darauf sitzen bleibt.
Das heißt natürlich gibt es überall Probleme, aber das sind ja nicht alles unlösbare
Probleme, sondern das hätte alles längst in Koordination mit dem Bund super laufen können.
Ja, wir haben, ich referiere es nur kurz, das habe ich mit Mick im Fernseh-Podcast
besprochen, eine kleine Kommune im politischen Dunstkreis von Mainz.
Da sind die sieben Gemeinderatsmitglieder geschlossen zurückgetreten und haben
noch mal eingeladen dazu, kommt alle her. Heute treten wir gemeinsam aus,
war eine große Party, sie haben gegrillt und so weiter.
Das heißt, diese Kommune ist jetzt ohne politische Vertretung.
Warum haben sie das gemacht? Weil sie ein Zeichen setzen wollten.
Wir würden gern politisch gestalten, aber schon der Betrieb der Kita verbraucht
mehr als 100% unseres Budgets.
Also haben sie sich gesagt, dann ist auch egal. Also wenn wir eh nur Haushalte
schreiben, die vom Land abgesegnet werden und wir schaffen eh nur drauf zu schreiben,
drei Kita-Beschäftigte, da funktioniert also nichts. Die brauchen keine,
also da würde ein Flüchtling die schon überfordern.
Ein Typ, der da über eine Bordsteinkante fährt mit seinem LKW und das kaputt
macht, würde diese Kommune schon überfordern.
Und der Innenminister von Rheinland-Pfalz, der also im Grunde der oberste,
ich segne eure Haushalte ab und so weiter, ist der ehemalige Bürgermeister von
Mainz, der also während der Corona-Pandemie Mainz regiert hat.
Der weiß, wie man eine Kommune mit Geld ausstattet. Man hat nämlich einfach
Biontech da und macht den größten Gewerbesteuerumsatz in der Geschichte der Menschheit pro Nase.
So, und in diesem Umfeld.
Kommt diese Kommune nicht von der Stelle. Also hier braucht niemand eine Flüchtlingsdiskussion,
sondern die Kommunen haben halt einfach Probleme. Ob jetzt Flüchtlinge da sind oder nicht.
Man hat halt keine Grundstücke für niemanden. Also auch nicht für Flüchtlinge.
Das muss man dann nicht immer dazu sagen.
In Koblenz haben auch ganz ohne Flüchtlinge Schwimmbänder noch und Löcher geschlossen. Ja eben.
Also wir brauchen hier keine Flüchtlinge und 200.000 Flüchtlinge ist einfach,
das ist nicht die Kategorie, in der ich sagen würde, absolut gerechtfertigt,
dass es in den Tagesthemen so anmoderiert wird.
Ja, man müsste es eigentlich mal so verschieben und sagen, also man hat ja jetzt
die Flüchtlinge ausgemacht als Thema, weil dann so wieder dieses wie und die
anderen Narrativ so gespielt werden kann.
Man müsste eigentlich jetzt mal so einen schönen Parodiefilm drehen,
Kommune XY mit Landrat, Bürgermeister und Co.
Ja, unser Problem sind die Kinder in den Kindergärten. Also wir müssen sehen,
dass wir die Kinder loswerden, weil wenn die auch noch mal geschult werden so
ab sechs Jahren, da wird es wirklich ganz schlimm. Also wir erwarten vom Bund
auch, dass diese Kinder zurückgeführt werden.
Können wir uns das noch leisten?
Können wir uns die Kinder noch leisten?
Diese Kinder, was machen die hier? Diese Einwanderung über die Gebärmutter,
das ist nicht mehr akzeptabel.
Absolute Obergrenze jetzt mal einführen. Und das 200.000 erste wird dann abgewiesen.
Wir brauchen ein Null-Kind-Politik, ja.
Genau, so ungefähr. So, und ich habe es auf der Bühne schon gesagt.
Es war ja quasi diese Woche, aber ich will es trotzdem noch mal wiederholen.
Dieser ganze Tenor mit diesen Es sind zu viele Menschen. Deutschland hatte 2000...
13 vor zehn Jahren, 83 Millionen Menschen. Und dann kam dieses gigantische Flüchtlingsjahr
2015 und das ging immer weiter.
Und 2016 eine Million Asylanträge und 2022 durch den Krieg. So viele Flüchtlinge kamen noch nie.
Und jetzt sind wir halt 84 Millionen in zehn Jahren.
Wir sind um ein Prozent gewachsen in zehn Jahren.
So ist irgendwer überfordert und so weiter. Da kann man jetzt irgendwem,
also der Zugewanderten, die Schuld in die Schuhe schieben, dass hier irgendwas
nicht funktioniert. Nein, das ist absolut alles Nonsens.
Und insbesondere finde ich deutlich, wie wenig politisch auch gemacht wird,
weil ja natürlich alle Politiker wissen, das ist ein non-mediales Thema.
Ja klar, ruft da irgendwie der Bürgermeister an und es ist auch ein echtes Problem,
wie diese gigantisch große Insellampe Dusa und so weiter. wird alles so hochgejazzt
und Gerhard Knaus hat diesen Blick mal ein bisschen zurecht gerötelt und das
fand ich irgendwie sehr gut.
Gerhard Knaus fasst mal zusammen, was die EU so insgesamt gemacht hat,
ich habe ja auch die zehn Jahre mal genannt, es ist im Grunde nichts Nennenswertes
passiert, außer medialer Stress und so weiter und so war auch die Politik eigentlich.
Die EU hat einen Plan, einen zehn Punkte Plan. Das Problem ist,
wenn ich alle 10-Punkte-Pläne der letzten 10 Jahre zusammennehme und die Aktionspläne
und Strategiepapiere und Rückführungsabkommen, die alle nicht funktioniert haben,
wahrscheinlich könnten sie ihr ganzes Studio damit tapezieren.
Und das Ergebnis ist einsichtig und offensichtlich.
Wir haben in diesem Jahr viel mehr Menschen, die irregulär aus Afrika nach Italien
kommen, als in den letzten Jahren. Vielleicht überhaupt ein Rekord.
Wir haben tausende Tote, auch wieder in diesem Jahr.
Wir haben so wenig Rückführungen wie, oder weniger Rückführungen als vor fünf
Jahren nach Afrika. Das Dublin-System ist zusammengebrochen.
Also in jeder Hinsicht, und mit dem zynischen Deal in Libyen und Indonesien
werden auch noch Menschenrechte verletzt. In jeder Hinsicht ist die Europäische
Union hier bis jetzt gescheitert.
So zahlenmäßig. Hätten die europäischen Politiker nicht einen Flüchtlingsgipfel anberaumt?
Ja. Hätten die Bund-Länder-Konferenzen nicht einmal das zur Tagesordnung gemacht?
Wäre ist genau die gleiche Situation wie so auch.
Es macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied, ob er jemand noch einen Zehn-Punkte-Plan
vorstellt, den dann eh nicht umsetzt.
Es eh ist, wie es ist. Und wer aus Afrika nach Deutschland kommt,
achso, Kanzler ist Scholz, ja wusste ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
So, es interessiert niemanden.
Es spielt einfach gar keine Rolle, was politisch passiert zu diesem Thema.
Und hat Italien ein Flüchtlingsproblem?
Ich meine, Ursula von der Leyen hält die State of the Union und ist zwei Tage
später an einem Sonntag auf Lampedusa eingeladen, weil die Dingsda Meloni meint,
ich brauche jetzt mal ein Foto-Op und so weiter, sie muss hier mal zu Kreuze kriechen und so.
Die ganze Debatte um Solidarität in der Europäischen Union ist sehr verwirrend.
Ich gebe Ihnen nur eine Zahl, äh zwei Zahlen. Im letzten Jahr hat Italien ungefähr 86.000 Asylanträge.
Österreich hatte 110.000, also mehr als Italien. Im letzten Jahr hat Italien
ungefähr 26.000 Menschen Schutz gewährt.
Deutschland hat fünfmal mehr Menschen Schutz gewährt als Italien.
Wenn man also von einer gerechten Verteilung reden würde in Europa,
dann müsste man Menschen aus Österreich und Deutschland nach Italien schicken und nicht umgekehrt.
Dass Italien damit überfordert ist, auf einer winzigen Insel ein paar tausend
Leute unterzubringen, ist kein Zeichen dafür, dass Italien besonders viele Asylsuchende
oder Flüchtlinge im Land hat.
Polen, Sie haben über die Solidarität gesprochen, hat zehnmal mehr Ukrainerinnen
aufgenommen als Italien. Also die Debatte um Solidarität muss ernsthaft geführt
werden, mit richtigen Zahlen und nicht nur mit Schlagworten.
Finde ich ein bisschen komisch. Ich habe die letzten Wochen und Monate immer
nur Italien überschwemmt mit
Menschen, die am Zaun rumsitzen und keiner weiß, wohin mit denen und so.
Ja, wenn man natürlich auf geringer Fläche viele wibbelt, dann ist immer voll.
Wie diese Parkfotografie bei Corona. Wenn du einen Kilometer länger,
aber auf Augenhöhe, dann siehst du nur Köpfe auf der Wiese.
Da sind sie wieder alle.
Zusammengerottet. Knaus macht hier noch mal einen Punkt zu Salvini.
Wenn Italien jetzt darüber nachdenkt, mit den Militärbooten zurückzustoßen,
und nach Tunesien wird das nicht gehen, die nehmen sie nicht,
vielleicht höchstens nach Libyen, dann wäre das ein Angriff auf das Fundament
der europäischen Rechtsstaatlichkeit.
Allerdings, Matteo Salvini wollte die EU und die Menschenrechtskonvention immer
zum Einsturz bringen, so gesehen würde das passen. Aber für Europa,
den Flüchtlingsschutz und die Rechtsstaatlichkeit, wäre das der schwerste Tag überhaupt.
So, Knaus beobachtet das jetzt, sieht Salvini, was er will, sagt,
das ist eine Zerstörung. Und übrigens, das ist auch als Angriff zu werten,
was da stattfindet auf unsere Grundwerte usw. und so fort, unser Rechtsgefüge.
Jetzt hören wir Salvini.
Immer wieder versuchen die Migranten, den Hafen zu verlassen und Absperrungen zu durchbrechen.
Der stellvertretende Regierungschef, Matteo Salvini von der Lega,
bezeichnet die Massenankunft auf Lampedusa als einen Kriegsakt.
Wenn 120 Schiffe in wenigen Stunden ankommen, ist das nicht spontan.
Offensichtlich ist das organisiert, finanziert und vorbereitet.
Das ist ein Akt des Krieges.
Also es ist wirklich wie die Landung in der Normandie oder so.
Sie kommen, sie greifen uns an.
Es ist wirklich absurd, wie diese Debatte geführt wird.
Knaus hier zum Thema, das Abkommen mit Tunesien. Warum funktioniert das eigentlich
nicht? Die USA davon allein hat sich doch so ins Zeug gehangen jetzt im August oder wann das war.
Einigung mit Tunesien ist vage, lang, voller Versprechen, unkonkret.
Und es ist überhaupt nicht klar, was Tunesien eigentlich machen sollte.
Und es ist auch nicht klar, was die EU Tunesien wirklich verspricht.
Also als Migrationsabkommen ist das nicht tauglich.
Das ist in dem Sinne gar kein Abkommens, das ist nur mal so ein Fototermin gewesen oder sowas.
Völlig bescheuert, also es ist wirklich unglaublich. Plus,
jetzt bringt da so eine Pull-Faktor-Sache mit rein, also wir haben diesen riesigen
Aktionismus um das Tunesien-Abkommen und es ist vorbildhaft für so viele Länder,
vielleicht sogar Libyen, aber wir zögern noch so ein bisschen,
weil es ja die Lage so unklar.
Das Paradoxe ist ja aufgrund oder während dieser Verhandlungen mit Tunesien
hat sich die Menschenrechtslage in Tunesien drastisch verschärft.
Für Menschen aus Sub-Sahara-Afrika ist es im, sie erinnern sich an die Bilder,
die Menschen, die in die Wüste gebracht wurden, an die lübische Grenze,
ohne Wasser, im Sommer, die Lage hat sich verschärft und da ist ein Anreiz entstanden,
für noch mehr Menschen sich in die Boote zu setzen.
Also paradoxerweise ist das schlechte, undurchdachte Abkommen mit Tunesien auch
ein Grund dafür, dass jetzt mehr Menschen kommen als davor.
Ja, also die kommen in diese Länder Nordafrikas und stellen dann fest,
okay, ich dachte, ich hatte bisher einen Fluchtgrund, aber jetzt habe ich erst
recht einen Fluchtgrund.
Ich muss weiter, also ich kann hier gar nicht bleiben. Und dann haben sie so
doppelte Fluchtgründe, endlich diese Länder zu verlassen und ja,
okay, dann ist halt Europa auf der anderen Seite.
Sind wir so attraktiv? Wissen die, wo sie hinfahren? Ne, die fahren erstmal
einfach nur aufs Mittelmeer raus und hoffen, irgendwann ist die andere Küste
näher, als die, von der sie abgelegt haben.
Naja, Knaus, kleines Finale zum Thema Rechtspopulismus.
Ich glaube, das ist auch eine Krise der Koalition. Es ist sicher eine Krise
der Europäischen Union.
Und die Ernsthaftigkeit mit Rechtsextremisten, Parteien überall in Europa,
die wachsen und die natürlich von diesen Bildern profitieren,
mit diesem Kontrollverlust,
die Ernsthaftigkeit sehe ich immer noch nicht, bei den Regierungen und auch
in Deutschland, diese Probleme jetzt nicht nur mit Schlagworten,
sondern mit umsetzbaren Plänen zu konfrontieren.
Der Appell des Migrationsforschers an alle, muss man sagen. Herr Knaus, ganz herzlichen Dank.
Dabei wäre es so einfach, den Kommunen mehr Geld und Unterstützung vom Bund.
Und medial muss man ja eigentlich vorschlagen, eine Dethematisierung.
Denn wenn es medial nicht vorkommt ... Außer man hat was zu berichten.
Wenn es nicht zu berichten geht.
Auch da nicht jetzt tausend Positivbeispiele von Integration,
also diese Geschichten, das ist ja auch immer so ein, ja das ist so ganz langweilig,
wenn man sagt, ach jetzt hier nochmal die hunderttausend so rührende Geschichten.
Nee, einfach ökonomisch draufgeblickt zu sagen, die Kommunen brauchen mehr Geld,
Platz ist ohnehin genug. Thema.
Nicht mehr in den Medien, stattdessen die anderen Themen,
die alle eigentlich brennend wären und dann würde das ja sofort,
also wir wissen ja, politische Öffentlichkeit ist nur mediale Öffentlichkeit,
es gibt noch das Gartenzaungespräch, aber eigentlich gibt es nur die Massenkommunikationsmittel
für die Bildung des Politischen.
Und des Populismus.
Und des Populismus, ja.
Wir können ja jetzt, also ich will dich jetzt nicht zu sehr in Beschlag nehmen,
aber ich will jetzt eine Pointe machen.
Die sieht ungefähr so aus, dass ich jetzt einfach die Frage in den Raum stelle,
wer ist ja eigentlich gerade der größte Populist?
Also wir haben jetzt gesehen, wir haben nicht wirklich ein Problem mit Flüchtlingen
oder mit Menschen oder wie auch immer,
sondern wir haben ein Problem mit Populismus, nämlich mit dem,
was daraus gemacht wird, dass da eigentlich nichts ist oder so wenig ist,
dass es jetzt schon ein politisches Thema, aber nicht unbedingt so ein Sendungseröffnungsthema
ist und so. Und wer ist jetzt der größte Rechtspopulist?
Und ich will jetzt nicht sagen Joachim Gauck, denn dann würde ich mich entschuldigen
müssen, weil ich Gefühle verletzt habe.
Ich sage dir aber auch nicht meine Gefühle hättest du damit verletzt.
Nicht meine. Ich will aber sehr gut auch es nicht auf ihn münzen,
sondern sagen, also die Frage noch mal kurz um,
wer sagt gerade besonders rechtspopulistische Sachen,
Weil sie auf so einer besonderen Ebene wirken, denn vielleicht kommen wir irgendwann
noch mal dahin, dass wir sagen, mit der AfD ist es gar nicht so schlimm,
da weiß man wenigstens, was man wählt.
Ich bin ja ein großer Verfechter von dieser These, vorhin auch schon ausgeräumt,
es gibt keine Protestwähler, Leute, die die AfD wählen, die wissen, wen sie da wählen.
Rechtspopulismus unterstellen wir aber, dass es so ein bisschen im Deckmantel kommt.
Und damit sind wir wieder bei Joachim Gauck, unserem ehemaligen Bundespräsidenten,
den wir ja sowieso nicht beleidigen dürfen, weil dieses Gesetz ist ja noch nicht
ganz ausgeräumt, es ist nicht mehr giltig, aber es ist vergessen.
Wie heißt denn dieses Gesetz nochmal?
Der gute Bundespräsident-Gesetz.
Irgendwie sowas, ja.
So, Joachim Gauck, wir hören ihn nur peripher hier im Heute-Journal am 17.
Also eine Kurzmeldung. Danach, weil ich will mich ja nicht in die Predoje bringen,
spiel ich einfach, was Florian Schröder dazu gesagt hat, weil ich das wirklich
super gut finde. Aber erst mal kurz zu Joachim Gauck selbst.
Ja, der ehemalige Bundespräsident Gauck hat angesichts der EU-Migrationspolitik
vor einem Rechtsruck gewarnt.
Bei Berlin Direkt erklärt er, eine Begrenzung der Zuwanderung sei politisch geboten.
Politik braucht Mehrheiten und wenn in vier verschiedenen Ländern unter diesem Migrationsdruck,
unter dieser Zuwanderung in einem Maß wie 2015 die Bevölkerung den Eindruck hat,
die Regierenden verstehen nicht, dass wir das Bedürfnis haben nach Überschaubarkeit
und Sicherheit, dann wird es zu einem weiteren Rechtsruck kommen.
So, die Demokratie braucht Mehrheiten.
Wie 2015 sagt er, wo wir überhaupt nicht 2015 haben.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, es droht nicht drüber.
Also ich meine, mir ist das sowieso, ich bin ja immer froh, dass ich kein Journalist
bin, aber mir wäre das ja zum Beispiel unmöglich, neutral GAUK anzuparlieren.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, wie das geht. Der sagt, mehr Waffen, frieren für die
Freiheit, überhaupt die Sozialleistungen sind ja auch so hoch und also das ist
ja, also GAUK ist ja, ja, also gut.
Genau, wir überlassen die Meinungsbekundung gleich Florian Schröder,
dankbarerweise, dass er sich da so reinhängt.
Joachim Gauck hat ja eben kurz gesagt, diesen einen Punkt muss ich nochmal extra
machen, Demokratie braucht Mehrheit.
Wir haben uns bei der Begründung unserer Demokratie darauf verständigt,
dass gewisse Sachen auch nicht durch Mehrheit abzuschaffen sind.
Und ich fand es sehr erschreckend, ich habe es auch am Dienstag, wird auch schon gesagt,
oder wann waren wir auf der Bühne, Dienstag, dass ich am Vorabend bei Michel
Friedmanns Buchverstellung im Literaturhaus war und ich das doch sehr,
so viel Attraktivität ich darin sehe, ein ökonomisches Argument zu machen,
aber man kann auch mal ein rein moralisches Argument machen,
nur weil es richtig ist und so.
Und wir müssen hier einfach noch mal darauf hinweisen, der Artikel 1 ist auch
nicht durch eine Mehrheit oder so abzuräumen.
Menschenwürde ist einfach Menschenwürde. Die ist unantastbar,
auch nicht durch eine demokratische Mehrheit, weshalb diese ganze Prämisse,
mit der er hier reingeht, schon verlogen ist.
Und auch eines Priesters unwürdig oder Pfarrers oder was auch immer.
Selbst da sind mir die Details jetzt egal.
Und Florian Schröder referiert jetzt so ein bisschen, was Gauck im Original
sagte und kommentiert das.
Und ich schließe mich da komplett an, also ich finde diese Verurteilung von
dem, was Gauck da sagt, kann nicht deutlich genug sein. Für mich ist das,
in dem was ich da höre von ihm, der...
Schlimmste rechtspopulistische Auswuchs der letzten Jahre irgendwie.
Und der steht auch noch über der AfD, von dem was man da so ausgefragt hat.
Ja, weil es in so einem Pfaffenton vorgetragen ist und dadurch so eine Seriosität erhält.
Absolut. Also hier Florian Schröder.
Wir hatten ja hier im Salon, im Live-Salon, hatten wir irgendwie Alice Weidel,
die brüllt irgendwas im Schnitzel. Aber hier das ist natürlich viel perfider.
Genau, bei Alice Weidel weiß ich, wie die zu Artikel 1 steht.
Macht einen klaren Unterschied zwischen Mensch und Mensch. Und dann gilt der
einfach nicht und wird auch abgeräumt. Und Schirra hat gesagt,
dann wird es ganz schlimm. Und ich sage, ja, genau.
Bei Gauck ist das halt so ein bisschen anders. Der macht das so mit halb geöffnetem
Visier. Und es ist einfach nicht gut. Also Florian Schröder dazu.
Ich lese die Meldung hier von der ZDF-Seite vor. Die Situation in den Kommunen
verschärft sich seit Monaten. Immer mehr Geflüchtete kommen an und müssen untergebracht werden.
Werden die Kapazitäten immer knapper. Wenn die Kommunen an die Grenzen ihrer
Leistungsfähigkeit kämen, besteht die Gefahr, dass, Zitat Gauck,
die wunderbare Solidarität der Bevölkerung, die es bisher gab,
schwindet, sagt Gauck in der ZDF-Sendung Berlin Direkt.
Die Menschen hätten dann Angst, dass, Zitat, in ihrem Leben sich unzumutbar viel verändert.
Denken wir an die die vorhin genannten Zahlen.
Durch den, Zitat Gauck, Migrationsdruck in verschiedenen Ländern
mit einer, wieder Zitat, Zuwanderung in einem Maß wie 2015,
wovon kein Mensch redet,
wieder, Verweis auf unsere Zahlen von vorhin, würde in der Bevölkerung der Eindruck
entstehen, dass die Politik ihre Ängste, Zitat, ihr Bedürfnis nach Überschaubarkeit
und Sicherheit, Zitat Ende. Nicht verstehe.
Das könnte zu einem weiteren Rechtsruck führen, mahnt Gauck.
Nein, du mahnst nicht, du führst gerade selber dazu und zwar mit jedem einzelnen Wort.
Er plädiert daher für eine Begrenzung der Zuwanderung. Und jetzt Achtung,
wir erinnern daran, es spricht ein Theologe.
Wir müssen Spielräume entdecken, die uns zunächst unsympathisch sind,
weil sie inhuman klingen, Zitat Ende, sagt der ehemalige Bundespräsident.
Aber die verschiedenen politischen Kräfte müssten, wie der Zitat,
von ihren Wunschvorstellungen Abstand nehmen und in der demokratischen Mitte
das entwickeln, was wir wirklich wollen." Zitat Ende.
Ja, ich würde sagen, Florian Schröder hat recht. Wir haben es hier mit einem
echten Problem zu tun. Der Rechtspopulismus schleicht sich ein,
versteckt sich und wirkt trotzdem auf ganz hinterhältige Art und Weise. Ja.
Ich muss da jetzt dir gerade was vorlesen.
Du durchwühlst dein Twitter-Profil.
Moment, du hast mir das jetzt geöffnet. Ich muss hier auf abbrechen.
Wie komm… ja siehste, ich kann ja schon gar nicht. Ich hab's schon wieder verwischt.
Also ich wollte dir jetzt einen Tweet vorlesen. Nicht von mir selbst,
aber ich hab ihn retweetet, damit wir das sehen können. Also ich scrolle jetzt noch einmal.
Und zwar hat sich Gaugs Kollegin im Geiste, also auch evangelische Kirche,
aus der ich ja, wie alle wissen, ausgetreten bin, die hat sich auch geäußert,
und zwar Katrin Göring-Eckardt.
Und die sagte, twitterte, 2015 fragten wir uns, schaffen wir das?
Heute, acht Jahre später, diskutieren wir die Frage wieder.
Und dann war da ein Zitat, das sie dann abgegeben haben.
Ich will, dass wir weiterhin ein freundliches Gesicht zeigen,
das fair ist. Sofern es gehört, dass wir klar sagen, wer nicht hierbleiben darf, der muss wieder zurück.
Aber wir machen das, also uns unterscheidet eigentlich nur noch von der AfD,
dass wir wie Gauck so pastoral da mit Vernunft und wir wollen ja nicht inhuman.
Oder wir zeigen ihnen ein freundliches Gesicht. Während die anderen gucken böse
auf die Flüchtlinge und schieben sie ab.
Und wir gucken lieb auf die Flüchtlinge und schieben sie ab.
Also, wir hören jetzt mal zwei Clips noch zum Thema, die mich so ein bisschen ...
Dauerhaft natürlich beschäftigen. Aber in dem einen Fall sind sie eben auch
für mich neu. Also, die Wortmeldung, die mal kam.
Bijan Dir Sarai, man hört schon an dem Namen, das ist jemand,
der auch schon mal die Ausländer rausschmeißt.
Also man kriegt es schon nicht mehr richtig verarbeitet so und ich finde es
ein bisschen crazy, wie hart die FDP ihre völlig falsche Linie,
nämlich wir haben ja Menschen, die wir wollen und dann die, die wir nicht wollen.
So als ob es einen Unterschied macht, wenn wir sagen wir mal so ein Boomer, der 64
in Rente geht im größten Jahrgang, warten wir noch fünf Jahre,
also der so 2033 mit 73 Jahren gepflegt werden möchte.
Ist es für ihn so entscheidend, wo der Mensch, der ihn pflegt,
vor zehn Jahren herkam, unter welchen Umständen?
Ob die Eltern irgendwie sofort auf dem Arbeitsmarkt präsent waren oder sich
so durchgeschlagen haben, um ihn durch die Schule und Berufsausbildung zu bringen.
Es macht keinen Unterschied.
Und das ist nicht gerade auch das Versprechen des liberalen Kapitalismus,
dass man sich emanzipiert, herauslöst aus Herkunftelterlichem Wurzeldenken und
sich selbst erfinden kann.
Ja, es macht, was die FDP hier argumentiert, macht keinen Sinn,
außer es gibt irgendwo einen Parteichef, der die Ansage macht,
wir müssen uns in der Ampel profilieren.
Und der einzige Weg, der für uns zur Verfügung steht, weil wir uns verbrannt
haben, mit den Grünen und den Roten, ist die rechte Schiene.
Aber ich will von 6 auf 8 %, das ist die Ansage. Also für 2 % ungefähr,
hören wir jetzt so einen Schrott.
Ob jetzt Kanada, USA, Australien oder Neuseeland, Und diese Länder sagen sehr
konkret, welche Form der Migration sie wollen.
Und diese Länder sagen auch sehr konkret, welche Form der Migration sie nicht wollen.
Diese Länder sagen ja, Migration muss interessengeleitet sein,
also Migration für den Arbeitsmarkt ja. Aber Migration in die sozialen Sicherungssysteme,
das ist nicht etwas, was wir wollen. Und ich glaube, wir tun gut dran,
dass wir diese Debatte auch in Deutschland sachlich und nüchtern führen.
Ja, das ist ja der größte Prumpf, den man immer im Ärmel hat,
wenn man selbst jemanden mit einer Migrationsgeschichte nach vorne stellen kann.
Wir hatten das im Live-Salon, sogar KRA adressiert jetzt die Türken in Deutschland
und sagt, also Türken in Deutschland, ihr müsst AfD wählen.
Ja, in diese Richtung geht das.
Ja, das ist einfach alles verlogen. Die Debatte kann man so nicht führen.
Es ist auf ganz vielen Ebenen, das ist ganz falsch. Nein, wir werden nicht gerade
überrannt. Wir sind auch kein besonders attraktives Einwanderungsland.
Die Leute fühlen sich bei uns nicht wohl, wenn wir jetzt unterscheiden zwischen
Menschen, die wir wollen und nicht wollen. Was sollen die Kriterien sein?
Wie sollen die nebenökonomischen Diskussionen mit unserem Grundgesetz vereinbar
sein und mit unserer Geschichte? Das macht alles gar keinen Sinn.
Also es funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Und es bedient einfach nur so einen Gemütszustand von Leuten in Suhl.
Ja, und das wird jetzt auch noch mal so ein Deutsch-Test-Debatten,
das kommt da noch dran. Das ist ja auch alles uralt.
Das ist ja vor 20 Jahren war doch schon mal so, da hat man doch so einen Test mal entworfen.
Kennen Sie die und die Gemälde von Caspar David Friedrich oder so?
Und dann hatte doch mal die FAZ dann damals Reich Rannitzky dazu befragt als
der große deutsche Literaturkritiker und er sagt, den Test hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht bestanden.
Ja, man hat ja auch Chrupalla mal gefragt, das deutsche Liedgut,
was ist denn dein Lieblingsgedicht?
Ja, ich komme darauf zurück. Er kannte nicht mal eins.
Nun gut, wir haben in dieser ganzen Diskussion seit dem Holocaust eigentlich
diese, ja, wir sagen Juden, aber meinen Menschen.
So ungefähr. Wir wollen diesen radikalen Universalismus, wie auch immer,
Artikel 1, pipapo, kürze ich mal ab.
Und jetzt war es so, dass im September, trotz dieses Stresses,
der Verband der Sinti und Roma in die Bundespressekonferenz ging und dort mal
eine Ansage gemacht hat.
Und die fand ich irgendwie gut, denn die erinnert uns nochmal,
dass wir gerade Flüchtlingsdiskurse haben und aber auch welche bräuchten.
Und das ist aber gar nicht deckungsgleich. Also wird uns hier mal vorgeschlagen,
was wir eigentlich mal so diskutieren könnten.
Es ist die erste systematische Erfassung und Dokumentation von antiziganistischen
Vorfällen in Deutschland.
Wenn wir unsere Vorfälle vortragen, die antiziganistisch sind,
dann wissen wir, dass vieles davon auch eben aus Unwissenheit,
weil im Falle unserer Minderheit gab es in diesem Land trotz des Holocaust eine
gewisse Form der Narrenfreiheit.
Und die wollen wir nicht mehr tolerieren. Im Oktober 2021 wurde begonnen,
die Meldestelle aufzubauen.
Und der Bericht heute zeigt, wie verbreitet Antiziganismus in Deutschland ist.
Wir fassen Vorfälle sowohl oberhalb als auch unterhalb der Strafbarkeitsgrenzen.
Ein Vorfall muss nicht strafrechtlich relevant sein, um als antiziganistisch
bewertet und dokumentiert zu werden.
Wir machen somit auch jene Dimensionen des Antisemitanismus sichtbar,
die für Betroffene alltägliche Realität sind.
Für Germaine Wagner und Anna Wagner haben die diskriminierenden Erfahrungen
sogar noch zugenommen, sagen sie. Jetzt die letzten Jahre, das hat sich extrem gesteigert.
Egal, wo man hinkommt, egal, ob man einkaufen geht, ob man zum Arzt geht,
ob man Behördengänge macht, egal, was es ist.
Und das verletzt immer wieder aufs Neue.
Ja, weil die Leute kriegen es halt nicht abgeschüttelt, immer das Objekt der
Flüchtlingsdebatte zu sein, der man dann so auf der Straße begegnet.
Und wir müssen eigentlich, also es ist ganz gut, dass wir eine Flüchtlingsdebatte
führen, wir müssen nur das Wortzeichen mal umdrehen. umdrehen.
Ist natürlich jetzt ein sehr frommer Wunsch so, aber es sind nur 200.000 Menschen
im Jahr. Was können wir denn für die eigentlich tun?
Statt, oh Gott, wie werden wir die wieder los?
Naja, traurig, aber es sind Wahlkämpfe und zwar die nächsten zwei Jahre. Gott. Es ist, wie es ist.
Wir bewegen uns jetzt mal aus der Politik raus und beschäftigen uns mit J.
Shetty. Ich habe dich eben gefragt, ob du ihn kennst und du kennst ihn nicht.
Er ist ein Experte für Dating, Beziehung, Alleinsein.
Ja, und zwar ist das ein großes Imperium. Also Shetty ist 35 Jahre alt.
Dieser Typen, der uns Selbstliebe gibt, obwohl wir Klassenkampf bräuchten?
Zum Beispiel.
Dann lernen wir den bestimmt alle kennen bei Jean-Philipp auf der Bühne oder so.
Vielleicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich will jetzt erst mal sagen,
also es ist jetzt hier nicht so ein Blog, bei dem ich sage, ich habe hier einen
ganz schlimmen Insel, den ich euch mal vorführen will oder so.
Ganz und gar nicht. Also das ist ein Selbsthilfe-Coach und Unternehmer,
35 Jahre alt und der hat aber, glaube ich, eine ganz große Relevanz für unseren
Podcast, weil ich mich gefragt habe, was suchen eigentlich die Leute für Ratschläge,
was wollen die eigentlich?
Also wir können natürlich sagen, also dem geht es nie um das Ökonomische.
Also das findet man einfach nicht. Man liest von dem ein ganzes Buch und hört
zig Podcasts und man wird einfach nicht auf solche Fragen kommen.
Ihm selbst geht es jedenfalls finanziell ganz gut. Also 2017 wurde Shetty von
Forbes unter die Top 30 unter 30 gewählt.
Sieben Milliarden Aufrufe bei YouTube. Instagram 14,5 Millionen Follower.
Bei Facebook 26 Millionen Follower. Er hat den On Purpose with Jay Shetty Podcast.
Er hat eine Meditation und Mental Health App namens Calm.
Ach, Calm, gehört ihm.
Ja, die hat ja schon bei Instagram 3,1 Millionen Follower und die App soll im
ersten Quartal 2023 laut Statista 22,5 Millionen Dollar verkaufen.
Umsatz gemacht haben. Wir reden hier von einem Imperium und nicht einfach von
einem Coach. Und ich bin wie auf ihn gestoßen, habe ich dir mal erzählt,
dass ich, ich habe ja noch ein anderes Insta-Profil, was ich nur noch habe aus
meiner Influencer-Recherche.
Also da bin ich nicht zu sehen, das ist einfach ein Fake-Profil.
Und da habe ich ja dann diese ganze Influencer bin ich denen gefolgt.
Und hin und wieder gucke ich da rein. Und dann wird einem ja immer so ein Zeugs
angezeigt, weil die ja dann anders einen einordnen.
Und ich bekam da schon immer mal den so angezeigt, hab das aber nie angeklickt.
Und ich folge mitunter auch, hab ich ja das mal erzählt, so irgendwelchen,
so bisschen prominenten Leuten, die so ganz gewöhnliches Promi-Leben haben.
Und die irgendwie so Soapstars oder so, weil das hoch aufschlussreich ist.
Ich will ja mal wissen, wie ticken die Leute so? Der Mittelbau.
Der Mittelbau, der vom Soap-Dreh kommt, auf der Kölner Domplatte ein Eis ist, das postet.
Und es schreiben einfach 400 Leute in Kommentaren darunter, da bekommt man ja
gleich auch Lust auf ein Eis. Lass es dir schmecken. Ja, bei dem schönen Wetter, gell?
Und das schreiben einfach 400 Leute darunter. Und hat zehntausende Likes.
Und ich denke, gut, das ist auch die Bundesrepublik.
Und über so ein Soap-Star-Profil sah ich plötzlich, oh, da liest ja jemand ein
Buch, was äußerst selten dann bei diesen zugegebenen Rassen vorkommt.
Und das war das Buch, ich habe es gelesen, aber ich habe den Titel jetzt gerade
nicht hier, Also acht Regeln für die Liebe oder sowas.
Conchetti.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ich habe in meinem ganzen Leben noch nie einen
Lebensratgeber gelesen. Und nicht, dass jemand sagt, es gibt doch keinerlei Nöten bei mir.
Aber ich wollte unbedingt mal wissen, wie funktioniert das? Also habe ich das
ganze Ding gelesen, habe so ein paar Sachen rausgeschrieben.
Dazu kommen wir gleich. Wir fangen jetzt aber erst mal ganz hoch oben an.
Jay Shetty ist also bestens vernetzt.
Und so hat er Joe Biden kürzlich in seinem Podcast gehabt, den amerikanischen
Präsidenten, der jetzt mal auf Tuchfühlung geht.
Wir haben ja schon dieses atmosphärische Sprechen bei Scholz und Matze Hielscher
und jetzt hier Kindheitserlebnis Joe Biden. Go back out there.
Ich sagte zu ihr, warte, bis er auf dich aufsteht. Und sobald er aufsteht,
schlägt er ihn dir direkt in den Nase.
Sie sagte, ich gebe dir 50 Cent, wenn du das tust.
Ich fragte, warum, Mutter? Sie sagte, du wirst nicht mehr in diesen Alley gehen
können, wenn du das nicht tust. Ich war schockiert, ich ging raus,
schlug ihn dir in den Nase, er blutete, er rann und ich dachte, ah.
Andere Erziehungsmethoden, andere Zeiten. Der Präsident erzählt,
wie er als Kind ein Kind geschlagen hat.
Lieber Hörer, ihr braucht diese Ansage natürlich nicht, aber wir lehnen Gewalt
immer ab. Prinzipiell, grundsätzlich und überall.
Also dieser Podcast ist so angelegt, dass immer irgendwelche sehr,
sehr bekannten Leute dort zu Gast sind und dann immer von ihren Experiences
erzählen und Jay Shetty dann immer sagt, ja ich hatte so eine ganz ähnliche Experience.
Sie hat auch immer bei jedem Gast auch ähnliche Experiences,
sie muss ein unglaublich volles Leben schon geführt haben und dann wird daraus
immer sowas herauskristallisiert, sowas, was man fürs Leben mitnehmen kann.
Hören wir noch einmal zu beiden.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass du in Zeiten, in denen du leider warst,
weil sie dich für deine indische Herkunft und deine weiße Bevölkerung lustig
machen, jemandem zu sagen, dass er mit dir zusammenkommen soll,
macht einen Unterschied.
Absolut. Ich werde dich nie vergessen. Du hast mich gerade erinnert.
Iain Windess war sein Name. Er war der schwierigste Kind in der Schule und er
hatte meinen Rücken. Das war der Typ, der mich anrufte.
Wenn jemand ein Problem mit mir hatte, hatten sie ein Problem mit ihm.
Ich frage mich, wie groß muss die Verunsicherung sein, deswegen habe ich mich
diesem Phänomen jetzt mal gewidmet, dass man sich diesen Kram anhört,
also es ist ja selbst aus dem Munde eines US-amerikanischen Präsidenten langweilig.
Und jetzt kann man sich vorstellen, diese anderen Gäste sind ja noch viel langweiliger,
vor allen Dingen geht es jetzt nicht mehr darum, dass man Pointen mitbringt,
nicht so wie man es versucht bei Neo Ragazzi und da geht es dann nicht.
Bei manchen US-Podcasts kann man ja sagen, wenn da gute Stars zu Gast sind,
können die ja durchaus unterhaltsam und intelligent erzählen.
Aber hier, das geht nur noch so auf diese Ebene.
Ja, weißt du, Stefan, manchmal hat man dieses Gefühl, irgendwie auch so sich
allein zu fühlen. Kennst du das? Und manchmal hilft ja dann noch schon so ein
Anruf bei einem Freund. Ja, ja, ja.
Ich verstehe das auch alles nicht, ob da so eine Repräsentation des Publikums,
so ein Reinfühlen, dieses… Naja, Kurt Krömer's Podcast jetzt heißt Feelings,
wo das ja auch, also ich habe da nur mal kurz bei YouTube reingehört,
das ist ja auch, mit sowas kannst du mich ja foltern, mit so einem Kram.
Also ich, das ist ja mal das Vorherrschen jetzt so, wir bringen mal unsere Inhaltlichkeiten
mit und haben mal so im gemeinsamen Gespräch was entwickelt. und.
Naja, aber ich meine, wenn du so eine allgemeine Stimmungslage hast,
in dem umso mehr Menschen zum Objekt gemacht werden, musst du dich natürlich umso mehr zum Subjekt.
Ah ja, klar.
Und dann ist das einfach die Kompensation.
Naja, das ist sehr gut, ja. Das ist etwas Kompensatorisches.
Tom Holland war auch zum Beispiel zu Gast bei Jay Shetty und da nutzt aber Jay
Shetty vor allem mal die Gelegenheit, um zum 100.000.
Mal zu erzählen, dass er mit 21 Jahren, Ja,
Mönch werden wollte für drei Jahre, das auch durchhielt in Mumbai in einem Ashram
und die Texte des Hinduismus,
die Veden, die hat er dann auch mitgenommen, also ein Kulturtransfer und daraus
leitet er dann ja seine acht zeitlosen universellen Regeln ab,
wie man leben und lieben sollte.
Aber wir hören jetzt mal rein, was er da zu berichten hat von seiner Zeit als Mönch.
Für mich war es eine der besten Erfahrungen meines Lebens, weil ich 22 Jahre
alt war, als ich das gemacht habe.
Ich weiß nicht mal, ob ich es jetzt noch machen könnte, aber du hattest so viel
Energie als 22-Jähriger, du bist einfach offen für jede Erfahrung und möchtest alles versuchen.
Und ich denke für mich war es, und das kommt zurück an die Leute,
die das gemacht haben, als ich 18 war, habe ich den ersten Monk kennengelernt.
Ich wusste nie wirklich, was Monke tun oder welche ihrer Praxis.
Aber ich habe einen Monk kennengelernt, den ich in meinem Buch überlege, der einfach...
Das hat mich beeindruckt, weil er die erste Person war, die ich mit sich selbst zufrieden war.
Und als ich 18 war, habe ich Menschen kennengelernt, die richtig und bekannt
waren, die wunderschön und mächtig waren und all diese Dinge.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich jemanden kennengelernt habe,
der wirklich glücklich und zufrieden war.
Mit sich selbst, nicht glücklich, wie, oh, ich bin so glücklich,
das Leben ist großartig.
Ich meine eher glücklich mit dem, wer sie sind. Mit dem, wer sie sind. Mit dem, wer sie waren.
Ja, ja, ja. Total. Und für irgendeinen Grund, als ich 18 war,
war das ein Schnellschuss direkt in mein Herz, wo ich dachte,
das ist echt, ich will das.
Und es ist einfach so schwer zu erklären, weil alle so sagen,
wie wusstest du das, 18? Und ich so, ich weiß nicht, es muss sein,
wie stark er war. Es ist so, als würdest du aufwachen, wenn die Sonne aus ist
und die Lichter aus sind, und du würdest aufwachen, weil du diese Energie spürst.
Was macht das mit dir, Stefan?
Ja, ich überlege, ob ich das so bedauere, dass ich mit dem Verborgen,
verwehrt blieb vom Schicksal bisher, aber vielleicht treffe ich ja irgendwann nochmal.
Oder ich werde diese Person, die für andere so geruhsam und durch die Calm App
nochmal besonders, und so.
Ja, ganz richtig.
Und das ist sozusagen die Zielsetzung.
Ja, ja, ja.
Werde doch mal ganz ruhig. Ich weiß, du hast 100.000 Dollar Schulden durch die
Schule und das, was du da gelernt hast, ist auch nicht so. Aber ja.
Ja, aber wenn man zum Beispiel hört, also jetzt aus dem Buch ein Zitat.
Es geht darum, mit den Fehlern umzugehen, die wir selbst, unser Partner und
das Leben mit sich bringen.
Ja, ist so richtig wie falsch. Wir hören weiter, Kim Kardashian war dort auch
zu Gast, auch eine große Philosophin.
Zu entscheiden und glücklich zu sein. So viele Möglichkeiten haben sich eröffnet.
Dinge, die ich nie gedacht hätte, in einem Millionenjahren zu kommen.
Es sah so klar aus, als würde mich das Universum für das Entscheiden von mir erwarten.
Entscheiden von mir.
Da unter deinem Buch liegt ja mein Sammelband Alfred Adler.
Ich habe ein bisschen gestöbert und so. Das ist ja hundert Jahre altes Zeug,
Richtung geht. Erstmal selber und dann in die Weltgemeinschaft der Glücklichen einfach eintreten.
Das kann man auch so und so weit treiben, aber nicht darüber hinaus und die
übertreiben ja alle maßlos.
Und es ist ja erst recht nicht, was die hier immer so sagen,
diese eine Entscheidung, das ist so wie so eine Erfindergeste,
irgendwann habe ich Heureka gerufen und dann habe ich mich selbst gefunden oder
selbst erwählt oder was auch immer und habe mich dann in die Freiheit begeben.
Ja, es ist wie bei diesen Familienunternehmern. Wenn du so und so viele Millionen
und Milliarden im Hintergrund hast, kannst du natürlich ausblenden.
Dann kommst du nur noch drauf an, was gibst du denn, weil dann stehen die Leute
Schlange vor dir, dann suchst du halt die Leute aus und dann resoniert halt irgendwas.
Und das ist, und das macht eigentlich diesen Chat hier so interessant,
dass man jetzt nicht hier so ein Andrew Tate oder irgendjemand sitzen hat,
wo man sagt, okay, der ist ganz klar für so eine Ideologie, sondern viel schwieriger
ist ja diese inkrementelle Ideologie zu erkennen.
Wo immer so gesagt wird, naja, dann hast du dich entschieden und toll und hast super gemacht,
aber man blendet halt alles, die politische, gesellschaftliche,
ökonomische Dimensionen aus und dass ich entscheide und vielleicht dann noch
die Zweierbeziehung, da gibt es dann noch immerhin Zweierakteure bei dem Ganzen,
aber auch da ist es wieder losgelöst von allem. Wir hören nochmal Kardashian.
Zweite Frage, was ist der schlimmste Lebensvorschlag, den du je erhalten oder
gehört hast? Ich denke, das schlimmste Ratgeber ist fast zu viel Ratgeber oder zu viele Meinungen.
Wenn du wirklich deinem Geist vertraust und du tust, was du tun willst,
und wenn du in deiner Bubble bist und wenn das Weltbein in deine Bubble kommt
und es so viele Meinungen gibt, denke ich, dass manchmal das komplizierte Ratgeber nur schlecht ist.
So ist das. Mit der Milliarde kommen die Milliarden Ratgeber,
die dir auf der Nase rumtanzen wollen.
Aber mit null Dollar seid ihr Nullratgeber.
Jetzt schreibt er ein Buch über die 8 zeitlosen, universellen Regeln,
wie man das Leben lieben sollte und die Regel Nummer 1 lautet, sei mal allein.
Es scheint wohl sehr schwierig für Leute zu sein, mal allein zu sein und es
gibt dann solche Tipps dort, dass man mal alleine essen gehen sollte oder mal
alleine ins Kino gehen sollte, um das einzutrainieren.
Also für mich ist es sehr, sehr fremd, weil ich natürlich sehr gerne allein
essen gehe und noch viel lieber aber allein ins Kino gehe.
Oder der Museumsbesuch, dass man den mal allein gestaltet. Also das ist so eine
Idee. Ich meine, das ist ja auch nicht falsch.
Was er dann sagt, also er versucht das dann aber auch immer wieder so zu kategorisieren,
was überhaupt nicht klappt. Er sagt dann, wichtig ist auf die drei Bs des Wandels zu achten.
Was sind die Bs? Das ist einmal Beratung, man muss kleine, einfache Schritte nehmen.
Die atomic habits.
Ja, dann muss man auf Beharrlichkeit zweitens setzen, also sich fortlaufend bemühen.
Stamina.
Ja, und dann drittens die Bezugsgruppe. Vernetze dich mit Menschen, die dich motivieren.
Vorbilder und Idole.
Ja, und das verkauft er, also es steht nicht ein einziger neuer Gedanke da drin,
außer dass er diese Geschichte hat. Ich war mal Mönch und habe hier mal was
in Indien gefunden und mitgebracht euch.
Aber das finde ich interessant, dass über die Schiene jetzt für sehr viele junge
Amerikaner auch Indien als so ein Sehnsuchtsort oder so weiter vermarktet wird.
Das ist nochmal Eat, Pray, Love. Regel Nummer zwei, achte auf dein Karma.
Also wichtig sei zu wissen, dass heutige Entscheidungen Wirkungen auf dein zukünftiges
Leben haben. Ja, das ist ja meistens so.
Du musst in eine Meditation gehen über dein Inneres Selbst und damit,
Bedeutet das auch, umarme dein jüngeres Ich. Also du hast heute schon den Bestseller
da, den ewigen Event. Und du musst dann nochmal dein inneres Kind entdecken.
Umarme dein jüngeres Ich. Was ist damit gemeint? Also du hast vielleicht manchmal,
warst du unsicher, heute bist du aber sicherer geworden.
Also ich kann jetzt mich nochmal in den 15-jährigen Wolfgang reinversetzen und
sagen, oh da warst du aber unsicher und dann kann ich sagen,
es ist okay, heute weißt du es besser, aber damals war das okay, wie du warst.
Umarme ich nochmal mein jüngeres Ich, das wird sich dann freuen.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich dieses amerikanische Embrace ist, das ja nochmal ein
bisschen anders, lockerer gemeint ist.
Vorsicht mit Oxytocin, denn er sagt, wir verwechseln schnell die hormonelle
Verbundenheit beim Sex mit Liebe.
Es sei eigentlich ein Hormon der Fehleinschätzung.
Wir werden ganz am Ende zum Thema Sex kommen und dann können wir uns nochmal
austauschen. Ich lese das nicht, Leute.
Das ist ganz falsch.
Ja, also er ist da anderer Ansicht. Reflektiere, lerne aus deinen früheren Beziehungen und so etwas.
Und dann sagt er, und das habe ich jetzt mal komplett hier als Zitat mitgebracht,
ich muss es vorlesen, weil es so herrlich ist. Schreibe dir selbst einen Liebesbrief.
Liebes Selbst, wir sind seit dem ersten Tag zusammen und Dir verdanke ich es,
dass ich dieses Leben erfahren darf.
Du stehst mir näher als jeder andere und weißt als einziges,
was ich gesehen und was ich gemacht habe. Du bist das Einzige,
das die Welt durch meine Augen sieht, das meine verborgenen Gedanken kennt.
Zusammen haben wir viel durchgemacht, alles genau genommen, wir haben Höhen und Tiefen erlebt.
In den wunderbarsten Momenten bist du bei mir und auch in solchen,
die ich im Nachhinein gern anders gestaltet hätte.
Egal was war, du hast immer zu mir gehalten. Wir sind echte Partner.
MeTime. Das ist ja, wenn die, wenn die… Steht da so drin? MeTime?
Nein, nein, aber MeTime schreiben doch immer diese Influencer.
Heute machen sie MeTime.
Self-Marriage.
Ja, du bist das einzige, von dem ich ohne jeden Zweifel weiß, dass wir für...
Dass wir für immer zusammenbleiben werden. Trotz deiner Fürsorge und Treue habe
ich dich hin und wieder vernachlässigt.
Ich habe nicht immer auf dich gehört, wenn du mir gesagt hast,
was für mich das Beste ist.
Statt auf dich zu achten, habe ich nach außen geschaut und beobachtet,
was andere gesagt und getan haben. Wir sollen die Lehre daraus ziehen.
Das ist auch das, was sich durch den Podcast durchzieht.
Ich kürze es ein bisschen ab. dass du sachsichtig zu mir bist,
dass du stark bist, dass du mit mir zusammen aus meinen Fehlern und Erfolgen
lernen und wachsen willst.
Und auch dafür, dass du mir immer das Beste, was in mir steckt,
immer wieder vor Augen führst.
Danke, dass du mir zeigst, was bedingungslose Liebe wirklich bedeutet. Alles liebe ich.
Sehr gute, cooles Vorbild.
Steht so von alles liebe ich.
Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so gut. Also sich so neben sich zu stellen.
Das finde ich auch nicht so gut.
Ich finde, man muss nicht mit sich im Reinen sein, aber man muss sich darüber
gewiss sein, dass man nur eine Person ist.
Ja. Und nicht, dass da schon mal jemand vorausgeht und man muss nur entsprechend
folgen oder man imaginiert sich so oder man entkoppelt sich von seinem Spiegelbild
oder was auch immer. Das sind falsche Strategien.
Er geht noch weiter, man sollte sich auch nicht nur bei seinem Selbst bedanken,
sondern z.B. auch bei seinen Füßen für die Standfestigkeit. Oder...
An den Bauch. Ich danke dir, dass du das Essen für mich verdaust. Oder Mund, Ohre, Nase.
Danke, dass durch euch kann ich die Welt und deren Genüsse genießen.
Das ist doch fast wie bei Otto, oder? Leber an Milz und so.
Eigentlich schon. Ja, und wir reden hier von einem Multimillionen-Bestseller
übersetzt. Ja, das ist, wenn es zu wenig Psychotherapie gibt, dann sprechen alle aus.
Ich glaube einfach, das sind ja nicht alle Leute, die eine Therapie brauchen,
sondern die sagen müssen, ich beschäftige mich mit etwas Sinnvollem und frage
nicht den ganzen Tag, wie geht es mir, wie fühle ich mich?
Man weiß es ja von hypochondrisch veranlagten Leuten. Wenn ich den ganzen Tag
da sitze und überlege, wo drückt es jetzt noch überall? Dann werde ich wahrscheinlich
am Ende sagen, mit dem ganzen Körper stimmt was nicht.
Hier ist es so, ich fühle nur noch in mich hinein. Ich definiere mich wieder
und mache so und so und so.
Das ist ja einfach ein Diskurs, der hier aufgekommen ist, ein Innerlichkeitsdiskurs,
den es so nicht gegeben hat.
Das ist, nachdem man jetzt den Körper zum Tempel erklärt hat und sich damit
die ganze Zeit beschäftigt mit Fitnessstudien und so, sag mal,
jetzt könnte ich das noch intensivieren, indem ich jetzt mein Inneres die ganze Zeit bespiegle.
Ich will mal sagen, der innere Dialog ist ja nicht unbedeutend.
Nein. Aber man kommt auch nicht um ihn herum.
Man kann ihn aber steuern und lernen, so ein bisschen zielorientiert damit umzugehen.
Beispielsweise diese ganzen Triathleten. Also Jan Frodeno beschreibt das ja
in seinem Buch ganz deutlich, wie natürlich ab einer gewissen sportlichen Leistungsgrenze,
die man erreicht, der psychische Anteil auch von Bedeutung ist.
Und sei es nur, um die Trainingsbelastung auszuhalten, beim Wettkampf kann man
sich dann trotzdem gehen lassen oder wie auch immer. Nur diesen inneren Dialog.
Also sich einreden zu lassen, dass der innere Dialog dann besonders gut gelingt,
wenn er so unter Dankbarkeits, Achtsamkeits und was auch immer Gesichtspunkten läuft.
Und wenn man dann sozusagen ein schlechtes Gewissen sich selbst gegenüber bekommt,
wenn man nicht sofort mit Dankbarkeit beginnt, da sind wir schon auf einem ganz
falschen Track irgendwie, weil das ist ja dann unehrlich.
Es reicht ja in Rollendistanz mit allen anderen Menschen festzustellen,
wie Erwin Goffman schreibt, ach so, der eine sieht mich so, der andere sieht
mich so, also ich muss das auch so ein bisschen spielen. in der Erwartung entsprechen,
wie auch immer, nur nicht sich selbst gegenüber.
Also wieso soll man sich selbst, also man kann doch erst mal anfangen mit,
ich schreibe mal Tagebuch mit dem, was mir so kommt, anstatt es muss ein Liebesbrief
sein und beginne mit Danke, weil vielleicht will man sich echt mal nicht bedanken.
Vielleicht will man es mal ausleben.
So wir haben es jetzt ganz häufig so mit psychischen, angeschlagenen, jungen Menschen zu tun.
Clip schaffen wir dann heute nicht mehr, aber das kann man ja noch mal aufheben,
die so mit 18, 19, 20 Jahren durch Corona plötzlich feststellen,
ach so, es geht gar nicht allen Menschen so, sich selbst zu hassen und sterben
zu wollen. Für manche ist das jetzt neu.
Und da nützt es einem, also da ist der Ansatz für diese Art von,
und das ist ja völlig Banane irgendwie.
Das ist so ein gefühliges Sprechen, mit dem man dann sagen kann,
ach ja, ist aber toll, dass es so jemanden gibt, der sich so witzig im Einklang
ist. Also ich glaube, das Prinzip Jay Shetty besteht überhaupt nicht aus den
Ratschlägen, was ich ja dann in diesem Buch entnehmen kann.
Definiere Liebe, bevor du sie fühlst. Ja, wie soll ich das jetzt mal aufschreiben?
Und dann gehe ich los und sage, ich habe hier jetzt die Definition,
ich suche da was Passendes zu.
Schlepp dir da irgendwie drüber, was ist, wenn ich mich nicht nach Dankbarkeit
mir gegenüber fühle? Wie mache ich denn das dann?
Ja, dann bist du noch nicht mit ihr im Einklang. Dann bist du wahrscheinlich
noch zu sehr von den Meinungen anderer Menschen geprägt, Stefan.
Da müssen wir dich noch hinführen.
Das ist alles so.
Du musst calm down.
Ja, genau.
Also, wir hören mal weiter. Selbstwertgefühl.
Wenn wir nicht Selbstvertrauen auf uns selbst bauen, bedeutet das,
dass wir jemanden für uns bauen wollen. Und das macht keinen Sinn,
weil das Selbstvertrauen ist. Du kannst es nicht ausführen.
Und Selbstvertrauen wird durch das Erkennen von den schwierigen Dingen,
die du täglich tust, gebaut. Jeder in diesem Publikum macht etwas Schwieriges täglich.
Und Selbstvertrauen wird durch das Erkennen von den Fehlern,
die du jeden Tag durchgeführt Wie viele Herausforderungen und Schwierigkeiten du durchgegangen bist.
Und wenn du dich nur für einen Moment darauf hinwirkst, dann wirst du dir vorstellen,
dass du viel stärker bist, als du warst. Ich halte dich für einen Experten, weil du ein Monk warst.
Ja. Und er hatte auch erkannt, dass Filme irgendwie ziemlich prägend sind.
Ich liebe einen Rom-Com. So liebe ich ihn. Wie jeder andere.
Ich liebe die glücklichen Endungen. But I've always...
Viele der Dinge, die wir als Kind von Fairy-Tales bis zu diesen Filmen gelesen
haben, haben dich verletzt, weil du dich verletzt hast, was Liebe und Beziehungen wirklich aussehen.
Wie bekommst du die beiden zusammen? Das ist so wahr. Es gibt eine Szene in
der Notebook, in der Ryan Goslings Charakter auf Rachel McAdams Charakter geht
und sagt, ich werde alles sein, was du willst.
Ich werde alles tun, was du willst. Und die Leute waren so...
Und es war so, das ist unglaublich, ich will jemanden wie das,
der sich einfach überdreht und überdreht.
Es ist schrecklich. Und dann gibt es noch eine Szene, wo sie auf dem Ferris-Wheel
sind, und er hängt ab, und er ist so, I'll let go if you don't go on a date with me.
Can you imagine threatening someone? Self-harm. You see all these really unhealthy ideas.
And I think the problem is, and I love love too, by the way,
and I love rom-coms, and you get addicted to these ideas and now you're looking
for them in real life, but they don't transpire.
So the only way to disconnect is to say to yourself, wait a minute,
I don't see that in reality, I don't see it in my parents' relationship,
I don't see it in the family members around me.
Let me set a new set of rules. Lassen Sie mich ein neues Set von Grenzen und
Prinzipien setzen, die ich überleben möchte und die ich Liebe aussehen möchte.
Wir müssen lernen, Liebe zu definieren, Bei unserer eigenen Definition, für uns selbst.
Dabei gibt er natürlich nichts Originelles in seinem Buch da Preis.
Vor allem das natürlich, er guckt jetzt die anderen, die Drehbücher schreiben
und hat nur Kritik von ihm.
Und dann kommt aber keine Reflektionsstreife auf seinen Seiten.
Er schreibt jetzt auch ein Drehbuch und sagt zum Beispiel, nein,
also im Prinzip ist es ja, wie du sagst, er reflektiert ja sein eigenes Schreiben,
seine Narrative nicht, sondern er nur die, nur die, genau.
Man könnte jetzt genauso einen Flip darüber machen wie er. Man könnte jetzt
auch da sitzen und sagen, ja das Problem ist, dass ja viele so Jay Shetty Bücher lesen.
Also man muss erst mal sagen bei der Regel drei, definiere Liebe bevor du sich
fühlst, dass es darum geht, dass man gemeinsam Träume entwickelt,
wenn man dann sich gefunden hat.
Und das heißt auch, die Ziele des anderen unterstützen.
Und das heißt, du sollst Guru werden in der Beziehung.
Und wie ist das nun jetzt gemeint? Er schreibt, leite Deinen Partner an,
auf seine eigene Art zu lernen.
Der Guru ist nicht nur Lehrer, sondern auch Freund seines Schülers und hat stets
sein Wohl im Sinn. Ein guter Guru beobachtet, wie sein Schüler lernt und findet
die optimale Methode, ihm etwas beizubringen.
Falls Dein Partner nicht gerne liest, schlage ihm einen Podcast vor.
Finde heraus, wie du ihm seine Interessen anhand von deinen Interessen näher bringen kannst.
Ordne deinen Partner einem Lernstil zu. Und wenn du das dann gemacht hast,
dann kannst du mit ihm achtsam kommunizieren.
Und jetzt kommt für mich wirklich die höchste Form der Gewaltausübung und zwar
wie du Feedback geben sollst.
Man kann sagen, wenn du die Wäsche machst, ist immer alles verknittert.
Dann hören wir, du machst nie was richtig. Als Guru müssen wir darauf achten,
auf welche Weise wir Feedback geben.
Besser wäre etwa, ich bin sehr froh, dass du mir bei der Wäsche hilfst.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass die Wäsche verknittert, wenn ich sie länger im Trockner liegen lasse.
Deshalb werfe ich den Trockner immer erst an, wenn ich Zeit habe,
gleich alles zusammenzulegen.
Du kannst dir gern etwas anderes überlegen, aber es ist doch so,
dass keiner besonders scharf aufs Bügeln ist.
Was schlägst du vor? Und wenn so jemand mit mir diskutiert, würde ich wirklich
ihn anflehen und sagen, bitte schrei mich lieber an.
Wie kann denn das innerhalb von der Liebesbeziehung überhaupt möglich sein?
Ja, das ist hier eine Regel.
Also wer das liest und denkt, das ist ein sehr guter Hinweis für meine Liebesbeziehung,
hat keine Liebesbeziehung.
Das wahrscheinlich auch, ja.
Das ist nicht mal für die Kindererziehung, finde ich, diese Art der Ansprache.
Also es sind ein paar clevere Gedanken für die Kindererziehung dabei.
Ja, aber es ist ja hoch manipulativ, wenn man sagt, so gehe ich jetzt mit dem
Partner um. Also das ist ja schlimmer als jede moderne Management-Probe.
Nicht hier, aber Niklas Luhmanns Liebesbuch.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Und das ist ja ein ganz frühes Ding. Das hat er ja noch als Student oder so
geschrieben. Naja, verrückt.
Und da ist ja eigentlich diese Definition von Liebe, man teilt halt den Lebensentwurf des Anderen.
Aber nicht, weil man sich entschieden hat, sondern weil man fühlt, dass man das genau will.
Also das, was er hier, denk mal so und leite dich selbst an,
diese Basis kommst und dann entwickelt daraus eine Strategie der Kommunikation mit dem anderen.
Ne, wenn du das alles noch machen musst, ist es keine Liebesbeziehung.
Und dann ist es auch nur, wie Verena Balsen sagte, weil ihr Coach zu ihr sagte,
du kannst es nicht faken. Wenn es nicht da ist, kannst du es auch nicht hinfaken.
Das ist genau dieses Fake-Programm.
Sich das so hinzufaken und dem anderen dann auch noch runter zu jubeln.
Die ganze Zeit mit so extra Kalkülen an Sachen ranzugehen, in der Methode zu
variieren und Erfolgsstrategien auszutesten, das ist keine gesunde Liebesbeziehung.
Nee.
Und das geht auch nicht auf Dauer gut. Nee. Das ist ja bescheuert.
Ja, aber es ist alles in diesem Ton der Achtsamkeit vorgegangen.
Und ich hatte, als ich bei Corporate Therapy zu Gast war jetzt kürzlich,
hatte ich von dieser Sandwich-Methode gehört, wie man dann Feedback gibt.
Immer so, erst was Gutes, dann was Schlechtes. sondern wieder abheben und dann
wieder mit was Gutem, damit das so aufgebaut ist.
Und das schlägt er selbstverständlich auch vor, also man sieht dann, wie das geht.
Wir hören mal noch weiter zu den Dating-Apps.
Ich glaube, die Realität ist,
dass wir glauben, dass eine perfekte Person für uns da draußen wartet.
Und was ich durch die Leute, die ich coachen habe, durch die Beziehungen,
die ich mit ihnen gearbeitet habe, gefunden habe, ist, dass es keine perfekte
Person gibt, die man findet. Es ist, mit wem man es arbeiten kann.
Und es ist, mit wem man Energie und Enthusiasmus hat, in die Welt zu investieren.
Und ich denke, dass Menschen mit mehr Wahl immer schlimmer machen.
Wir vergessen das. Wenn wir mehr Wahl haben, machen wir schlechte Entscheidungen.
Und ich denke, dass viele von uns zu schnell oder zu schnell weitergehen.
Wir denken, dass jemand da draußen uns glücklich machen wird,
anstatt zu denken, dass wenn wir beide die Energie haben, das zu machen, es besser wird.
Ja, was soll ich sagen? Also diese Supermarkttheorie des Joghurts.
Wenn da 80 Joghurts steht, kauf dir trotzdem nur dein Lieblingsjoghurt,
weil am Mittwoch ist dir egal, dass du eine Variation zum Joghurt vom Montag
brauchst. Du hast halt meinen Lieblingsjoghurt und nach 24 Stunden hast du auch
wieder Lust auf deinen Lieblingsjoghurt, da brauchst du keine Variation.
Nur, ich dachte mittlerweile so...
Das haben alle geschaut. Also eigentlich sollte das bekannt sein.
Das ist das Ding. Also ich habe dann als Fazit mir unter meinen Notizen geschrieben,
wenn man nicht völlig verrückt ist, kommt man auf vieles selbst.
Also das ist, also es gibt einmal diese komischen.
Wenn man das nicht intuitiv versteht, ist man ganz falsch bei einer Beziehungsplanung.
Dann sollte man wirklich nochmal bei sich anfangen.
Aber ganz, ganz auf null setzen nochmal. Weil da sind so viele Dinge,
wo ich einfach sage, ja genau, also wenn man, bevor man die Schuhe anzieht, lieber erst die Hose.
Ja, so Dinge schreibt er einfach nochmal auf und deswegen hat das ja,
glaube ich, auch so diese Wirkmacht, dass du auf allen paar Seiten Dinge findest,
die so klar sind und dann kaufst du aber auch noch diesen anderen Kram ab mit,
achso, ja, wenn mir das eine klar ist, dann muss ja auch völlig logisch dass
ich mal einen Brief an mich selbst schreibe und mich bedanke.
Es gibt natürlich noch viel mehr in diesem Imperium. Zum Beispiel ein Genius-Programm.
Da bietet er dann auf seiner Webseite an, dass er dort als Coach zur Seite steht.
Es gibt dann da auch ein Quiz, das man machen kann.
Take my new quiz to discover your deeper purpose.
The right path for you is only a few steps away.
Wir hatten ja auch schon mal mit diesen Persönlichkeitsprofilen,
mit irgendwelchen Zahlen, die man dann dekodieren kann und dann steht man für,
weiß ich nicht, den General oder was weiß ich.
Und hier gibt es auch nun jetzt dieses komische Programm und hier wird das vorgestellt. Genius.
Es gab so viele Leute, die die Videos online geschaut haben.
Gleichzeitig gab es so viele Leute, die die Podcaste downloadeten.
Und heute, die sogar das Buch lesen. Aber ich habe mir das Gefühl,
dass, um einen wirklichen Wandel in einer Person zu schaffen, du drei Cs brauchst.
Diese drei Cs sind Coaching, Konsistenz und Gemeinschaft.
Du brauchst einen Trainer, der dir die Wege leitet, dir den Weg zeigt,
dir die Obstakte und Herausforderungen zeigt, die wahrscheinlich auf dich kommen werden.
Du brauchst Konsistenz, du brauchst das Verpflichten, wöchentlich etwas zu tun,
auf eine regelrechte Art und Weise, damit du eigentlich sehen kannst,
die Veränderung messen und verbessern
kannst und schaue, wie dein Leben Schritt für Schritt aufwächst.
Und du brauchst eine unglaubliche Gemeinschaft, um es dir zu helfen.
Ohne Verantwortung, ohne Freunde, ohne ein Gefühl für die Familie,
ist es wirklich schwierig, eine lastige Veränderung zu machen.
Also habe ich mit einem Team einen Genie entwickelt, sodass wir dir die Plattform,
den Ort, den Zweck geben können, den Schritt in Richtung deiner besten Selbst
in den Bereichen zu gehen, die am meisten bedeuten.
Ob es finanzielle, mentale, physikale, spirituelle, emotionale Gesundheit ist.
Wir priorisieren diese in Genius, damit du die beste Version deines Selbstes werden kannst.
Das ist ein bisschen wie die Listen-Notiz-App von Apple.
Seit Neuestem kannst du nicht einfach nur eine To-Do-Liste schreiben,
sondern du kannst sagen, das ist eine Einkaufsliste. Und dann würde das Obst
in Kategorien zusammengefasst.
Das erkennt dann, du hast Apfel draufgeschrieben und dann rutscht das nicht
irgendwo hin, weil der Apfel ist ja am Anfang im Supermarkt.
Also rutscht das ganz nach oben.
Nur die Leute sind auch damals schon mit Papier und Stift einkaufen gegangen,
haben sich das zu Hause aufgeschrieben in der Reihenfolge, die wahllos waren,
haben dann einfach einen Riss an der Seite reingemacht und haben gesehen,
ich hab ja schon Äpfel in meinem Wagen. Und so ist das hier auch ein bisschen.
Die kommen immer alle nur auf die gleiche Idee zurück, alle.
Es sind die Atomic Habits. Es gibt dieses Buch, das ungefähr zehn Milliarden
Mal verkauft wurde, das als Buch schon zu lange ist, weil es einfach nur diese
kurze ... Darüber und welche an welcher Routine du welches minimale Verhalten hängst.
Du gehst durch den Türrahmen machen Liegestütz. Dann hast du am Tag 10 Liegestütze
gemacht und du wolltest jetzt 10 Liegestütze machen.
Das ist die ganze Magic. Man braucht da kein App-Programm drumherum,
nicht nochmal eine Podcast-Geschichte oder sonst. Man hat die Idee sofort verstanden
und dann macht man es oder nicht. Das ist die ganze Idee der Selbstentwicklung.
Was man dann macht, kann man sich intuitiv mit sich beschäftigen,
irgendwas aus Erfahrung schöpfen oder wie auch immer.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Prinz Harry und Meghan schon dort zu Gast waren,
aber es würde so passen. Also wir haben das Buch ja gelesen,
das wäre eins zu eins das, was man da an den Erfahrungen machen kann.
Die treffen sich auf Augenhöhe.
Also man muss sagen, wer jetzt Interesse doch an Genius hat,
es ist ein bisschen teurer als der Salon.
Kostet 39 US-Dollar im Monat, also 390 US-Dollar dann im Jahr.
Das ist die Dating-App für dich selber.
Ja, das ist die Dating-App für dich selber und sie haben aber eine Studienauftrag
gegeben und dein … Wo denn?
Im Corn Institute?
Dein, wahrscheinlich, dein Sense of Purpose soll schon nach 90 Tagen Nutzung
um 40 Prozent sich steigern. 40 Prozent? Ja.
Und die Fähigkeit dich zu fokussieren steigert sich um 50 Prozent und … Ist
die Einheit von diesen Maßen, die … Es ist einfach so, man muss auch immer vertrauen.
Ich finde, wir müssen jetzt auch nicht da in die, ne? Das ist doch wunderbar.
Wir springen mal ein bisschen.
Wie finde ich eigentlich the one and only?
Wir sind also jetzt, gehen jetzt mal ein bisschen zurück zu seinem YouTube-Kanal.
Wie finde ich the one and only? Also wann kann ich mir sicher sein,
dass das, und hier sehen wir wieder, ja, hier sind jetzt auch einfach Tipps
dabei, die sind nicht verkehrt, aber die, Ja, braucht man die nochmal extra,
muss man die nochmal erzählt bekommen.
Hey everyone, this is Jay Shetty and welcome back to my YouTube channel.
When I make videos about love and relationships, I know that they really connect
with you. And a lot of you have been asking, Jay, how do you know when you found
the one? So here you go, this is the video for you.
Jetzt sind wir gespannt.
Ich bin jetzt wirklich sehr gespannt.
Ja, also wir machen nicht alle zehn Regeln, ich habe mal vier mitgebracht.
Die ich ja, die können wir jetzt mal diskutieren. Also erster, erster Tipp.
Nummer eins, sie unterstützen und respektieren eure Träume. Das bedeutet nicht,
dass sie deine Träume für dich machen werden. Das bedeutet nicht,
dass sie immer da sein werden, um dich anzusehen. Aber es bedeutet,
dass sie deine Priorität über deine Träume respektieren. Sie wertschätzen, was du suchst.
What? Sie teilen deinen Lebensentwurf? Cool. Das ist eine gute Kategorie, weil, ja klar.
Ja, also, dass man, das kann man, ja, vor allem sagen.
Also vielleicht sollte man es ja wirklich im Detail, weil wir machen ja alle so diese Erfahrungen.
Jemand, der deine Wünsche teilt oder, das hat er jetzt gar nicht angesprochen,
jemand mit dem du gemeinsame Wünsche entwickelst, die man gar nicht alleine haben kann.
Ja, sehr richtig, sehr richtig.
Zack, mach ich den nächsten Podcast zum Thema.
Vielleicht, also du siehst, was man hier verdienen kann, da gibt es nochmal
ganz andere Möglichkeiten.
Meldet euch, falls ihr das mit der App, also wie man eine Webseite in der App,
so dass es nicht so aussieht, als wäre es eine App, weil eine Webseite reicht
ja, ne? Ja. Dann teilen wir uns das 50-50. Zweiter Tipp.
Nummer zwei, sie werden dich wirklich im Moment präsent haben.
Ich liebe es, wenn ich mit Leuten umgehe, die mir helfen vergessen,
auf mein Handy zu schauen.
Das ist der Typ Person, mit der du sein möchtest. Jemand, der nicht von seinem
Handy, von seinen Nachrichten, von seinen Freunden oder von irgendetwas anderem
enttäuscht ist, wenn sie mit dir sind, sind sie mit dir. Wenn sie immer vergessen,
was du sagst, haben sie die Chance, dass sie nicht derjenige sind.
Also, habe ich mitgebracht für Bekannte, die hier zuhören, dass sie,
dass sie, doch die Smartphoneabhängigkeit nimmt ja zu.
Ich sage mal so.
Sagen wir mal so.
Es gibt, das kommt natürlich alles in meinem Buch. Du stellst das ja als super Thema.
Ich gebe dir gerne das Exzerpt.
Sehr gut. Es gibt bei YouTube Courtney Ryan, die macht sehr gute Dating-Videos,
aber aus dieser Position. Ich habe eine Paarbeziehung, bei mir ist alles klar.
Ich sehe das als interessierte Person und so weiter.
Und sie hat dann so verschiedene, manchmal hat sie auch so Gästinnen einfach
da, mit denen sie darüber redet.
Und sie hat so in diesem einen Fall, Woran erkennst du als Mann, dass die Frau dich mag?
Da hat sie eine Umfrage gemacht und die Antwort, weil sehr vielen Männern war.
Ich erkenne, dass sie mich mag.
Sie schreibt mir zurück. Und dann sitzt sie so vor der Kamera und sagt,
Männer, das kann nicht der Maßstab sein. Sie schreibt euch zurück.
Ihr fühlt es doch auch. Das reicht nicht. Also schön, dass euch mal jemand zurückschreibt
auf Tinder, aber das ist dann wirklich nicht so. Die Maßstäbe sind verrutscht.
Hier, ich würde ja sagen, man braucht keine Liebesbeziehung,
nicht mal eine freundschaftliche Beziehung, sondern es ist rudimentäre Höflichkeit,
dass jemand sein Smartphone stecken lässt.
Wenn das die Kategorie für, ist wirklich in dich verliebt ist,
dann sind die Maßstäbe verrutscht.
Aber ich meine, die Smartphone Nutzung ist ja… Exorbitant.
Aber ich finde, da sind dann doch die Maßstäbe verrutscht. Das stimmt.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen. Also wenn das jetzt schon reicht, wow,
hat keinmal aufs Smartphone innerhalb von zwei Stunden geguckt,
muss die Beziehung fürs Leben werden.
Ich sehe schon den Titel vom nächsten Clip.
Ja, wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich so gemeinsam?
Nummer 5. Du brauchst nicht immer jemanden oder etwas anderes,
um die Chemie zu halten, um das Unterhalten zu halten und Dinge frisch zu machen.
Wenn du dir vorstellen musst, dass du immer eine externe Form von Freude oder
Aufregung brauchst, um alles zwischen dir zu halten, ist es ein Zeichen,
dass du nicht mit dem anderen verbunden bist, sondern mit dieser anderen Sache verbunden bist.
Frage ich mich jetzt auch, was ist damit gemeint? Also klar kann man jetzt nicht
jedes Treffen spektakulär ausgestalten, aber irgendwie auf etwas Drittes ausgerichtet,
ist man ja eigentlich auch in einer guten Freundschaft.
Das heißt man hat gemeinsame Themen über die man spricht, man hat gemeinsame
Veranstaltungen die man besuchen will, das kann das Konzert sein,
genauso wie das Fußballspiel oder man spielt zusammen etwas.
Das heißt, man ist ja eigentlich auch.
Auf immer etwas gemeinschaftlich, auf was Drittes ausgerichtet.
Bei einem Paar dann vielleicht auch irgendwann ein Kind, ist auch eine Ausrichtung auf was Drittes.
Und man hat doch gerade, also das ist doch die Erfahrung, die zum Beispiel ganz
viele Leute machen, wenn sie aus der Schule raus sind, dann hält man ja noch
so einen losen Kontakt und irgendwann bricht dieser Kontakt ab.
Weil man merkt, es war mal eine Ausrichtung dieser Freundschaft auf etwas Drittes.
Wenn dies aber völlig wegfällt, man kann sich ja nicht nur gegenüber sitzen
und sagen, wir finden uns so toll oder wir finden uns so nett.
Das heißt, da ist eine gewisse Ausrichtung auf was Drittes. Klar muss man jetzt
nicht jeden Tag ein Feuerwerk sehen.
Also, wenn man sich in Liebesbeziehungen den Weltentwurf des anderen teilt,
wäre es schon gut, wenn einer da ist, den man unterscheiden kann von anderen
Weltentwürfen, also der einen Unterschied macht.
Okay, also benötigt man etwas Drittes, hattest du geschrieben.
Ich habe das jetzt sehr schnell auf so eine soziale Ebene, aber es ist auf der Sachebene.
Klar braucht man da irgendwas. Auf der Sozialebene ist es natürlich schon wieder was anderes.
Weißt du, wen er getraut hat übrigens? Jennifer Lopez und Ben Affleck.
Jetzt bei der Wiederholten.
Toll, ne? Da wünscht man doch viel Glück.
Also Ben Affleck rennt ja seit Jahrzehnten durch Hollywood und alle,
die ihn sehen, abseits seiner Filme, sehen, dass er trübsinnig ist.
Nicht besonders fröhlich. Und dann gibt es dieses eine kurze Clipding,
wie er Jennifer Lopez ins Auto steigen lässt und die Tür dann hinter eher so zuknallt.
Und das kennt man sehr häufig aus diesen Situationen, das ist eigentlich recht
amüsant, wenn man es so beschreibt.
Eltern packen das Auto, weil die Kinder irgendwo hin müssen.
Kofferraum zu, Kinder rein, Kinder anschnallen, rückwärts aus dem Auto hinten
rauskrabbeln, Tür der Kinder zumachen.
Und diese zwei Sekunden, die man hat, bevor man vorne wieder einsteigt. Weißt du?
Zieht man ein Gesicht.
Die sind sehr erlösend. Das sind so diese zwei Sekunden. Okay,
gut, ich hab's alles geschafft.
Ich hab kurz für mich. Jetzt steige ich vorne wieder ein. Der Lärm geht wieder los.
Mama, Mama, Papa, Papa, was ist? Und so weiter. Diese zwei Sekunden.
Und das hat man auch bei Ben Affleck gesehen in diesem in diesem kurzen Snippet,
wie er so diese Autotür zuschlägt und dann so ganz erleichtert diese drei Sekunden
ums Auto reingeht und dann,
okay, Zurück in diese nicht sehr schöne Paarbeziehung wahrscheinlich,
dass die beiden sich irgendwie da sitzen und gemeinsam diese Podcasts hören
und diese Bücher sich vorlesen.
Man kann es sich vorstellen.
Genau. Und dass die sich dann davon trauen lassen, finde ich ehrlicherweise
einen ganz traurigen Fakt.
Also es macht mich wirklich ein bisschen traurig zu hören. Ja,
ja, dass so erfolgreiche, schöne Menschen so… Ja, dass die es irgendwie auf
der Ebene leider bewältigen.
Ich meine, es ist auch in gewisser Weise erleichternd zu sehen,
da ist es auch nicht besser.
Ja, vielleicht ist das für viele auch so, das Phänomen, dass man sich damit
beschäftigen will, wenn man sagt, naja, wenn selbst die da ihre Probleme haben,
dann ist es doch auch okay. Nun.
Ich gebe dir noch einen Satz mit auf den Weg. Lass nicht jeden Stolperstein dein Leben bestimmen.
Tolle, ne? So, jetzt letzter Tipp für the one and only. Nummer acht.
Du musst nicht alle Freunde lieben.
Ich denke, es gibt so viel Druck, von den Freunden der anderen Person zu lieben,
dass sie deine Freunde lieben, dass deine Freunde sie lieben.
Die Chancen sind, dass du viel zu viele Tickboxen reinlegst,
die ziemlich schwierig zu managen werden.
Wenn deine Freunde denken, dass sie völlig verrückt sind oder sie denken,
dass deine Freunde verrückt sind, dann schau dir das an.
Sie ist sehr peinlich, Kumpel. Aber die Wahrheit ist, dass es wichtig ist, dass ihr alleine seid.
Das heißt, aber ich verstehe mich mit allen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so,
dass ich sage, kann es kommen, aber bring ja nicht deinen Mann mit, ja.
Sondern es ist aber so, dass ich kein Interesse oder kein gesteigertes Interesse
habe zu sagen, dass wir uns zusammentreffen, weil es auch, weil es bei mir,
genau, und das kann ich auch begründen damit, die Freundschaft ist ja auf etwas
Drittes ausgelegt, das wir da teilen.
Wenn das aber von der anderen Person, also dem Partner, Partnerin nicht geteilt
wird, weiß ich nicht, in die Oper gehen oder so, muss ich ja nicht jemanden mit noch da mitziehen.
Da hätte ich dann keine Lust zu.
Aber zugleich ist es auch wieder völlig falsch, weil man ja erst mal sagen muss,
der eigene Freundesbekanntenkreis ist ja nicht eine Gruppe, die man so trifft,
die sitzen da alle in einem Raum, sondern selbst der Der ist ja schon unterteilt, ausdifferenziert.
Bei dem man sagen würde, ich würde jetzt nicht auf die Idee kommen,
Freund X mit Freund Y zusammenzubringen, um gemeinsam mit ihnen zu gehen.
Ich würde das eher separiert halten.
Die begegnen sich vielleicht mal auf einer größeren Feier oder so,
würde man sich alle treffen.
Aber eigentlich passt das nicht so richtig zusammen, weil man dann doch verschieden aufgestellt ist.
Ich sehe das ein bisschen so, aus nicht nur eigener Erfahrung,
sondern weil man es ja auch dann so in der Peripherie, weil man nämlich mal
zu diesem Freundeskreis gehört, wo Menschen sich dann vielleicht auch mal lieben oder so.
Ich würde sagen, so wie er das jetzt gesagt hat, ist es grundfalsch.
Du musst die anderen nicht mögen. Ich finde aber, es steckt ein ganz großer
Indikator da drin, wie dir die Freunde von Freunden begegnen. entgegnen.
Weil da zum Beispiel zur Geltung kommt, wie wird eigentlich über dich geredet,
wenn du nicht da bist? Welchen Stand hast du denn so insgesamt?
Und damit ist das zum einen gesagt,
aber völlig eingepreist, dass dieser weitere soziale Kreis natürlich aus Gründen da ist,
weil ich auch, vielleicht hatte das auch an so einem Punkt, überfrachte nicht die Zweierbeziehung,
nur weil sie so liebend und wir alle so, das ist aber Magic und wir können uns das gar nicht erklären,
Aber dann baue nicht alles da rein, sondern schaffe die Distanz,
damit sich jemand in so ganz speziellen Neigungen so ausleben kann,
wie er es möchte, mit jemanden, die das auch möchte, sodass es da nicht zu irgendwelchen
Schieflagen und so weiter kommt.
Und klar, man hat dann Freundeskreise, mit denen man andere Sachen macht als
mit anderen Freundeskreisen. Also man braucht nicht mal eine Liebesbeziehung
jetzt für diese Art der Erklärung.
Aber trotzdem finde ich, wenn man… Es ist schon aus… also es ist ja auch aussagekräftig,
welche Freunde Leute haben, also über die Persönlichkeit, weil da hier immer,
glaube ich, so mitschwingt.
Es gibt so ein Ich, das ist so irgendwie da, das ist sogar so von mir losgelöst,
dass ich dem selbst mal einen Brief schreiben kann.
Und dieses… und so ein Ich finde ich auch dann in the one and only,
aber das hat nichts mit irgendwelchen sozialen Kontexten oder ökonomischen Kontexten zu tun.
Und hat auch eigentlich dann nichts mit den Freunden zu tun.
Und das stimmt ja nicht. Also gewisse Leute haben gewisse Freunde.
Das ist einfach so. Also das wäre, würde man ja nicht sagen,
ist wirklich ein ganz tolles Ich, was ich da kennengelernt habe, so mir gegenüber.
Hat halt so ein völliger AfD-Freundeskreis, aber das Ich ist ganz reingeblieben davon.
Das ist ja Unsinnig. Also diese diese Spaltung, die er da immer sich vorstellt,
dass man sich da gegenseitig Briefe schreiben, sich selbst Briefe schreiben
kann, das zeigt sich dann darin auch.
Also da da da hakt das wieder. Aber wir sehen jetzt gerade wir verzetteln uns
ja selbst, gehen jetzt selbst auf so eine Jay Shetty eben, wie verführerisch
das ist, dass man sowas von dem bekommt, was so nicht abzulegen ist.
Also bei Andrew Tate hast du ja einfach jemanden, da versperrst du dich ja völlig
und sagst, oh Gott, aber hier hast du jemanden, der ja immer alles so halb falsch und halb richtig ist.
In dem Falle, ich finde, das ist ganz falsch. Also man muss die Freunde des
anderen nicht mögen als Prämisse.
Ja, aber das sagt er.
Genau, das sagt er und ich finde es ganz falsch. Denn ja, da sind immer mal
welche dabei und die kann man dann vielleicht nicht mögen aus Gründen oder was
auch immer. Aber ich finde für eine Zweierbeziehung und wie sie sich verändert, ist es ein ganz,
deutlicher Indikator, ob sich das eigene Denken über die Freunde verändert.
Ja, das stimmt. Weil wenn sich das verändert, droppt sich das so langsam ran.
Und dann läuft auch der Countdown für die Beziehung. Und das muss man sich dann auch nicht schönreden.
Also ich rede jetzt arbeitsthesenhaft, während er so Thesen macht.
Ich übertreibe ein bisschen in der Formulierung. Aber ich finde,
da steckt so ein Indikator, den man dann durchaus mal expliziter hinterfragen
sollte, als man es nur so mitfühlen lässt.
Ich hatte die ja noch nie gemocht und so, vielleicht hat man sie ja doch mal
ein bisschen mehr gemocht, aber jetzt weniger.
Das schleppt sich dann so, das kommt dann so ran irgendwie. Also da würde ich
sagen, da muss man dann schon...
Ich glaube aber, wo er recht hat, ist, dass man eine gewisse Distanz haben muss.
Und es gibt ja Leute, die, sobald sie in Beziehungen sind, nur noch zu zweit
denkbar sind. Und da fragt man sich schon, wieso soll...
Ja, mit 18 kann man das machen, aber nicht mit 18.
Soll ich das mitmachen? Also, wenn man jetzt irgendwie einen guten Freund hat
seit Ewigkeiten und dann sind die zu zweit, dann ist das ja schön mal dann was
zu unternehmen, aber es muss ja dann nicht immer im Duo sein.
Also müssen die nicht immer im Duo auftreten, da sehe ich ja keinen Sinn drin.
So, jetzt gehen wir noch zum letzten Thema über Jay Shetty, zum Thema Sex.
Da bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt.
Das sind wahrscheinlich so, da werden dann E-Mails kommen, also wir hören uns
das mal erst an hier, Sex und Buddha.
Aber das Wasseren der Intimität, die Entwicklung der Intimität,
das Wachstum von Unterhaltung zu Experimenten, zu Erfahrungen,
zur Bildung, zur Zusammenarbeit in der Dienstleistung, all das kreiert so viel
Intimität, dass die physische Intimität ein natürliches Gegenüber ist.
Also das Bild ist klar, die Blume,
die gepflückt wird, das ist nicht die geliebt wird, sondern die sexuell begehrt
wird während der tägliche Einsatz für die Blume, sie bewässern,
Sie bewässern, pflegen, hegen. Das ist die Liebe.
Ja, ich finde, die Metapher ist irgendwie intuitiv plausibel.
Aber wir wissen ja, Naturmetaphern für menschliche Verhältnisse immer schwierig.
Sie ist unpassend bescheuert. Ja, denn überleg mal jetzt mal nur rein professionell.
Wir sind da im Salon, wir haben da ja auch so...
Relativ viele jüngere Mitmacher in dieser Podcast-Welt, die dann die Gelegenheit
nutzen, da bei uns zu sein und so.
Das sind doch alles Menschen, die wir hegen und pflegen wie so ein kleines Pflänzchen
und dann gießen wir nochmal Wasser raus und bezahlen die Cocktails und unterstützen
hier und verschaffen Räume oder wie auch immer.
Nur wir fallen doch nicht über die her, im Sinne von körperlicher Anziehung
und so weiter. Wir sind doch hier in einer ganz anderen Kategorie bei dieser Art von Metapher.
Nee, nee, er meint ja einfach, also er nimmt ja angeblich diese Metapher dazu,
um zu sagen, dass wer die Blume täglich pflegt, der liebt sie.
Wer die Blume pflückt, also im Sinne von Sex.
Das kurze Vergnügen. Und genau und das und das und das und jetzt und jetzt kommen
wir also das ist die Idee und jetzt kommen wir jetzt zu sein,
weil das sein vorhin schon ja also diese Oxytocin Oxytocin Sache und so.
Es wird immer so unterstellt, dass Menschen so unglaublich häufig Sex ohne Liebe haben.
Während das in meinen Erzählungen, die ich so bekomme, selten ist,
ich das von mir gar nicht kenne und die Statistik auch sagt, das ist nicht so.
Die Leute haben unglaublich wenig Sex und immer später. Die Tendenzen sind genau
andersrum, als wenn Boomer über Jugendliche reden, weil sie ihre eigene Jugend
im Hinterkopf haben oder so was.
Und von der Sicht bin ich mir sowieso nicht so sicher, ob er hier gerade einen Zeitgeist trifft.
Außer er macht natürlich nur Programme für die 10 Prozent, die sich auf Tinder
die ganze Zeit aneinander andaten, weil die es einfach schaffen,
innerhalb von zwei Tagen was zu organisieren.
Aber das sind so wenig das ist so verschwindend.
Ja aber also ich würde jetzt mal so hier hat er tatsächlich eine interessante
also das ist eine interessante Überlegung die er hier anstellt irgendwas muss
man ja auch mal Positives sagen.
Und dass es ihm die Möglichkeit gab, bessere Entscheidungen zu treffen,
ob es wirklich Intimität gab, ob es wirklich eine Verbindung gab und ob hier etwas wirklich war.
Das könnte mit Sex gebaut werden. Anstatt zu sagen, ich bin einfach so attraktiv
zu ihr, sie ist so attraktiv zu mir, wir haben das beste Sex je, oder wir nicht.
Dann hängt das alles an. Also würde ich eigentlich auf diese Art gehen und sagen,
dass Zölibat nicht so sein muss, wie ich es war als Mönch.
Zölibat kann in kleinen Dosen verwendet werden, nicht weil man zölibatisch ist
und sich verletzt. Das ist nicht, was ich empfehle.
Was ich empfehle, ist, es nicht als eine Art, Ich denke,
dass wir tatsächlich vielfach die Situation haben,
dass Datings sehr darauf ausgelegt sind,
dass also das Date erfolgreich war, dass es an den Sex geknüpft ist und dass
dadurch auch sich sehr viel erstmal nicht aufbauen kann oder so nachträglich
sich aufbaut, erst möglicherweise.
Also es gibt natürlich solche und solche Wege, die daraus sich ableiten.
Aber ich denke, dass es schon einen gewissen Punkt hat, dass diese Dating-Apps,
wenn man sieht, wie sie programmiert sind, was sie nach vorne stellen und so,
ganz darauf ausgelegt sind, zeig dich mit deinem sexuell begehrenswerten Körper,
gib schon entsprechende Daten dazu an, dass man schon weiß, was nicht zu sehen
ist, wie es aber sonst dann noch da aussieht,
was du willst im Bett und et cetera.
Und dann kann man das jetzt mal durch explizieren dann beim realen Date.
Aber natürlich ist es da ganz schwer, von dieser Ausgangslage eigentlich auf
eine andere Ebene zu kommen.
Und da glaube ich scheitern ja viele. Also ich denke, die Einsamkeit liegt ja
nicht nur darin, dass die Leute sich gar nicht begegnen, sondern dass sie einander
begegnen, aber dann nur so kurz. Und es ist ja kein wirklich...
Also weil man sagt dann immer, die sind intim geworden. Nee,
man wird ja gar nicht intim, wenn man jemanden zwei Stunden kennt und dann im Bett landet.
Dann ist es in dem Sinne keine Intimität, sondern das ist halt ein sehr großes
Maskenspiel im ausgezogenen Zustand, wenn man so will.
Aber ich glaube, dass da ein gewisser Punkt drin liegt, der sicherlich nicht
zu irgendeinem komischen Konservatismus führen sollte.
Aber ich glaube, das zu bedenken, dass die Programmierung dieser Apps eigentlich auf diese,
die so sehr ausgerichtet ist und dass damit die ganzen anderen Dimensionen,
weshalb Menschen eigentlich Beziehungen suchen, ausgeblendet sind oder zumindest
sehr stark marginalisiert sind, das scheint mir schon ein größeres Problem zu sein.
Und das anzusprechen halte ich jetzt nicht für falsch.
Das stimmt. Ich frage mich nur, ob mit dieser intuitiven Plausibilität mit Erde das jetzt formuliert.
Und wir kennen ja alle, ich habe es häufiger genannt, aber ich muss nochmal raussuchen, wer genau.
Es gab diesen einen Wirtschaftswissenschafts-Nobelpreis für die These,
jede Bauernregel hat auch einen Gegenentwurf.
So.
Ja, also, ich würde sagen, wir würden jetzt ...
Was ist jetzt hier der Gegenentwurf zu dem, was er sagte? Den kann man ja auch
genau so formulieren. Ich versuch's mal.
Sehr viele Männer stellen fest ...
Also, ich werde das natürlich noch mal so durchrecherchieren,
dass ich's möglichst hart formulieren kann.
Aber sehr viele Männer stellen ja fest, dass sie auf einer Dating-Plattform sind, die immer läuft.
Unter so wie du es jetzt auch schon so, dass es eigentlich eine Sex-Plattform
ist. Es läuft so hauptsächlich Sex oder der Körper.
Also man sieht vor allem Bilder und entscheidet sich dann dafür.
Und dann gibt es ja zwei Hürden.
Man trifft dann die Person im realen Leben und stellt fest, Distanz,
Bild und Person ist so ein bisschen so und so.
Wie fühle ich mich denn damit? Also fühle ich mich jetzt veralbert oder denke
ich mir, ah ja, zum Glück ging es auf.
Ich habe bekommen, was mir versprochen wurde, sozusagen von der App.
Also geht man diesen körperlichen Track weiter und dann, und das ist ganz hochinteressant,
dass ja Männern immer unterstellt wird, die wollen ja nur Sex.
Nur sagt dann auch die Forschung, naja, das ist schon so ein bisschen so,
dieses verführerische Moment ist ganz unterschiedlich danach,
ob man schon weiß, was man dann bekommt oder nicht.
Also die erste Verführung und das erste Mal ist zu Recht hervorgehoben im Vergleich
zur Routine-Angelegenheit, die es später werden kann.
Und ich würde sagen, ja, das kennen wir ja aus vielerlei Diskursen,
Unterschieds von Verliebtsein und Liebe und wie auch immer, welche Zugeständnisse
macht man, wo gesteht man sich selber ein, dass man hier über etwas hinweg sieht,
Gefühlslagen sind ja auch ein bisschen Entscheidungssache und so weiter und so fort.
Und was man immer mal wieder hört, ist so dieses Phänomen, dass Männer ganz
vernaht sind in Frauen, Und erst nachdem sie dann mit ihr Sex hatten,
feststellen, dass es so eine Jäger-Mentalität war.
Sie wurden nicht nur von der Frau verführt, sondern auch von ihrer eigenen Sehnsucht.
So. Und diesen Moment, also der kann sehr belastend sein, gerade wenn eine Beziehung
schon lange läuft, lange läuft, wenn der Mann dann feststellt,
dass er nicht mehr so lange läuft, wie er
Nee, das körperliche ist mir wichtig und ich kam doch nicht auf meine Kosten.
Ich möchte weiter single bleiben.
So, und jetzt wäre der Gegenentwurf zu dem, was er gerade sagte.
Geht doch zuerst einmal zusammen ins Bett und versucht danach immer noch eine Beziehung zu wollen.
Ja, also das ist ja was, was, was, was, würde ich sagen, das dominantere Konzept ist.
Bleibt doch mal, versuch doch, ob der Wunsch bleibt, nachdem eigentlich das,
was dir so schon in Erfüllung geht.
Also es wäre sozusagen der Gegenentwurf zu dem. Und den finde ich,
wenn man die beiden gegenüber stellt, ich wüsste jetzt.
Ich kann das auch nicht entscheiden.
Also ich wüsste rational, welcher besser ist als der eine. Aber so emotional
würde ich sagen, sind die beiden auf Augenhöhe.
Also man wüsste jetzt nicht genau, welcher wäre der vernünftige,
wenn man mal ausblendet, wie dieses Dating ansonsten in real life so stattfindet.
Es ist ein bisschen wie bei den Medizinern, du wirst es mit toten Körpern zu
tun haben und das macht einen sehr großen Unterschied für die Universität.
Die spart nämlich dann ein paar hunderttausend Euro, ob sie dir gleich in der
ersten Woche des Studiums einen toten Menschen zeigt und du sagst,
ach so, nee, scheiße, kann ich doch nicht.
Oder halt am Ende des Studiums, wo du denkst, krass, so viel investiert.
Und das ist mein Arbeitsgegenstand für die nächsten 40 Jahre,
scheiße. Scheiße. So auf der Ebene irgendwie müsste man das mal.
Aber ich habe das jetzt nur formuliert als Gegenentwurf. Ich bin nicht dafür,
dass man sofort ins Bett geht beim ersten Date und so weiter,
um da irgendwie zu testen.
Du hast völlig recht. Und wir werden Leute haben, die uns hören,
die sagen, ja genau, so war das bei mir.
Wir sind sofort ins Bett gegangen und sind jetzt seit fünf Jahren zusammen oder
zehn Jahren zusammen. Und man wird Leute haben, die sagen, ja,
wir haben uns dann lange nicht getraut und haben drei Monate gewartet und wir
sind jetzt auch seit zehn Jahren zusammen.
Es gibt gar keine allgemeine Regel daraus.
Kann es keine Regel ableiten. Und das ist, glaube ich, das Verrückte, dass wir nun...
In der Moderne angekommen sind eigentlich, also das ist ja unser großer Wunsch
und der erfüllt sich dann so selten,
wo man sagen muss, ja diese Regelwerke, es hat schon keine Regelpoetik im Barock
geben können, also die ging nur dadurch, dass man die ganze Zeit sie missachtet, ja.
Und jetzt versucht man eine Regelpoetik der Liebe aufzubauen und kann es natürlich
auch nicht, weil man sofort aus eigener Erfahrung oder aus Freunden,
Freundeskreis, Bekanntenkreis Gegenbeispiele findet, die sagen,
ach nee, das geht ja gar nicht nach Regel.
Und dann kommt man nur noch darauf hinaus, dass so die, die aller selbstverständlichsten
Dinge, bei denen man sagt, ja klar, da hat er ja aber auch recht.
Also man muss irgendwie nett zueinander sein. Das stimmt ja aber wirklich,
dass man eigentlich nur noch eine Zustimmung dazugeben kann,
wo man, wo man sagt, ja, aber das wussten wir ja nun wirklich alle schon vorher,
wenn man nicht völlig verdreht ist.
Und da finde ich, ist es ein Phänomen, dass ja Instagram besonders bevölkern.
Das ist ja jetzt nur ein Beispiel für tausende Codes und Programme und Bücher,
die einem alle immer nur dasselbe sagen. Und deswegen gebe ich dir zum Schluss
auch noch einen Rat mit auf den Weg.
Träume müssen nicht groß sein, aber es müssen deine Träume sein.
Finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, sagen wir es mal so.
Sehr gut, ja, okay, liebt mehr, wie auch immer das geht.
Wir sind jetzt schon am Ende angekommen, du hast noch einen witzigen Clip.
Also ich sah, irgendwo habe ich da so einen bekannten Namen,
einen wiederkehrenden Namen gesehen. Ja, welchen? Da war noch mal so eine kleine Corona-Nachlese.
Oh mein Gott, ich habe es vorhin referiert, dass Lauterbach sagte,
die Kliniken füllen sich nicht und belassen wir es dabei, da wir einen anderen
Humor haben oder sagen wir mal so, das Publikum ist darauf vorbereitet,
jetzt ganz ernste Themen, aber noch mal humoristisch.
Es gibt den Podcast, wo habe ich den? Hier, Sicherheitshalber,
Thomas Wiegold, Militärexperte und Co., Masala, wie sie alle heißen.
Und da ist einer dabei, Frank Sauer, auch von der Bundeswehr, Uni in München.
Und die sitzen ja zusammen, besprechen den Krieg. Die haben diesen Podcast schon
lange über den Krieg hinaus, die sind in der 75.
Folge, vielleicht ist es so die 40. oder 50. zum Krieg, so in den letzten anderthalb Jahren.
Und ich war ein bisschen überrascht über diesen einen Ausspruch, den wir jetzt hören.
Es gab diese Doku in der ARD.
Und die haben die Doku geschaut. Ich habe sie noch nicht gesehen, weil ich mir denke...
Ich habe reingeguckt, es ist furchtbar.
Ich kenne die Nachrichtenlage und ich weiß, wie Stefan Lambi die Filme macht.
Er ist nämlich einfach im Zimmer dabei.
Ja, die sind im Regierungsflieger und dann spricht Christina Dunst nochmal darüber,
worüber sie immer halt so spricht. Also ich sehe Regierungspolitiker und Regierungsjournalisten,
wie sie so einen Film gemeinsam machen.
Und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, das erste Mal hat mich ein Teaser,
hat mir ein Teaser gesagt, nee, musst du nicht gucken.
Weil Stefan Lambi immer betont hat, er wollte nicht, dass die Journalisten im
Nachhinein erzählen, sondern dass er die am Tage erwischt. Ich sehe also wirklich
nur Archivmaterial mit Leuten, die zu nah am Panorama stehen,
um mir irgendwas nochmal zu erklären, ja später sozusagen.
Und dieser Film war aber trotzdem sehr instruktiv für die Leute,
die uns peripher des Medien oder mit Masala eben auch mittendrin,
aber hier dann in Länge und so den Krieg erklären die ganze Zeit.
Die uns immer Bescheid wissen angeblich.
Genau, die uns plötzlich an der Manufaktur ihrer Gedankengänge teilnehmen lassen,
auf einer Art und Weise, bei denen ich dachte.
Krass das hätte ich nicht gedacht ich dachte das mehr ich also warum
höre ich diesen podcast ich habe es ja wir hören uns das mal kurz an ich habe
diese dreiteilige ad logo geguckt irgendwie die den titel trägt regieren am
limit was so quasi in twitter wird sein könnte diese gestern oder was ja ja
die habe ich auch gesehen ja ja genau.
Und ich fand die außerordentlich aufschlussreich. Ich finde,
es sollten auch vor allen Dingen mal diejenigen gucken, die da immer besonders
laut schreien, wie schrecklich unsere Regierung ist und wie die alle quasi gar nichts können und so.
Oder insbesondere natürlich auch die Leute, die auf Scholz eindreschen und alle
im Kanzleramt, was diese Waffenlieferungsthematik.
Er meint sich selbst, er meint den Masala, die im Fernsehen die ganze Zeit erzählen,
das müssen jetzt die Panzer und so weiter, das muss ja alles gemacht werden.
Es ist wirklich crazy, was jetzt hier für eine Party.
Die Leute, die Leute.
Die Leute, ja genau, wer sind diese Leute.
Ich finde man sieht den Leuten da schon an, dass es sie ernsthaft sozusagen
irgendwie umtreibt, so bestimmte Dinge.
Und ich finde es halt immer schwierig von der Couch aus zu sagen, was ziehen die sich so.
Ich glaube wenn man in dieser verantwortung steckt ist man sogar gezwungen das
doppelt zu überdenken ich würde immer noch behaupten.
Es wäre besser sie wären 15 prozent mehr entschlossener aber der eindruck der
sich vermittelt in dieser doku wenn man scholz zuhört schmidt zuhört und so weiter.
Ist halt schon dass die extrem sich sorge machen vor diesem flächenbrand und
das ist ein das ist quasi ein motiv was in dieser doku von 22 bis 23 sich über
12 13 14 monate durchzieht.
Und mehr oder weniger gleich geblieben ist im denken von leuten wie scholz und
schmidt und so weiter und deswegen glaube ich.
Dieses nicht diesen krieg sich ausweiten lassen so dass nato beteiligt wird
und so weiter ist nach wie vor ein absolut zentrales motiv ich sage nicht dass
ich das teile ich sage nur das ist das was da eine rolle spielt.
Das ist doch irre.
Also die, die hier als Berater und alles auftreten, die die großen,
die wissen, die offenbar von gar nichts eine Ahnung haben,
also die völlig, völlig so da, eine Doku von Lambi,
die so populär nochmal jetzt hier für die Leute, die auf der Couch liegen,
zeigt, Mensch ist das stressig, Regierungsflieger rein, Regierungsflieger raus,
ja, die kriegen jetzt, also die, die ganz dicht dran sind auch an den ganzen,
ja, Herr Strack-Zimmermann hat mir heute morgen auch nochmal, das und das gesagt, ja.
Die kommen und sagen, das ist ja ganz erstaunlich, also Scholzes,
der macht sich ja schon so Gedanken,
auch wenn er so eine Entscheidung trifft und die hadern auch da mit manchem
und da gibt es auch so eine echte
Angst auch, ein Bedenken, dass sich das ausweiten könnte, so ein Krieg.
Soll ja schon vorgekommen sein. Also ja, man kann darüber nur den Kopf schütteln.
Ich hab noch einen zweiten Clip für dich. Und muss sagen, diese Experten sind keine.
Der zweite Clip ist vielleicht für unser Gespräch, das wir auch bisher zum Krieg hatten.
Ich meine, das war jetzt amüsant, aber jetzt wird es, glaube ich,
auch ein bisschen wichtig.
Und du siehst halt unten auf dem Boden, siehst du die Leute,
die von den Abwürfen von diesen Systemen, wenn es Drohnen waren zum Beispiel,
ja Leid davon tragen, mit dem sie ihr ganzes Leben lang rumlaufen werden.
Das war auch so ein Gespräch, die ich geführt habe, die wir vielleicht hier
auch mal führen könnten bei einer anderen Gelegenheit. So diese Frage,
da wird ja im Grunde auch eine ganze Generation und ein ganzes Land traumatisiert.
Was das für die nächsten 20, 30, 40 Jahre bedeutet, auch mit Blick auf Europa
und die Friedens- und Sicherheitsarchitekturen, die zu schaffen sind.
Ich würde eigentlich tatsächlich ganz gerne noch was über Taurus fragen.
So, also das waren jetzt hier so zehn Sekunden. Wir könnten ja auch mal über
diese jahrzehntelangen Generationen prägenden Verwerfungen und Traumata sprechen.
Aber ich hab noch mal eine Frage zu diesen Langstreckendingern,
die jetzt nicht geliefert werden.
Wo du denkst, Alter, jetzt führ doch mal diese Gespräche zum Krieg.
Über anderthalb Jahre Krieg.
Nee, ist ja auch ... Also, das war noch ... Ich mein, die, die alle diese Schlachtrufe
losgetreten haben und Scholz zögert und so. In unserem präferierten Podcast
wollen wir hier nicht nochmal alle aufrufen, die das getan haben.
Die haben ja zum Beispiel auch jetzt den Krieg so ziemlich für sich abgegeben.
Also die gehen jetzt rüber zum Feld der AfD, Aiwanger, Röder Co.
Und irgendwann werden die nur noch verkünden, dass es jetzt Verhandlungen haben jetzt begonnen.
Und wahrscheinlich werden sie auch dann sagen, dass die also auch alternativlos
sind, die genauso wie alternativlos alle Waffenlieferungen gewesen sind.
Und dann ist das gut. Und hier muss man noch, die müssen ja noch weiterhin am
Ball bleiben und kommen dann jetzt so nach anderthalb Jahren auf die Idee,
ach ja im Moment Krieg, wer ist eigentlich davon so noch getroffen, wenn die.
Was bedeutet eigentlich Krieg in unserem Kriegspodcast?
Ja.
Okay, gut. Das ist wirklich, als wir angefangen haben 2020, ich glaube,
es war direkt im Januar mit Christine Lagarde, die dann in der EZB,
Was ist eigentlich Inflation?
Ja, wir müssen da nochmal neu drüber nachdenken.
Genau, so ist das hier auch. Es ist wirklich, es ist irre, aber es ist, wie es ist.
Ja, wir bleiben dabei. Wir wollen noch hinweisen, dass wir uns im Salon sehen können.
Wir haben schon gesagt, wie man da hinkommt. Patreon, Apple ist schon benannt.
Über Spotify kommt man zu Steady. Man kann über die neuen 20er zu Steady kommen.
Man kann auf Steady zu Steady kommen.
Also einfach die Steady-Seite aufrufen, unseren Podcast suchen,
am einfachsten ist es aber über neu20er.de.
Dort findet man diesmal eine kleine Aktion zusammen mit den Crowd-Reportern.
Man kann also, wenn man noch mehr Content haben will und zwar dann bei den Crowd-Reportern
geschriebenen, bei uns ja nur zu hörenden Content, dann kann man so ein Kombi-Abo abschließen.
Das ist das vierte Paket bei Steady. Wer also daran Interesse hat und beide
Projekte unterstützen will oder kennenlernen will, kann das tun.
Wir sagen aber noch, was wir im Salon lesen.
Wir haben uns entschieden, uns einmal in diesen Kulturkampf Identitätspolitik,
all das zu wagen mit dem Buch Links nicht gleich woke von der Philosophin Susan
Naimann, das weit oben in verschiedenen Bestsellerlisten ist,
das sehr ernsthaft diskutiert wird, wie mir scheint.
Und wir sind gespannt darauf. Im Hansa Verlag auch diesmal nicht so lang, knapp 180 Seiten.
Und ich kann schon mal ein Buch ankündigen, das ich noch vorstellen will.
Das heißt, die Zukunft der Menschheit soll es uns weitergeben.
Das ist von dem Philosophen Tim Henning.
Also man kann auch Nein sagen.
Da ist das ein Buch, das auch in der Tradition der analytischen Philosophie
steht. Wir haben da ja mit MacAskill und Chalmers und so schon einiges kennengelernt.
Aber hier das scheint mir, ich habe das also noch nicht gelesen,
doch sehr viel interessanter, fundierter argumentiert zu sein.
Geht es auch wirklich mal so ganz konkret um Fragen.
Wie ist denn das mit diesem Antinatalismus? Was sind wir den zukünftigen Generationen schuldig?
Wie weit kann man es treiben?
Also das kann man auch in der Kürze machen, ja?
Man kann es auch in der Kürze machen. Das Buch ist also 150 Seiten lang.
Und vielleicht ist das, weil wir diese philosophische Strömung auch polemisch
verhandelt haben, weil man es auch musste, weil diese Bücher unseriös sind im
höchsten Maße. Hier zumindest ein ganz anderer Entwurf. Ich bin gespannt darauf.
Sehr gut. Ich weiß, dass ich noch mal in diese Mitte-Studie reingucke.
Die hat zwar in voller Länge auch 450 Seiten oder so.
Aber ich las so die Präampel, den Einstieg,
also gleich so richtig Textseite 1, und dacht mir, hm, krass,
ich wollte eigentlich nur kurz reingucken, aber ich könnte mir schon ganz schön
viele Anmerkungen machen, weil das doch ordentliche Sätze sind,
also nichts von Präampel-Prose oder so, sondern gleich all in.
Und ich dachte mir so, bei 450 Seiten, Also ich lese nicht alle 450 Seiten,
aber ich glaube, in den jeweiligen Kapiteln beginnen wurden noch mal kleine
Bomben platziert, diese Zahlen unterfüttern.
Ich bin selber sehr gespannt und habe ein bisschen Zeit zu lesen bis Mittwoch, wenn wir den aufnehmen.
Und dann gehen wir dem mal noch nach und den Rest mal schauen.
Einen schönen Monat.
Haut rein!